COMMITTEE ON THE JUDICIARY TO
MEET.
AND WE WILL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE IT BUT FIRST I WANT
TO INTRODUCE OUR NEWEST MEMBER.
SENATOR LENA GONZALEZ FROM LONG
BEACH WHO IS NOW JOINING US AND
AS A NEW MEMBER OF OUR ESTEEMED
CLUB WELCOME WELCOME WE'RE
DELIGHTED TO HAVE YOU HERE IN
THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
I THINK YOU'LL FIND IT VERY
INTERESTING.
AND AS A NON LAWYER -- DON'T IN
ANY WAY BE INTIMIDATED YOU
PROBABLY KNOW JUST AS MUCH AS
THE REST OF US.
AND WE'RE DELIGHTED TO TO HAVE
YOUR INPUT IN IN TO THIS
COMMITTEE AS WELL.
SHE WILL KEEP YES I A I SUSPECT
THAT'S TRUE.
DO YOU HAVE.
AND WE DO HAVE ENOUGH FOR A
QUORUM -- SO OF WILL GO AHEAD
AND CALL THE ROLL.
AGAIN WILL TRY TO GET ONE OF OUR
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES HERE IT'S
USUALLY.
OF WHAT WE DO BUT GIVEN THE TIME
AND THE FACT WE HAVE A PRETTY
ROBUST EACH AND WE'RE GOING TO
GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED.
OF MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL JACKSON.
JACKSON HERE BORDERS
[inaudible] TO RUSSELL.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HERE JONES.
MONNING.
MONNING HERE STERN.
TURN HERE ON BURKE YOUR NUMBER
HERE WHITE HOUSE HE BORDERS HERE.
ALL RIGHT WE DO HAVE A QUORUM
AND SHORTLY WILL HAVE OURS.
OTHER NEW MEMBER AND HOPEFULLY
SHOULD BE HERE SHORTLY AND I'D
BE HAPPY.
TO MAKE THAT INTRODUCTION OF HER
AT THE TIME.
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF BILLS ON THE PROPOSED
CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH ALL
IDENTIFY RIGHT NOW -- IF YOU ARE
HERE ON ANY THESE BILLS YOU'RE
WELCOME TO STAY BUT THEY WILL BE
ON CONSENT SO THERE WON'T BE ANY.
DISCUSSION ON THE ISSUES BECAUSE
THEY WILL OF HAD AGREEMENT FROM
BOTH SIDES.
THE FOLLOWING ITEMS ARE ON THAT
COULD PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDAR
FILE ITEM.
THREE AB FOR SIXTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN.
FILE ITEM FOR A. B. FIVE NINETY
SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON.
FILE ITEM SEVEN AB SIX SEVENTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI.
FILE ITEM EIGHT AB SEVEN FORTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO
GARCIA.
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE AB NINE
TWENTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA.
FILE NUMBER ELEVEN AB ELEVEN
SIXTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAUER.
KAHAN.
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
THIRTEEN AB THIRTEEN NINETY SIX
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE.
AND FILE ITEM FOURTEEN A. B.
FOURTEEN TWENTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON.
AND WITH THAT IS OUR MOTION.
TO PASS THE CONSENT FILE ALL
RIGHT THERE IS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR JACKSON HI
JACKSON AYE BORDERS.
OR DECIDE TO RUSSELL.
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I JONES.
MONNING.
MONEY AYE STERN.
STERN I AM BURKE.
ARMORED IOWA CASKEY.
ALL RIGHT THIS WE HAVE SIX VOTES
THERE WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND WE
WILL START OUR FIRST ITEM.
IS AB SEVENTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS -- I'D LIKE TO ASK
THAT FOR EACH MEASURE THERE BE
NO MORE THAN TWO MAIN WITNESSES
TWO MINUTES EACH.
IN SUPPORT.
A ON TO ALL THOSE OTHERS WHO
WISH.
TO INDICATE THEIR SUPPORT IF
THEY COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE
WE HAVE.
OVER HERE IN THE SIDE -- GIVE
THEIR NAME THEIR AFFILIATION AND
INDICATE THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE
ITEM SIMILARLY WE WILL HAVE TWO
MAIN WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH
IN OPPOSITION.
AND THEN INVITE ANY ADDITIONAL
ITEMS TO COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE GIVE THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND THEIR OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL WE DO ALSO ENTERTAIN.
A NEUTRAL POSITIONS WHICH YOU
CAN EXPRESS EITHER AFTER THE
SUPPORT.
OF OR THE OPPOSITION -- ERA WITH
THE SAME OF PROCESS GOING ON AND
WE WILL THEN OPEN THE ITEM UP
FOR DISCUSSION FROM THE DIET SO --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS YOU HAVE
THE FIRST ITEM THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- FIRST LET ME BEGIN.
BUT I'M BY CHAIRED BY THINKING --
YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE I
APPRECIATE THE WORK IN THE
ANALYSIS AND IDENTIFYING THE
ISSUES BUT ALSO.
THE ARTICLES THAT HAVE BEEN
WRITTEN ACROSS THE COUNTRY ABOUT
WHY THIS IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT
MEASURE SO THANK YOU FOR THAT
AND I APPRECIATE THE WORK ON THE
ANALYSIS.
AB SEVENTEEN ALSO KNOWN AS A
VOTER PROTECTION ACT WOULD
ADDRESS VOTER COERCION AND
PROTECT BALLOT INTEGRITY BY
PROHIBITING.
AN EMPLOYER FROM REQUIRING ARE
REQUESTING THAT AN EMPLOYEE
BRING THEIR VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT.
VOTERS HAVE A RIGHT TO CAST A
BALLOT -- WITHOUT THE FEAR OF
EMPLOYER INTIMIDATION AND THIS
IS A VERY STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL
AS YOU CAN TELL IT'S ONE PAGE.
AND WITH THAT MORE THAN HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS BUT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAY ABOUT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE ITEM
ANY WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT.
OF FILE ITEM ONE A. B..
SEVENTEEN ARE THERE WHEN ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE THE DYESS.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
BORCHERS ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
NOW [inaudible]
OKAY.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS JACKSON HI
JACKSON AYE BORDERS.
OR DECIDE TO RUSSELL GONZALEZ.
AND DOLLARS I'D JONES
[inaudible]
CORRECT.
JONES NO MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN.
STERN I AM BURKE.
NUMBER I WAKE HEALTHY. SIX ONE
FOUR EIGHT SIX TWO ONE WE WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND APPRECIATED
THE CONCISENESS IN THE BREVITY
WITH WINCH.
THAT BILL WAS HEARD THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
ALRIGHT WE NOW MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM TO AB THREE THIRTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
GABRIEL.
AND MY UNDERSTANDING IS THERE IS
NO OPPOSITION THAT HAS BEEN
REPORTED ON THIS BILL EITHER
[inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
AFTERNOON THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TODAY 2% AB
THREE THIRTY WHICH WILL EXPAND
FUNDING FOR THE HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL.
SARGENT SHRIVER CIVIL COUNCIL
ACT PROGRAMS WHICH WERE
ESTABLISHED IN TWO THOUSAND NINE
WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT UNDER
GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER.
THESE PROGRAMS PROVIDE VITAL
LEGAL REPRESENTATION TO LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS IN
POTENTIALLY LIFE CHANGING LOOK
CIVIL LEGAL MATTERS.
INVOLVING BASIC HUMAN NEEDS AND
HELP TO ENSURE THAT OTHERWISE ON
REPRESENTED PARTIES HAVE
MEANINGFUL ACCESS TO JUSTICE IN
THE MOST PROFOUND AND HIGH
STAKES CASES.
INCLUDING CHILD CUSTODY AND
HOUSING RELATED MATTERS.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL RELEASED AN
INDEPENDENT EVALUATION OF THE
PILOT PROGRAMS CONDUCTED BY AN
OUTSIDE RESEARCH FIRM.
THE STUDY FOUND THAT SHOULD THE
SHRIVER PILOT PROJECTS IMPROVED
OUTCOMES FOR LITIGANTS INCREASE
SETTLEMENTS REDUCE COURT COSTS
AND ENABLE JUDICIAL SYSTEM TO
PROCESS CASES MORE FAIRLY AND
EFFICIENTLY.
AB THREE THIRTY SIX TO EXPAND
THE REACH OF THESE HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS BY MODESTLY
INCREASING THE FILING FEES THAT
FUND THE PROGRAM AND MAKING
MINOR ELIGIBILITY CHANGES
SUGGESTED BY THE EVALUATION.
IN SO DOING AB THREE THIRTY WILL
HELP MORE PHONE NUMBER
CALIFORNIANS SECURE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE SAVE TAXPAYER RESOURCES
IMPROVE THE EFFICIENCY AND
FAIRNESS OF OUR JUDICIAL SYSTEM.
AND BUILD UPON A PROGRAM THAT
HAS PROVEN EFFECTIVE BY RIGOROUS
INDEPENDENT EVALUATION AND
ANALYSIS. FOR THESE REASONS AB
THREE THIRTY ENJOYED STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE
ASSEMBLY HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
HAS BEEN ENDORSED BY A BROAD
ALLIANCE OF LEGAL SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS AND SPECIALISTS
AND THE LOS ANGELES TIMES
EDITORIAL BOARD.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE THIRTY IS
SELENA COUPLED WITH THE LEGAL
AID ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
AND SKIP KOENIG WITH THE
NEIGHBORHOOD LEGAL SERVICES OF
LA COUNTY.
THANK YOU AND WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST HER AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
WITNESSES -- TWO MINUTES EACH.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS SKIP CANTICUM DIRECTOR POLICY
ADVOCACY NEIGHBORHOOD LEGAL
SERVICES VALLEY COUNTY.
WE'RE ALL PAINFULLY AWARE OF THE
GROWING HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS THROUGHOUT THE STATE IN
LA WE SAW ARE HOMELESS
POPULATION INCREASED BY 16% THIS
PAST YEAR WITHIN THE CITY AND
12% IN THE COUNTY.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT WE'VE
HOUSED OVER TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
PEOPLE LAST YEAR.
BECAUSE WE KNOW WE CAN'T BUILD
OUR WAY OUT OF THE CRISIS WE
HAVE TO ATTACK IT FROM ALL
ANGLES IN THE SHRIVER CIVIL
COUNCIL ACT AS ONE OF THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAYS. TO STEM THE
INFLOW INTO HOMELESSNESS BY
WORKING TO KEEP.
KEEP PEOPLE IN THEIR EXISTING
HOMES.
THE SHRIVER PROGRAM PROVIDES
LEGAL SERVICES IN CRITICAL AREAS
AFFECTING BASIC HUMAN NEEDS SUCH
AS HOUSING CHILD CUSTODY
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
GUARDIANSHIP.
THE DRIVER PROGRAM THAT AN LS
ADMINISTERS FOCUSES ON EVICTION
CASES OUT OF THE STANLEY MOSS
CAUGHT HALF COURT HOUSE IN LA.
WHICH IS THE HIGHEST VOLUME
EVICTION CASES IN THE LARGEST
COUNTY IN THE COUNTRY.
AS THE LEAD AGENCY FOR THE
DRIVER HOUSING PROJECT WE SEE
POWER IMBALANCE AN EVICTION
CASES EVERY DAY OR ONLY 10% OF
TENANTS ARE CURRENTLY
REPRESENTED AS COMPARED 290% OF
LANDLORDS.
THROUGH THE SUCCESS OF THE
STRIVE A PROGRAM WE SEEN THAT
70% OF TENANTS REPRESENTED BY
COUNSEL HAVE A CHANCE OF
AVOIDING HOMELESSNESS.
AS AN EXAMPLE OF THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF COUNSEL ONE OF
OUR CLIENTS A SINGLE MOTHER
CARING FOR A DAUGHTER AND AN
ARTISTIC GRANDSON.
LIVED IN A RENT CONTROLLED UNIT
FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
AS A RESULT OF A CASCADE OF
MISFORTUNE SHE SUFFERED A STROKE
LOST HER JOB AND FELL BEHIND IN
A RENT.
THE STRIVE RETURNEES OBTAINED.
OF FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO PAY
HER BACK RENT AND GO SHE IS A
SETTLEMENT SO THAT SHE AND HER
FAMILY WERE ABLE TO REMAIN IN
THEIR HOME.
AND THEIR RENT CONTROL TENDENCY
WAS REINSTATED IN ULL WITHOUT
RISK LEGAL REPRESENTATION YOU
CAN IMAGINE THE DEVASTATION OF
FICTION IMPOSSIBLE HOMELESSNESS
WOULD HAVE HAD ON OUR CLIENT.
ALTHOUGH WE'VE HOUSE MORE WE'RE
LOSING THE BATTLE BECAUSE MORE
PEOPLE ARE FALLING INTO
HOMELESSNESS AS A RESULT OF A
FICTION WE HAVE TO SHUT OFF THE
SPIGOT.
WE KNOW KEEPING PEOPLE HOUSES
ONE OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAYS
TO COMBAT HOMELESSNESS AND
PROVIDING COUNSEL TO THOSE WHO
CAN AFFORD IS ONE OF THE BEST
WAYS TO ACHIEVE THAT GOAL.
IN LA 63% REPORTED FALLING
FALLING INTO HOMELESSNESS FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WITH 53% CITING
FINANCIAL REASONS AS THE BECAUSE
THE SHRIVER PROGRAM HAS PROVEN
TO BE AN EFFECTIVE WAY TO KEEP
PEOPLE HOUSED WITHIN INCREASE OF
FUNDING WE CAN PROVIDE LEGAL
SERVICES TO MORE LOW INCOME AND
UNDERSERVED.
FAMILIES AND HELPS THEM THE TIDE
OF DISPLACEMENT AND HOMELESSNESS
THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS TWO
MINUTES PLEASE GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M SELLING A COUPLE AN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE LEGAL
AID ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
AND OUR ORGANIZATION WAS
ACTUALLY REALLY INSTRUMENTAL IN
PASSING THE REGIONAL A. B. FIVE
NINETY SO OUR ORGANIZATION HAS
BEEN CONTINUE TO BE INVOLVED IN
THIS RIDER PROJECTS.
INCLUDING FOR THE BEGINNING
COORDINATING PROJECTS AND
HELPING TO TRAIN THE NEW CORPS
OF HOUSING ATTORNEYS -- BUT I
PERSONALLY AM INVOLVED IN A
DIFFERENT WAY I SERVE ON THE
SCHREIBER SELECTION COMMITTEE SO
I REVIEW APPLICANTS FOR FOR NEW
GRANTS AS THEY COME IN.
AND I HAVE TO SAY THAT WE CEASE
COURSE SEVERAL MILLION DOLLARS
MORE IN REQUEST FOR FUNDING THAT
WE WERE ABLE TO PUSH OUT SO --
WE SUPPORT EIGHTY THREE THIRTY
BECAUSE THIS ACTUAL MAKE US BE
ABLE TO APPROVE MORE GRANT
APPLICATIONS -- MY ORGANIZATION
SUPPORTS INCREASED FUNDING FOR
LEGAL AID OF COURSE -- AND YOUR
THROUGH EQUAL ACCESS FUND AND
OTHER SOURCES OF FUNDING BUT
WHAT IS REALLY INTERESTING ABOUT
THE SCHREIBER PILOT PROJECTS AS
THE EVALUATION PIECE.
BECAUSE PROGRAMS WERE BUILT FROM
THE BEGINNING TO HAVE EVALUATION
IS A CORE COMPONENT THEY'RE ABLE
TO TEST OUT -- DIFFERENT
INTERVENTIONS TO TESTING OUT
MEDIATION AND OTHER OTHER
INTERVENTIONS TO SEE WHAT THAT
MEANS AFTER THE CASE IS CLOSED.
AND THE EVALUATORS ARE ABLE TO
FOLLOW UP WITH CLIENTS AFTER THE
FACT TO SEE WHAT ACTUALLY
CHANGES IN THAT PERSON'S LIFE.
AND SO WE HAVE A LOT OF OUTCOME
DATA WHICH YOU DON'T TPICALLY
GET FROM LEGAL AID ORGANIZATIONS
BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT
HAPPENS TO A CLIENT SIX MONTHS
LATER -- BECAUSE OF THE THE
EVALUATION PIECE WE HAVE A
REALLY AMAZING CLIENT STRIES
ARE GOING TO SHARE VERY BRIEFLY
SOME EXAMPLES FROM LEGAL AID
FOUNDATION SANTA BARBARA COUNTY
WHO'S WHO OF THE SHARED
PERMISSION.
TO GIVE ME PERMISSION TO SHARE
THE STORY -- DID THAT THIS IS A
REALLY GREAT EXAMPLE OF HOW
SHRIVER HELPS PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
TRUE LIFE CRISES.
AND IN ONE EXAMPLE THERE WAS A
WOMAN WHO IS PREGNANT WITH TWINS
AND SHE PASSED AWAY WHILE
PREGNANT AND THE TWINSWERE
DELIVERED POSTMORTEM AND THE
HOSPITAL RUSH THEM TO THE
HOSPITAL SEVERAL HOURS AWAY AND
THE FAMILY WAS UNABLE TO GET ANY
INFORMATION.
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED TO THESE
BABIES THEY DIDN'T KNOW THE
HEALTH CONSEQUENCES YOU KNOW HOW
THEY WERE DOING AND THE HOSPITAL
WOULDN'T GIVE THEM ANY
INFORMATION AND SO HOW LEGALLY
FOUNDATIONS IN A PROPER STEPPED
IN AS THEY WERE ABLE TO GET.
IT INITIALLY JUST GET
INFORMATION ON THAT THE THE
STATUS OF THE CHILDREN AND HELP
THE FAMILY GET A TEMPORARY
GUARDIANSHIP SO COULD HAVE
GUARDIANSHIP OVER THE INFANTS.
AND YOU WOULDN'T THINK THAT THIS
IS A LEGAL A PROBLEM BUT LEGALLY
STEPS IN WHEN THERE'S A CRISIS
AND THERE IS A LEGAL HOOK
THERE'S ALL THESE WAYS THAT
GUARDIAN SHIPS AND HOUSING.
ATTORNEYS CAN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
ENTHUSIASM AS WELL AS YOUR
TESTIMONY ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS ITEM.
IF YOU WOULD JUST STEP FORWARD
TO THE MICROPHONE WITH YOUR NAME
AND AFFILIATION PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON AVI LEVY ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CERTIFIED FAMILY LAW SPECIALIST
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE DíAS I WANT TO THANK YOU
FIRST OF ALL.
FOR BRINGING THIS MEASURE WE
TALKED ABOUT IF THERE'S NY
TWEAKING TO BE DONE AT ANY POINT --
COUPLE THINGS IN HERE THAT I
UNDERSTAND YOU YOU WOULD BE
RECEPTIVE TO BUT THEY'RE NOT
REALLY -- INTEGRAL TO THE TO THE
VALUE OF THIS BILL.
AND I THINK IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THAT PEOPLE HAVE THAT
ACCESS TO JUSTICE WHICH YOU
REPRESENT IN WHICH IS A PRIORITY
SO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR GOOD WORK
WITH THE WITH THE FOUNDATION AND
THE ALL RIGHT I CERTAINLY YEAH I
THINK THIS IS.
IMPORTANT IN HELPING OUR LOWER
INCOME FOLKS -- OBTAIN JUSTICE
OF THANK YOU FOR THE BILL AND
ARE THERE ANY OTHER COMMENTS-SENATOR STERN.
EGGMAN CHAIR.
I DON'T APPLY THE AUTHOR AND
THOSE OUT THERE DOING THE WORK I
KNOW YOU DO THIS WORK YOURSELF --
TO I HAD THE CHANCE TO BE A
LEGAL AID INVESTIGATOR ACTUALLY
BEFORE LAW SCHOOL.
AND MY ONLY CONCERN WITH HIS
MEASURES JUST NOT ENOUGH.
RIGHT I THINK IT'S SO GOOD THAT
YOU'RE GONNA MAKE THIS IMPACT
BUT DO YOU CAN YOU GIVE US A
SENSE OF EVEN IF WE GET THIS
DONE.
HOW HOW BIG IS THIS CIVIL GIDEON
GAP STILL GOING TO BE BECAUSE
EVERY PERSON WE LEAVE BEHIND AND
TO BECOME A HUGE COST IN THE
SYSTEM AS IT IS RIGHT I MEAN? TO
ME FALLS AND HOMELESSNESS IS
GOING TO COST US.
SO MUCH MORE IN THE BACK AND
SAID DO YOU HAVE A SNSE OF HOW
HOW MUCH WE CAN BITE INTO THE
PROBLEM HERE AND YEAH WOMAN YEAH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR FOR
YOUR COMMENTS ARE FOR YOUR OWN
PERSONAL PERSONAL RECORD ON THIS
I THINK.
YOU KNOW FOR ME THIS REPRESENTS.
A LOT OF HOW I THINK POLICY
MAKING SHOULD BE DONE WHICH IS
WE DID A PILOT PROGRAM THERE WAS
AN A RIGOROUS EVALUATION AND
ANALYSIS IT.
REPORTED REALLY GOOD OUTCOMES
ACROSS THE BOARD BOTH FOR THE
FOLKS WHO ARE REPRESENTED AT THE
LITIGANTS THEMSELVES AND ALSO
FOR THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM WE'RE
NOT GONNA MOVE HOPEFULLY TO
DRAMATICALLY EXPAND THE PROGRAM
BUT WE'RE GOING TO MAINTAIN THAT
RIGOROUS EVALUATION ANALYSIS AND
SO HOPEFULLY.
pYEARS FROM NOW THAT THIS ISN'T
SUFFICIENT TO GET THE JOB DONE
WE CAN COME BACK AND CONTINUE TO
MAKE TWEAKS TO THE PROGRAM SO.
WE CERTAINLY HAVE OUR EYE ON
HELPING AS MANY FOLKS AS
POSSIBLE AND MAKING SURE THAT
ACCESS TO JUSTICE IS AVAILABLE
TO EVERYBODY IN THE STATE
WITHOUT REGARD TO WEALTH -- BUT
WE WANT TO DO THIS IN A WAY THAT
IS -- THOUGHTFUL AND DELIBERATE
OF AND BASED ON EVIDENCE AND
RESEARCH AND DATA ABSOLUTELY
WHAT IF THERE IS A TWO WEEK OR
REMAIN IN THE FUTURE PLEASE
CONSIDER ADDING ME AS A CO
AUTHOR LOVES PORCH ON THIS
EFFORT AND YEAH I APPRECIATE THE
METRICS DRIVEN APPROACH TO
BECAUSE I THINK.
THE OUTCOMES ARE THERE RIGHT I
MEAN THE DATE HAS BEEN GIVEN TO
THANK FOR THE THOUGHTFUL
ANALYSIS ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR MONNING.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I TO WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD -- AS YOUR MIND THIS OUR
FORMER COLLEAGUE.
NO CITY ATTORNEY FEWER.
CARRIED I THINK THE ORIGINAL
VERSION OF THIS.
I'D LIKE THE REFERENCE TO THE
CIVIL GIDEON -- BUT MY QUESTION
GOES KIND OF THE SAME AREAS MY
COLLEAGUE HERE.
IN ALSO.
I ALL TO FIND HELP CAN I ALSO
FUNDS BE USED TO SUPPORT ON THE
AISLE TO FUNDS BEING TRUST FUNDS
IN ATTORNEY TRUST ACCOUNTS THE
THE INTEREST EARNS GOES.
TO LEGAL AID GROUPS CAN HAD IS
THAT MONEY -- CAN IT BE USED TO
SUPPORT THIS.
THIS WORK.
OR IS THAT MORE GENERAL PROGRAM
SUPPORT MONEY.
EITHER -- WELL SENATOR THE AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION THE
I. ALL TO FUNDS DOES DOES GO TO
SERVE LEGAL AID IN GENERAL AND
SO FOR INSTANCE OUR ORGANIZATION
NEIGHBORS LEGAL SERVICES VALLEY
COUNTY -- GET A GOOD CHUNK OF
OUR BUDGET COMES FROM THE AYE
ALL TO FUNDS IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY -- WE CAN'T USE IT
FOR THE TREVOR PROJECT SO WE USE
IT FOR OTHER SERVICES THAT WE
PROVIDE A LOT OF THEM INCLUDE --
HOUSING CASES -- AS WELL AS
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THAT -- DOVE
TAILING TO WHAT THE DRIVER
PROGRAM DOES BUT IT'S A
DIFFERENT SET OF LAWYERS IT'S A
DIFFERENT.
BUCKET OUT OF WHICH WE GET THE
FUNDS THE FUNDING FOR THIS BANK
YOU APPRECIATE THE CLARIFICATION
AND DID YOU HAVE SOMETHING
FURTHER JUST ALLEGED ADDITIONAL
ANSWER IS I'LL TO SPEND SOME OF
ALL THE TILE OF OVER THE PAST
SEVRAL DECADES THERE'S BEEN UPS
AND DOWNS AND WAY UPS AND THEN.
CRASHES TO YOUR LESS THAN FOUR
MILLION A YEAR AND SO WHAT THAT
MEANS IS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
STEPPED IN A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
WAYS TO PROVIDE OTHER -- STABLE
FUNDING FOR LEGAL AID AND
SHRIVER'S ONE OF THOSE RESPONSES
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND NINE
BUT THERE ARE OTHER THINGS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE'S DONE INCLUDING
INCREASING CO ACCESS FUNDS.
AS STABILIZE THE FUNDING BECAUSE
IT DOES I'LL TO DISCUSS THIS
THANK YOU -- IN AGAIN I THINK.
THE PARALLEL IS.
YOU THE RIGHT TO HELP ACCESS WE
WE ESTABLISH A RIGHT BUT THEN WE
LOOK AT IMPLEMENTATION AND
DEPENDS ON ACCESS AND RURAL
AREAS ACCESS TO POOR PEOPLE
ACCESS TO UNDOCUMENTED.
IN IN THE LEGAL ARENA WE CAN
ESTABLISH CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS
BUT THEY DON'T GET FULLY
REALIZED PARTICULARLY THOSE THAT
DON'T HAVE.
THE RIGHT TO REPRESENTATION SO.
THANK YOU FOR THE WORK I'D BE
GLAD TO MOVE THE BILL AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU
CENTER MONEY.
US SENATOR BOARD JUST.
I TOO WOULD LIKE TO COMMEND --
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD -- IT JUST SO HAPPENS
THAT IN MY PREVIOUS CAPACITY AS
A SUPERVISOR.
WE HAD -- A NUMBER OF
DISCUSSIONS ON WITH THE OUR
COLLEAGUES IN THE JUDICIARY ON
THE COSTS THAT -- ARE BEING --
DEVELOPED WITH THE VARIOUS FEES
AND WHATNOT AND I THINK.
I BELIEVE MY AREA WILL BENEFIT
FOR THIS PROGRAM.
THE CHALLENGE THOUGH IS THAT THE
DOLLARS ATTACHED TO IT -- THE
COMING FROM INDIVIDUALS THAT MAY
NOT INITIALLY DRIVE TO BENEFIT
FROM IT SO I THINK.
YOU'RE FINDING IN A SITUATION
WHERE I IN MY BACKYARD I HAD
ALREADY HAD THIS DEBATE ON HOW
TO GET COSTS LOWER -- WITHIN THE
FILING FEES -- EVEN THOUGH WE'RE
AND DERIVE A HUGE BUT IT
BENEFITS SO I'M GONNA LAY OFF
BUT I DO COMMEND YOU I THINK
THIS WILL HAVE SOME HELPFUL --
CONTRIBUTIONS ON TO THOSE THE IN
THE SO I COMMEND YOU FOR YOUR
WORK.
PARDEE COURSE NOTING THAT MONEY
DOESN'T GROW ON TREES IT HAS TO
COME FROM SOMEWHERE -- ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU JUST
WANT TO THANK THE THE SENATORS
FOR THEIR IF THEY'RE THOUGHTFUL
FEEDBACK AND COMMENTS JUST TO
YOUR POINTS IN A MINING I DID
WANT TO NOTE THAT. ONE OF THE
TWO WEEKS WE MAKE IN THIS BILL
AS WE AUTHORIZE THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL TO ACCEPT VOLUNTARY
DONATIONS FROM PUBLIC OR PRIVATE
ENTITIES.
WE'VE HAD SOME -- THOUGHTFUL
CONVERSATIONS WITH FOLKS IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR WHO ARE OF THE
HAVE SEEN THE EVIDENCE IN THE
RESEARCH ON THIS PROGRAM AND HOW
EFFECTIVE IT'S BEEN IN MIKE
THEMSELVES WANT.
TO FIND A WAY TO STEP UP AND
CONTRIBUTE SO WE ARE TRYING TO
THINK YOU KNOW WITH RESPECT TO
SENATOR BOARD DISS COMMENTS
ABOUT.
OUR THEIR STREAMS OF FINDING OUT
THERE THAT WE CAN USE TO SUPPORT
THIS VERY.
WORTHY WORK -- AND AND ALSO THE
OTHER WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE AND
WITH THAT WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU AND I DID NOTE IN AN
ARTICLE IN TODAY'S PAPER.
THE CHANGES THAT WERE MADE IN
THE FEDERAL TAX LAW HAVE SERVED
TO DISCOURAGE CHARITABLE
CONTRIBUTIONS WHICH IS
UNFORTUNATE AND I HOPE AT SOME
POINT WE CAN TURN THAT AROUND SO.
PROGRAMS LIKE THIS CAN BENEFIT
FROM THE GENEROSITY OF THOSE WHO
HAVE.
OF THE MONEY TO GIVE SO WITH
THAT WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
MONNING IT IS A MOTION TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO AB THREE
THIRTY JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE BORDERS [inaudible]
TO RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I'D JONES [inaudible]
MONNING.
I STERN.
STERN I AM BURKE.
NUMBER TO IOWA KELSEY.
BUT SIX SIX TWO ZERO WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BRINGING THE BILL
FORWARD AND YOUR TESTIMONY AS
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I.
N. BEFORE OUR NEXT.
PRESENTATION I WANT TO WELCOME
MORE.
A SECOND NEWEST MEMBER OR I
GUESS SO AMONG OUR TWO NEWEST
MEMBERS A SENATOR MARIA ELENA TO
RISE SO AND I THINK THAT WAS AN
APPROPRIATE FIRST VOTE FOR YOU
IN AN AREA THAT I KNOW YOU FEEL
VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT AND WE'RE
DELIGHTED TO HAVE YOU JOIN US
THANK.
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SO ARE WITH THAT WILL GO TO FILE
ITEM FIVE WHICH IS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOLIES A. B..
SIX TWENTY GOOD AFTERNOON.
NICE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT -- AGAIN -- THIS IS AN
ITEM THAT.
OF HIS NO.
KNOWN OPPOSITION AND FOR WHICH
NO AMENDMENTS WERE REQUEST SO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO GO AHEAD AND
PROCEED YEAH THERE I DO.
SENATE MEMBER KEN COOLEY
PRESENTED AB SIX TWENTY DEALING
WITH SUDDEN LOST MY DEATH IN
CHILDHOOD.
THERE WAS A VERY TECHNICAL MEN.
THAT AFTER WE LEFT PUBLIC SAFETY
PUBLIC SAFETY STAFF.
URGED UPON ME FIND REFINE AND
CHANGING THE WORD ARTICLES
APPEARS IN SUBSECTION A OF A
GIVEN SECTION TO SECTION ANNUAL
EXCEPT I AM I WILL UNDERTAKE
THAT.
EITHER DO IT HERE ACTUALLY WAS
THINKING I MIGHT DO IN YOUR IN
THE FLOOR.
BUT AS BY AGREEMENT WITH THE
POLICY WHEN WHICH IS TO ACCEPT
THAT IS AN AUTHORS AMENDMENT AND
AND TEAR IS OPPOSITION MY
APOLOGIES WE DO HAVE OPPOSITION
ON THIS BILL -- AND IT'S STATED
IN THE ANALYSIS MY MY APOLOGIES
FOLKS SO IF YOU'D LIKE TO GO
AHEAD.
THIS IS -- AB.
SIX TWENTY SORRY ON THE ISSUE OF
OPPOSITION I DO WANT TO SAY THAT
WITH THIS CHANGE IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING.
THAT THE CALIFORNIA STATE COURT
ASSOCIATION HAS TO INDICATE THEY
WILL REMOVE THEIR OPPOSITION SO
THIS ONE WORD CHANGE WAS
IMPORTANT OF THEM -- AND WE
THINK A SUMMER ACTION FOR THE
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION BUT
HAVE NOT HEARD THAT.
WILL PERHAPS THEY'RE HERE TODAY
TO EXPRESS THEIR POSITION THAT
WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL.
VERY GOOD.
SO THIS MEASURE RELATES TO A
TOPIC KNOWN AS SUDDEN
UNEXPLAINED DEATH IN CHILDHOOD.
AND A TOUCH THE OF WINCHELL
FAMILY OF MY DISTRICT SONYA
WINCHELL'S HERE.
LOST HER SON NIKO.
A CAME HOME ONE NIGHT ELEVEN
O'CLOCK AT NIGHT WENT TO BED.
ANA AND THE NEXT MORNING
SLEEPING IN A WIN AND A ROUSING
WHEN HE PASSED AWAY IN THE NIGHT.
A COMPLETE MYSTERY AS TO WHAT
WENT ON THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
THAT ANY CIRCUMSTANCE A PERSON'S
INFORMED OF THE ADVISABILITY.
PARTING TISSUE SAMPLES WHICH IS
SIMILAR TO WHAT IS DONE WITH OF
SIDS SUDDEN EXPLAIN DEATH IN
CHILDHOOD.
I WILL NOTE THAT THE SCIENCE OF
GENETICS HAS GROWN BY LEAPS AND
BOUNDS SINCE THE SAID STATUE WAS
ADOPTED.
AND WAS SEEM LIKE A GOOD IDEA IN
THOSE DAYS WHEN SO LITTLE IS
KNOWN ABOUT GENETICS.
A TODAY WE'RE JOINED BY DOCTOR.
TEST CAN OF WHO IS A GENETICIST
WHOSE ASSIST THE WINCHELL FAMILY
SO SHE'LL BE OFFERING.
TESTIMONY ANA [inaudible]
SO.
IT IS A VERY RARE OCCURRENCE
SUDDEN EXPAND DEATH IN CHILDHOOD --
AND IT'S HAS REPORTED INCIDENTS
OF ONLY ONE POINT TWO DEATHS PER
HUNDRED THOUSAND CHILDREN.
VERY VERY SMALL.
ARE CURRENTLY IN ANY CASE WERE
AN INFANT ON THE AGE OF TWELVE
MOST.
IN THE SUSPECTED CAUSE OF JESS'S
SIDS SUDDEN.
INFANT DEATH SYNDROME.
EXISTING LAW REQUIRES THE CORNER
NOTIFY THE CHILD'S PARENTS THE
IMPORTS OF TAKING TISSUE SAMPLES
FOR FURTHER INVESTIGATION.
THAT DOES NOT APPLY TO SUDDEN
UNEXPLAINED DEATH IN CHILDHOOD.
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN THE FELLOW
GOVERNOR SHE PASSED A STATUTE IN
THIS AREA.
SUDDEN INFANT DEATH DID AND HAS
AN AWARENESS ACT. TO INCREASE
AWARENESS AND PROMOTE BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE CAUSES FOR
KIDS OLDER THAN TWELVE MONTHS.
AND SO ACTUALLY THIS URGING
PARENTS TO GET THIS TISSUE
SAMPLE ALIGNS WITH THAT FEDERAL
ENACTMENT TO GET BETTER
INFORMATION -- SO AB SEARCH
TWENTY DEFIES ON THE FOR IN
DEPTH IN CHILDHOOD A STATUTE.
REQUIRES CORNERS AND FOR THE
PARENTS OF A CHILD WHO DIES IN
THESE CIRCUMSTANCES ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF TAKING TISSUE
SAMPLES.
AND AS I SAY WITH THE CEMENT BUT
THERE WAS A QUESTION IN THE
PRIOR COMMITTEE OF WHETHER THE
BILL COULD MANDATE.
THAT SUDDEN INFANT DEATH IN
CHILDHOOD BE ENTERED AS A CAUSE
OF DEATH ON A TEST FOR TO FORGET.
IT'S NOT OUR BELIEF THAT THE
BILL EVEN AS INTRODUCED WOULD
PROVIDE FOR THAT.
AND WITH THIS.
CHANGE THAT WE ARE OFFERING
TODAY THE IT COMPLETELY
ELIMINATES ACT CONCERNED.
SO HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IS SONYA WINCHELL --
AND THEN DOCTOR TESCO SO -- MS
WINCHELL WANT TO OPEN UP THANK
YOU AND IF YOU WOULD TWO MINUTES
FOR EACH WITNESS THANK YOU
MEMORY THIS AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TO YOU ABOUT MY FIRST
BORN SON MICHAEL WINCHELL AND
SUDDEN UNEXPLAINED DEATH IN
CHILDHOOD OTHERWISE KNOWN AS AS
YOU DO SEE.
SUNDAY OCTOBER TWENTY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE WAS SUPPOSED TO
BE JUST ANOTHER DAY FOR NICO
FIFTEEN YEAR OLD SOPHOMORE RIO
AMERICANO HIGH SCHOOL AND
DEVOTED JAZZ GITARIST HIS MOUTH
THE NIGHT BEFORE AT ONE OF THE
MANY FALL BND FUNDRAISING
PARTIES AND SUNDAY MORNING HE
WAS TO VOLUNTEER AT THE BAND.
CAR WASH NICO NEVER MADE IT
BECAUSE SOMETIME BETWEEN FOUR
AND FIVE AM HE DIED IN HIS SLEEP.
INSTEAD OF A JOYOUS DAY HELPING
US BAND COMMUNITY OUR HOME
BECAME A CRIME SCENE WITH FIRST
RESPONDERS INVESTIGATING A
QUESTIONING OUR FAMILY.
THE CHAPLAINS A RIDE WITHOUT ANY
HELPFUL ADVICE EXCEPT TO DRINK
WATER.
THE CORNER REMOVED HIS COLD
PURPLE TINGE BODY AS HIS FATHER
TWELVE YEAR OLD BROTHER AND I
SAT SHOCKED IN NUMBING SILENCE.
WE WE WERE LEFT WITH NO IDEAS
HOW A HAPPY HEALTHY SIX FOOT
TALL TEENAGER COULD JUST DYING
TO SLEEP.
I'M SORRY IS FIFTEEN HE ALMOST
WAS EIGHT DAYS BEFORE SIXTEENTH
BIRTHDAY.
THIS ONLY HAPPENS TO INFANTS WE
ARE TOLD SINCE WE HAVE NO FAMILY
HISTORY OF AS YOU DC OR HAD EVER
HEARD OF IT WE WERE COMPLETELY
UNAWARE OF HOW TO PROCEED.
THANKFULLY A FRIEND WHO'S A
FORENSIC PATHOLOGIST IMMEDIATELY
CALLED TO INFORM US ABOUT S. UTC.
HE TOLD US AT THE CORNER DOES
NOT HARVEST IN A RICH TO ISSUE
AND THAT WE NEED THAT FOR
FURTHER INVESTIGATION
NONE OF THIS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT INFORMATION CAME FROM
THE FIRST RESPONDERS.
IN CALIFORNIA MOST FAMILIES WHO
ARE VICTIMS OF ISSUE YOU SEE ARE
LEFT WITHOUT ANY ABILITY TO FOR
THE INVESTIGATION OF THEIR
CHILD'S DEATH.
THERE IS AN INCREDIBLY SHORT
TIME PERIOD TO COLLECT IMPORTANT
DATA FOR S. UT RESEARCHERS.
BECAUSE OUR FRIEND INTERVENE WE
CONTACTED THE CORNER IN TIME
PARTITION ORGAN RETENTION AND
WERE ABLE TO SUPPLY S. UT
RESEARCHERS AT BOSTON CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL VALUABLE DNA
INFORMATION AS WELL AS ORGANS
FOR RESEARCH.
MOST FAMILIES BERRIER CREMATE
THIS INFORMATION WITH THEIR
CHILD AND ARE LEFT TO LIBERALIZE
NEVER KNOWING WHY ARE HOW
THEY'RE HEALTHY CHILD DIED OR
THIS WILL HAPPEN TO ANY OF THE
SURVIVORS OUR FUTURE SIBLINGS.
WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT THE FOR
EVENTUALLY VERSUS PONDERS THE
MOST ESSENTIAL TEAM ADVISED
BEREAVED FAMILIES AND COLLECT
IMPORTANT DATA FOR S. UTC
RESEARCH WHICH IS SUPPORTED BY
THE NATIONAL CORNERS ASSOCIATION.
THE HARVESTING OF DNA TISSUES
CURRENTLY DONE FOR INFANTS UNDER
AGE ONE WHY DON'T CHILDREN OVER
AGE ONE NOT MERIT THE SAME
CONSIDERATION WITH THE PASSING
OF NICO'S BILL AB
SIX TWENTY YOU HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE
IN THE LIVES OF ALL CHILDREN BY
EATING RESEARCHERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE.
DOCTOR TELLS CAM THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BY.
I AM I AM MAD AFTER TESTS CON
I'M A MEDICAL GENETICIST IT AT
KAISER PERMANENTE HEY.
AND I'VE BEEN IN THIS PRACTICE
ABOUT OVER TWENTY YEARS AND
GENETICS DEFINITELY HAS IN -- IN
IMPROVED AS A LOT OF WE SEE A
LOT OF RARE DISORDERS AND MORE
MORE THESE RARE DISORDERS WORSE
HOLDING SOLVING WITH THE
ADVANCEMENTS IN THE GENOMICS
FIELD.
UNFORTUNATELY ONE OF THE
REFERRALS WE GET IS A FAMILY
HISTORY OF SUDDEN UNEXPLAINED
DEATH IS WELL IT'S IT'S ACTUALLY
NOT AN UNCOMMON REFERRAL WE WILL
GET.
THAT OLD WENDELL THE DUST
SETTLED THAT IS SUDDENLY THAT WE
GET THIS REFERRAL FAMILY WANTS
TO MEET TO FIND OUT IF.
WHY THIS HAPPENED AND WILL IT
HAPPEN AGAIN I THE FIRST THING
WE ASK IS WELL IS THERE A TISSUE
SAMPLE OR DNA AVAILABLE ON THE
DISEASE?
BECAUSE THAT'S OUR INDEX CASE
THAT WILL BE BASS OUR ANA.
MIDDLE OUR GENETIC COUNSELING.
UNFORTUNATELY MOST OF THE TIME.
NOTHING IS AVAILABLE OF ONLY A
FEW TIMES I HAD TO RUSH TO THE
CORONER'S OFFICE AND BEG FOR
TISSUES BECAUSE THAT WILL BE
VERY ON CRUCIAL -- THEY'RE A
CITY SIX TO CHANGE.
THAT 30% ABOUT 30% OF THE ON
EXPLAINS SUDDEN DEATH SAW THE
AUTOPSY COMES BACK THAT YOU
DON'T YOU CAN YOU DON'T HAVE AN
ANSWER THERE'S NO.
EXPLANATION WHY THIS HAPPENED A
SO THEIR DIAGNOSES SOUTHERN
UNEXPLAINED DEATH.
OF NOW WITH THE ADVANCEMENTS IN
THE GENOMICS FIELD THESE CASES
THE BERRIES PER PAPER BUT 2230%
OF THE TIME.
THESE UNEXPLAINED DEATHS ARE
BEING EXPLAINED BY MOLECULAR
TECHNOLOGIES.
BURGER THANK YOU DOCTOR YOUR
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS.
ITEM.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY WITNESSES IN -- JOYFUL
NEUTRALITY.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NONE OF WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE DíAS --
CENTER BORCHARD SHOWS INQUIRED
AND I BELIEVE FROM PRIOR HEARING.
RIGHT NOW THE CORONER'S UNDER NO
OBLIGATION TO TAKE THIS TISSUE
SAMPLE THAT'S CORRECT -- BUT DO
CORNERS IN THESE CIRCUMSTANCES
USUALLY -- DO AN AUTOPSY.
SO.
SO THEY DON'T BUT THEY DON'T
SAVE ANY A I'M ASSUMING WHEN YOU
DO AN AUTOPSY THEY HAVE TO DO
SOME KIND OF AN EXAMINATION OF
TISSUE DO THEY NOT THE DAY DO
COLLECT SAMPLES -- THEY'RE%
MOSTLY FOR TOXICOLOGY AND THE
OTHER TWO BEING THAT THEY USE --
DO YOU CANNOT EXTRACT DNA FROM
THEM.
YOU DO NEED THE PROPER ANA I
MEAN TECHNOLOGY HAS IMPROVED
AGAIN SO THEY'RE EVEN CAN DO YOU --
DNA EXTRACTION FROM PARAFFIN
EMBEDDED TISSUES THAT SERRA BUT
UNFORTUNATELY WHAT'S REMAINS
AVAILABLE IS NOT OKAY FOR DNA
TESTING SO THERE HAS TO BE THE
SECONDARY -- YES AND THIS IS
DUNN'S IN APACHE WAY IN
CALIFORNIA AND SAY IN IN SAN
DIEGO THERE IS ACTUALLY IT IS
COKE MEDICAL EXAMINERS CORONERS
OFFICE THEY'RE DOING A VERY GOOD
CALL OF OUR COLLABORATIVE WORK
WITH.
SCRIPTS INSTITUTE SO IT'S UNFAIR
THAT THEN PATCHY PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY AT A A CALIFORNIA.
IT'S DONE -- IT'S COLLECTED AND
SO THEY ARE THE LUCKY ONES AND
THEN SOME MAJORITY OF THE OTHER
PARTS IT'S NOT DONE AND THAT'S
NOT FAIR.
UNDERSTOOD ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
THERE'S A MOTION BY SENATOR
STERN AND AT THIS POINT IF YOU'D
LIKE A TWO BRIEFING CLOSELY
THANK YOUR SEARCH AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT THE MOTION IS.
WE'RE GOING TO SAY DO PASSES
AMENDED BECAUSE THAT ONE ITEM
MIGHT AS WELL TAKE IT HERE.
SIMPLE TO TAKE IT HERE -- I
BELIEVE IT'S BEEN DISCUSSED AND
WE KNOW THAT WE'VE GOT THAT
AVAILABLE TO US SO IT'S TO PASS
AS AMENDED. TO APPROPRIATIONS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB SIX
TWENTY JACKSON HI JACKSON AYE
BORDERS.
GORGEOUS I TO RUSSELL
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I'D
JONES.
JONES I AM MONNING MONNING AYE
STERN.
STERN I AM BURKE.
WE CAL SKI.
WE CASKEY I SEVEN TWO ZERO EIGHT
TWO ZERO THE BILL IS OUT --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
APPRECIATE YOUR PERSISTENCE ON
THIS VERY HELPFUL IN.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER COULD.
NEXT UP IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN.
WHO IS NOT HERE?
AND IT APPEARS THAT WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY AUTHORS TO PRESENT.
WE COULD DO THAT BUT I'M NOT
GOING TO GO THERE YET -- WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FRIEDMAN.
OBERNOLTE -- GLORIA RADIUS AND
BURNER.
HORVATH WHO STILL HAVE ITEMS YET
TO HEAR SO IF WE COULD -- PLEASE.
IF THE SERGEANT COULD -- CONTACT
THEM AND TELL THEM THAT WERE
WAITING FOR THEM
--
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN HAS TWO
ITEMS WILL START WITH FILE ITEM
SIX A. B.. SIX SEVENTY
COLLEAGUES WERE BACK.
AT WORK WE ARE ON FILE ITEM SIX
AB SIX SEVENTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
TERRY JACKSON -- AND MEMBERS AND
I BEG YOUR PARDON FOR BEING A
FEW MINUTES LOW AT THAT THAT'S
RIGHT NO NO APOLOGIES NECESSARY
JUST WE NEEDED AN AUTHOR AND I'M
HERE GLAD TO HAVE YOU HERE VERY
HAPPY TO BE HERE AND I WANT TO
ALSO -- THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK
WITH MY STUFF AND MYSELF ON THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THERE ARE
OVER FIFTY TWO THOUSAND
COMMUNITY INTEREST DEVELOPMENTS
BEING.
OUR TRADITIONAL HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS H. AWAY IS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT MAKE UP
ABOUT ONE QUARTER OF THE STATE'S
HOUSING STOCK.
RESIDENTS IN MANY OF THESE
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN DENIED THE
ABILITY TO BUILD EIGHTY USE AS
STATE LAW REQUIRES BECAUSE THE
H. AWAY IS HAVE SEEM TO HAVE
GOVERNMENTAL AUTHORITY TO DENY
THEM.
THIS BILL BRINGS THE CHOICE INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH THE REST OF THE
STATE BY SAYING THAT THEY CAN
HAVE REASONABLE RESTRICTIONS ON
AB USE SUCH AS DESIGN REVIEW
WITH LREADY SO THEY CAN LOOK
LIKE THE REST OF THEIR EACH AWAY
IF THAT'S WHAT THEY WANT.
BUT CAN'T JUST BLANKET STOP THEM
OR MAKES -- REQUIREMENTS THAT
ARE SO ON REASONABLE BUT IT'S
TOO EXPENSIVE FOR PEOPLE TO
BUILD THEM WE'VE HEARD FROM A
LOT OF RESIDENTS ACROSS THE
STATE THAT THEY WANT TO DO AN
EIGHTY YOU BUT THEIR H. AWAY AND
THERE CITY ALLOWS IT.
BUT THEIR H. AWAY IS NOT
ALLOWING IT SO THIS BILL DOES
BRINGS HUAC COMPLIANCE WITH THE
SAME AS ANY MUNICIPALITY.
I'M ALLOW FOR EIGHTY USED TO BE
CREATED IN THOSE COMMUNITIES WE
WITH ME TODAY IS DAVID JONES IS
REPRESENTING THE TOWN OF TRUCKEE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE NOON I HOPE IT'S NOT AS HARD
IN TRUCKEE IS IT IS HERE AND IF
IT IS WERE ALL IN BIG TROUBLE SO
HE'LL BE THERE IN THREE MINUTES
EXCELLENT.
THEY MINUTES PLEASE TWO MINUTES
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME -- TO
TO TO PRESENT TODAY ON BEHALF
TOWN TRUCKEE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT FOR WORKING WITH US --
WEEKS BENT OVER BACKWARDS WITH
THE OPPOSITION -- THE THAT
CONCERNED ABOUT IT THAT'S WHY
THIS BILL IS PASSED WITH ZERO NO
VOTES THROUGH THE ENTIRE PROCESS --
THE BILL DOES TRY TO BALANCE
PROPERTY RIGHTS THOSE OF THE
EXISTING H. AWAY AND THE OWNERS
OF THESE INDIVIDUAL -- HOMES FOR
THEM TO BE ABLE TO HAVE AN
EIGHTY YOU -- SO WE LOOKED VERY
CAREFULLY AND TRIED. TO BE AS
CAREFUL AS POSSIBLE TO ADD TO
RESPECT ANY OF THE H. AWAY LAWS
THAT WE THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN
PLACE SO.
DESIGN REVIEW ASCETICS FIFTY
FIVE AN OLDER THE EIGHTY YOU
WOULD NOT WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
THOSE SAME RULES SO WE TRIED AS
BEST WE CAN AND THAT'S WHY WE
THINK WE HAVE OF CRAFTED BILL
THAT IS A VERY WELL CRAFTED --
FOR FOR YOU TODAY WE FOLLOWED
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME --
EIGHT EIGHT TWO WAYS -- THE
LEGISLATURE SAW IN ITS WISDOM TO
ALLOW.
THE H. AWAY PEOPLE TO HAVE SOLAR
EVEY CHARGING STATIONS AND WATER
CONSERVATION AND WE THINK
PROVIDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS
AS MERITORIOUS IS THOSE SINCE OF
WITH THAT WE ASK FOR NIGHT OF
YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SAYS THE MATTER NOT LIKE HAS
PUBLIC AFFAIRS HERE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA U. M. B. AND SB AT
HOME IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
AND I MIGHT NOTE FOR THE RECORD
THAT THERE WAS OPPOSITION THAT
CAME FROM THE BOARD OF THE SAN
LORENZO VILLAGE HOMES
ASSOCIATION.
BUT THAT THE LETTER.
DID WE WERE NOT MADE AWARE OF
THE LETTER TILL AFTER
PUBLICATION OF THE ANALYSIS SO.
WE DO KNOW THAT THERE IS
OPPOSITION FROM THE RELEASED
EXPRESSED WRITTEN OPPOSITION
FROM A COUPLE.
OF THESE ASSOCIATIONS -- BUT
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION HERE.
ALRIGHT WITH THAT WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE DíAS AND I JUST
WANT.
TO OF THANK YOU AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME WE WILL HAVE A
MOTION -- OBVIOUSLY WITH OUR
HOUSING CRISIS WE HAVE TO LOOK
AT A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT OPTIONS --
THAT ARE AVAILABLE AND I I LIKE
MANY OF YOU RESPECT H. AWAY HIS
RIGHTS TO TRY TO MAINTAIN
CERTAIN CONTROLS WITHIN THEIR
ASSOCIATIONS.
BUT THIS BILL I THINK MEECH SO
THAT DAD BALANCE NICELY BECAUSE
IT DOESN'T IMPOSE ANY RULES ON A
CHOICE THAT ARE ALREADY IN
EXISTENCE.
AND IT STILL ALLOWS H. R. WAYS
TO MAINTAIN THE INTEGRITY OF
THEIR COMMUNITY IT JUST THAT THE
DOES ALLOW THEM TO PROHIBIT H.
AWAY SIN -- I THINK THAT'S OF
THE VERY ELEGANT THE SOLUTION
AND APPRECIATE YOUR DOING THAT
SO -- IF THERE ARE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
[inaudible]
SENATOR STERN.
THANK YOU MANAGER AND THANK YOU
SO MEMBER FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND PLEASE INDULGE MY MY
ANXIETIES I KNOW -- WE DO HAVE A
CRISIS ON OUR HANDS -- JUST WALK
CAN YOU WALK ME THROUGH BRIEFLY
IN TERMS OF THE LIKE WHAT WHAT
AN EFFECTIVE PROHIBITION WOULD
BE VERSES SOME REASONABLE
RESTRICTIONS I KNOW I I RESERVE
THE THIS ISSUE IN THE HIGH FIRE
SEVERITY ZONES.
IF THEY'RE SORT OF PUBLIC SAFETY --
LEGITIMATE PUBLIC SAFETY
INTERESTS ABOUT.
HOW MANY CARS YOU CAN GET OFF OF
ONE CANYON ROAD AT A TIME?
OR SOME OTHER SORT OF WHAT THE
VIN OUNCES BECAUSE A REASONABLE
RESTRICTION HOW DOES HOW DOES
THAT LINE LOOK TO YOU WILL THERE
BE SOME DISCRETION WITH THE H.
O. WAYS TO SORT OF PURSUE THAT.
THAT KIND OF RESTRICTION IS THAT
HOW YOU ANTICIPATE IS BEING
IMPLEMENTED THE WAY THAT IT'S
WRITTEN I USUALLY I'M NOT SURE
THAT H. ALWAYS THEMSELVES ARE
THE ONES THAT ARE -- MAKING
DECISIONS ABOUT HEALTH AND
SAFETY THEY TEND TO REGULATE
THINGS THAT ARE MORE LIKE A
STATICS.
SO WOULD TYPICALLY BE MORE OF
YOUR MUNICIPALITY OR YOUR FIRE
MARSHAL THAT MIGHT LOOK AT
HEALTH AND SAFETY AND I WOULD
ASSUME THAT IT'S POSSIBLE THAT.
THEY CAN STOP DEVELOPMENT IN
GENERAL BASED ON CERTAIN TYPES
OF A SEVERITY OF OF A PUBLIC
SAFETY THREATS WHETHER IT'S A
THREAT OF A LOT OF A MUD SLIDE
OR SOME OTHER THREAT THEY MIGHT
JUST SAY LISTEN WE'RE JUST NOT
GOING TO ALLOW MORE DEVELOPMENT
IN A CERTAIN AREA.
BUT THAT'S NOT AN H. ALWAYS
PLEASED TO MAKE THAT KIND OF
DETERMINATION H. ALWAYS ARE
TYPICALLY REGULATING.
YOU KNOW OF DESIGN THE
REGULATING CERTAIN SETBACKS AND
USUALLY WITH AN EYE TOWARD SORT
OF A STATIC SO MAINTAINING
PROPERTY VALUES.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS SO
IN THEORY IF THE IF THE HI FIRE
SEVERITY ZONE CITY OR COUNTY.
IMPOSE SOME LOCAL ORDINANCE LIKE
THAT SOME RESTRICTION ON
DEVELOPMENT IN THE WE WE ARE IN
THE HIGH FIRES VERY SOUNDS WHICH
I KNOW IT'S BEEN A BIG ISSUE FOR
THE CHAIR AS WELL.
THAT WOULD ACTUALLY.
THAT WOULD TRUMP THAT I WOULD
OKAY SO THE AGE WE WOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO SAY NO TO THAT AND IT'S
IN YOUR SAYING IT'S NOT EVEN
REALLY IN THEIR PURVIEW I DON'T
THINK IT'S WITHIN THEIR PURVIEW
EVER TO TRUMP SOMETHING LIKE
THAT THEY'RE NOT THEY ARE NOT A
CITY -- THEY HAVE CERTAIN TYPES
OF DISCRETIONARY APPROVAL I
DON'T I DON'T KNOW THE JOYS OF
YOU CAN.
YOU KNOW THAT THEY'RE THE ONLY
ONE THAT COULD APPROVED
DEVELOPMENT -- I THINK THAT WE
STILL HAVE TO HAVE AN UNDERLYING
PLAN FROM THE MUNICIPALITY -- IT
IS IS MY YOU KNOW GAS SO WE
DON'T TRUMP ANY STATE LAW THAT
THAT REGULATES.
THE PROHIBITION OF BUILDING
BECAUSE OF SAFETY THIS DOESN'T
HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH THAT
THIS IS JUST SAYING H. AWAYIS
BASED ON SORT OF THEIR OWN
INTERNAL.
METRICS OF WHAT THEY THINK IS
ALLOWABLE THEY THEY CAN DO A LOT
pTO IT TO EIGHTY IS BASED ON
THOSE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY.
SENATOR BORCHERS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
I WILL ACCEPT YOUR VARIOUS TWO
COMMENTS AS MY CLOTHES AND
RESPECTFUL QUEST MEMBERS MARCH I
LIKE THAT.
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT WE HAVE A
MOTION.
DO PASSED TO THE SENATE FLOOR BY
SENATOR BOARD JUST PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX AB SIX
SEVENTY JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE BORDERS.
PORCHES I DO RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ GNZALEZ I'D
JONES.
JONES I AM MONNING.
MONEY AYE STERN STERN I AM BURKE
WHY CASKEY.
CASKEY I EIGHT ZERO EIGHT TWO
ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT THANK YOU --
EXCUSE ME EXCUSE ME CENTER ON
BURKE IS NOT HERE SO WHAT WE
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN BUT
CLEARLY YOU HAVE THE VOTES.
VERY GOOD AND THERE YOU HAVE ONE
OTHER ITEM OF FILE ITEM.
TEN THE AB ELEVEN TEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN --
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU I'M AB.
ELEVEN TEN SIX TO HELP RENTERS --
GIVE THEM SOME A SMALL MEASURE
OF RELIEF WHEN IT COMES TO
NOTICING REQUIREMENTS FOR RENT
INCREASES SO THIS IS NOT A BILL
THAT'S GOING TO CHANGE THE
UNIVERSE PEOPLE CAN STILL HAVE
THEIR RENTS RAIDS BUT WHAT IT
DOES IS IT SAYS IT USE THE
POLITIES.
WILL BE ABLE TO REQUIRE -- Là --
LONGER NOTICING PERIODS FOR
JUROR DRAMATIC RENT INCREASES
WHICH WILL GIVE RENTERS MORE
TIME TO FIND A NEW PLACE TO LIVE
TO PREPARE TO LEAVE RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE A SITUATION IN GLENDALE
WHERE WE'RE SEEING ONE IN TWO
HUNDRED PER SOMETIMES 2100% RENT
INCREASES.
AND THE HOME OF THE RENTER'S
MONTHS ONLY HAVE ONE MONTH
BEFORE THEY HAVE TO MOVE OUT SO
WHAT THIS DOES IS IT INCLUDED
WOULD PROPOSE RENT INCREASES
ABOVE 10% UP 215% WOULD GET A
NEW NINETY DAY NOTICE.
AND FOR RENT INCREASES OF MORE
THAN 50% A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
DAY NOTICE WILL BE REQUIRED.
THIS ISN'T SO MUCH ARE THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE ON YOUR TO YOUR
THOUGH IT WILL AFFECT THEM BUT
WE HAVE A LOT OF BUILDINGS IN MY
COMMUNITY THEY DON'T OFFER YOUR
TO LOSE YOUR LEASES THAT ONLY
OFFER MONTH TO MONTH LEASES FOR
PEOPLE WHO WOULD RATHER HAVE A
YEAR. TO YEAR FOR THOSE PEOPLE
HAVING OTHER RENTS INCREASED A
100% AND BEING GIVEN THIRTY DAYS
NOTICE JUST IS NOT ENOUGH TIME
SO WE'VE HAD A LOT OF SUPPORT
FOR THIS -- BILL IT'S THE
SPONSORS THE CITY OF GLENDALE
AND WITH THAT -- DAVE JONES IS
STILL HERE IS NO LONGER FROM
TRUCKEE TO THESE FROM GLENDA AT
NOW IS FROM GLENDALE SO HE'S
GOING.
TO RIGHT VERY GOOD FROM GLENDALE
FEW OF TWO MINUTES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH -- I THINK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DID A VERY GOOD
JOB OF EXPLAINING IT WE HAVE
CRISIS GOING ON THE STATE OF A
LOT OF PEOPLE -- NEAR HOMELESS
GIVE THEM MORE OPTIONS A LITTLE
BIT MORE TIME TO FIGURE OUT
WHETHER THEY CAN AFFORD TO STAY
IN THE PLACE THAT THEY'RE IN --
WE THINK THAT THIS IS A A VERY
SMART THING FOR US TO DO AND SO
WE'RE SPONSORING THE BILL AND
ASK FOR LIVE UP.
VERY GOOD ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IF YOU TO STEP UP.
I'M SURE MEMBERS RAND MORE NOW
BEHALF OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NONE WILL BRING
IT TO THE DIET SENATOR BORCHERS.
JUST ONE UNDERSTAND.
THE SEQUENCE OF TIME SO IF IT IS.
IF IT'S 10% OR LESS.
THEN IT'S THIRTY DAYS.
I BELIEVE SO IT'S WHATEVER THE
CURRENT THE OTHER CURRENT LAW
THAN THIRTY THAT'S THE COULD THE
THAT THAT'S THE CURRENT LAW --
YOU'RE PROPOSING THAT.
IF IT'S GREATER THAN 10% LESS
THAN -- FIFTEEN KNOWS REQUIRED
NO LATER THAN NINETY DAYS THE
ACT.
OF ITS 10% BETWEEN TEN AND
FIFTEEN BECAUSE THE NINETY RIGHT.
SHE SAID DO YOU CHANGE THE
NATIONAL THIRTY DAY PERIOD.
NOW SO IF THEY'RE ONLY RAISING
IT LET'S SAY 7% IT'S STILL THE
THIRTY DAYS THEY GET THEY ARE.
THIRTY THIRTY DAY NOTICE MINIMUM
THAT THERE'S GONNA BE A RENT
INCREASE SO COULD SOMEONE DO.
NINE AND IN HAVE ITALY TRIGGERED
THE SIX OR THE TWO MONTH PERIOD --
BECAUSE IT'S CALCULATED ON A
CUMULATIVE CUMULATIVE BASIS
BASED IN THE PREVIOUS TWELVE
MONTHS.
THEY GET BECAUSE YOU YOU ADD OR
YOU CAN'T SURE CUT IT NOW OKAY --
AND IF IT'S MORE THAN THAT
THAT'LL BE A HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS.
IS THERE.
A MATHEMATICAL -- UNCENSORED
ECONOMIC RATIONALE WHY NINETY IS
INSUFFICIENT ONE TWENTY IS.
JUST THAT IF YOU'RE INCREASING
SOMEONE'S RENT A 100% THEY'RE
GOING TO NEED MORE TIME
SOMETIMES TO FIND THEY THEY
MIGHT.
THERE'S LESS CHANCE THAT THEY'LL
BE ABLE TO PAY THE 100% INCREASE
SO THERE'S MORE CHANCE OF THEM
HAVING TO MOVE YOUR BE 15% OR
MORE.
ABOVE FIFTY WITH YOU THAT'S A
HUNDRED I MEAN THAT THAT I AGREE
I TOTALLY GET THAT BY INTUITION
BUT I MEAN IF IT'S A 15%.
FIFTEEN OR MORE PERCENT JUMP
WITH A LOOP THROUGH THE CHAIR
SIR THROUGH THE CHAIR.
SEC YEAH JUST THAT WE THINK THAT
BECAUSE THERE'S LESS HANCE AT
THAT POINT THAT THE RENTERS
GOING TO BE ABLE TO STAY IN THE
SAME ACCOMMODATIONS WE WANTED TO
GIVE THEM THE BENEFIT THAT
THEY'RE PROBABLY GONNA HAVE TO
MOVE.
AND GIVE THEM AS MUCH TIME AS WE
THOUGHT WAS REASONABLE WITHOUT
BEING PUNITIVE TO THE PROPERTY
OWNER.
THAT THESE PEOPLE ARE GONNA HAVE
TO MOVE OUT AND SO WE WANT TO
GIVE THEM MORE TIME TO FIND
ANOTHER PLACE TO LIVE -- YOU
KNOW IN PLACES LIKE LOS ANGELES
IT'S SO HARD TO FIND
[inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
REASONABLE I WOULD SAY
REASONABLE BUT FIND RENTS AT
THAT SAME PACE SO WE HAVE WE
HAVE COMPLAINTS DOZENS OF
COMPLAINTS EVERY WEEK.
MY RENT WAS YOU KNOW INCREASE TO
WHERE I CAN'T PAY IT I'M CAN
GIVEN THIRTY DAYS TO MOVE OUT
AND THIS IS NOT ENOUGH TIME THAT
CYCLE THROUGH ON CRAIG'S LIST
YOU KNOW KIND OF EVERY THIRTY
DAYS YOU START SEEING THE NEW
LISTINGS.
THEY JUST NEEDED THEY NEEDED
MORE TIME TO FIND A PLACE TO
LIVE SOMETIMES THEY HAVE TO MOVE
OUT OF THE THE AREA COMPLETELY
[inaudible]
YOUR ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
SENATOR TO RAZA -- I THANK THE
AUTHOR VERY MUCH -- WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT THOSE PEOPLE WHO
ARE ON THE EDGE.
A BECOMING HOMELESS.
WE RARELY TALK ABOUT THEM.
AND THAT'S REALLY KIND OF WHAT
THIS IS ABOUT.
IS THAT WATCHING OUT FOR THOSE
PEOPLE I KNOW IN LA COUNTY ALONE.
THERE ARE SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS.
OF SEVERELY OVER BURDENED.
HOUSEHOLDS THAT CAN PAY THE RENT
FOR THEIR PAIN ARE THE I THINK
THAT'S 50% OF THEIR INCOME.
SEOUL MORE AND MORE AND MORE
FAMILIES ARE ON THE BRINK OF
THAT AND I GUESS THIS IS THE
VERY LEAST THAT WE CAN DO WHICH
IS ALLOW THEM TIME TO FIND.
MAYBE THE RIGHT STREET THAT
THEY'RE GONNA PUT UP THE TENT.
OR YOU KNOW LIVE IN SOMEBODY'S
LIVING ROOM OR SLEEP ON THE
COUCH OR SOMETHING.
SO -- I APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
DOING AND I HOPE THIS LEADS TO
OTHER -- MEASURES THAT ARE FAR
MORE CONSCIOUS OF THE FACT THAT
THERE ARE TOO MANY PEOPLE ON THE
ON THE EDGE.
YEAH AND SOMETIMES FOR PEOPLE
GIVING THEM TIME TO NAVIGATE
OTHER RESOURCES THAT MIGHT BE
OUT THERE.
WHETHER IT'S SHELTERS ARE OTHER
AID OR PORTABLE HOUSING THIS
GIVES HIM A LITTLE BIT MORE TIME
AND HOPEFULLY THAT EXTRA MONTH
COULD YOU KNOW IT POTENTIALLY
COULD KEEP SOMEONE FROM.
ENDING UP ON THE STREET YOU KNOW
BECAUSE IT MIGHT TAKE THEM A
COUPLE MONTHS TO FIND THEIR WAY.
YOU KNOW INTO SOME ALTERNATIVE
SO I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
SAYING THAT.
THANK YOU OTHER OTHER WITNESSES
OTHER QUESTIONS RATHER.
ARE ON I JUST WANT TO ADD IT'S
NOT A UNIQUE TO LA COUNTY I KNOW
I HAVE STAFF HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WHO HAVE.
BEEN GIVEN NOTICE OF FIFTY AND A
100% RENT INCREASES AND YOU KNOW
THEY'RE WORKING.
THEY'VE GOT RESPONSIBILITIES ARE.
IN PLACES LIKE LA WHERE TRAFFIC
BECOMES A FACTOR IN HOW YOU GET
TO WORK OR IN THE BAY AREA AND
TO ALMOST ANYWHERE I MEAN THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT THINGS
I WISH.
I WISH PEOPLE WEREN'T SUBJECTED
TO SUCH HIGH RENT INCREASES BUT
I ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT LANDLORDS
HAVE.
CERTAIN CERTAIN RIGHTS SAID THE
TO CHARGE WHAT THEY FEEL THEY
CAN.
DO APPROPRIATELY AND LESSER SO
THE REGULATION SO I THINK --
WHILE IT DOES ADD TO A PERIOD OF
TIME -- GIVEN OUR HOUSING SHORT
FOR RIGHT NOW I CAN'T.
SEE ANY REASON WHY THIS WOULD BE.
ONEROUS FOR ANYONE SO UP.
YOU'RE BRINGING THE BILL AND
I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION BY
SENATOR MORNING.
THE MOTION IS SAID TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN A. B.
ELEVEN TEN JACKSON HI JACKSON I
BORDERS.
OR JUST NO DO RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I'D
JONES.
JONES NO MONNING.
MONNING ICE STERN.
STERN I BURKE.
WHITE HOUSE E. Y. CASKEY I SIXTY
TO SIXTY TWO WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN.
AND APPRECIATE.
YOU'RE RESPONDING SO QUICKLY TO
OUR ALL POINTS BULLETIN.
AND NEXT UP WE HAVE OF WITH HIS
ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OBERNOLTE IS HERE HE'S NEXT UP
ON THE FILE.
FILE ITEM TWELVE AB.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY GOOD AFTERNOON
AND TRUE TO FORM YOU DON'T HAVE
A SINGLE PIECE OF PAPER WITH YOU.
ALWAYS IMPRESSED ME A YOU'VE
EITHER GOT IT UP HERE NO
COMPUTER WITH YOU TODAY.
WELL ARE.
YOU CAN TRUST YOU TELL YOU'RE
NOT IMPRESSED WHEN I ALL RIGHT
IT IS RISKY.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AB.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY HAS TO DEAL WITH
THE DISPOSITION OF PREMARITAL
AGREEMENTS IN CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA STATE LAW AN AXE
PROTECTIONS FOR PARTIES ENTERING
INTO PREMARITAL AGREEMENTS IN
PARTICULAR.
IT ADVISES ON ON REPRESENTED
PARTY TO SEEK REPRESENTATION AND
IMPOSES A MINIMUM SEVEN DAY
WAITING PERIOD BETWEEN WHEN AN
AGREEMENT ASDRAFTED AND WANTED
TO SIGN ANOTHER WERE IN ORDER
FOR THE AGREEMENT TO BE VALID.
HOWEVER SOME AMBIGUITY HAS
ARISEN IN THE INTERPRETATION OF
THIS LAW PARTICULARLY WHETHER OR
NOT THAT SEVEN DAY WAITING
PERIOD APPLIES TO BOTH
REPRESENTED AND UNDER
REPRESENTED PARTIES STAND.
IF AN AGREEMENT IS AMENDED
WHETHER OR NOT THE AMENDMENT
TRIGGERS ITSELF ANOTHER SEVEN
DAY WAITING PERIOD FOR THE
AGREEMENT TO BE VALID.
SO THIS BILL CLARIFIES STATE LAW
A. B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY WOULD
INTERPRET THE ORIGINAL STATUTE
IN THE BROADEST POSSIBLE WAY --
IT APPLIES TO BOTH REPRESENTED
AND UNDER REPRESENTED PARTIES
AND CLARIFIES THAT IF AN
AGREEMENT IS AMENDED AS LONG AS
IS AMENDMENTS ARE SUBSTANTIVE
BUT THAT TRIGGERS ANOTHER SEVEN
DAY WAITING PERIOD SO WITH ME
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
IS LARRY DOYLE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA BAR ASSOCIATIONS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MAN SENATOR
MEMBERS -- THE PURPOSE OF THE
BILL AS WELL EXPLAINED IN THE
ANALYSIS WHICH WAS EXCELLENT.
AND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBEROBERNOLTE
THE THIS WORKS OUT TO BE FAIRLY
SIMPLE EVERYBODY AGREES.
WITH THIS PARTICULAR PROVISION
OF THE CODE NEEDS TO BE
CLARIFIED.
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T TELL EXACTLY
WHAT IT MEANS THAT THE DOCUMENT.
IS CO HAS TO BE GIVEN TO THE
PERSON THANK PERCENT AT SEVEN
DAYS -- THE NOBODY OBJECTS TO
THAT THE ONLY ISSUE IS WHETHER
OR NOT.
AT THE END.
YOU WHETHER OR NOT.
IT MAKES A DIFFERENCE OF
SOMEBODY'S REPRESENTED.
AND THE DECISION -- THE WE'VE
MADE ND IN CONJUNCTION ITH.
ASSEMBLY STAFF AND SENATE STAFF
REALLY IS THAT -- WE SHOULD BE
MOST PROTECTIVE OF THE
PARTICIPANTS PARTICULARLY THE
WEAKER PARTIES WHO ARE GOING TO
BE THE ONES WHO ARE ASKED TO
SIGN.
A PRENUPTIAL AGREEMENTS SO THE
YOU CAN OF THEY KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE SIGNING IN
CAN MAKE A DECISION.
WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE INTO YOU
KNOW GETTING AN ATTORNEY.
THE DAY BEFORE YOU'RE SUPPOSED
TO SIGN A PRENUP DOES NOT
GUARANTEE THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
BE WELL INFORMED AS TO WHAT'S IN
THAT.
NO MATTER HOW GOOD THE ATTORNEY
MAY BE.
THIS MAY BE A LITTLE BIT -- YOU
KNOW.
RESTRICTIVE IN SOME SENSE BUT ON
THE OTHER HAND.
IF YOU HAVE TWO COMPETENT
ATTORNEYS WORKING TOGETHER.
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE THEM.
BE ABLE.
TO GET THINGS DONE FAIRLY
QUICKLY SO YOU HAVE THE SEVEN
DAYS.
AND IF SOMETHING IS GETTING IN
THE WAY FROM A TIMING STANDPOINT
IS.
WAITED OUT THAT YOU CAN ALWAYS
DO A POST UP.
SO -- WHO WERE TRYING TO BE AS
PRODUCTIVE AS POSSIBLE AND TO
CLARIFY AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE?
AND WE HOPE YOU WILL SUPPORT US.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
EACH STEP FORWARD PLEASE.
YOU CAN TAKE A SEAT RIGHT IN
FRONT [inaudible]
VERY GOOD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THE TWO MINUTES
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR JACKSON AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS BOBBY LEVY AND I'M HERE TODAY.
THE FUTURE CERTIFIED FAMILY LAW
SPECIALIST.
AND THE FAMILY LAW EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE.
OF THE CALIFORNIA LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION SO I HAVE TWO HATS
TODAY.
OF BOTH ORGANIZATIONS OPPOSE AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY UNLESS AMENDED.
BASICALLY BOTH ORGANIZATIONS
OPPOSE THE PART OF THE BILL TO
THE EXTENT THE SEVEN DAY WAITING
PERIOD APPLIES TO REPRESENTED
PARTIES.
AS EXPLAINED IN THE TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN CASE OF IN RAIN MARRIAGE
OF COD WELL FOSSIL IN FOSS SO.
THE SEVEN DAY PERIOD MAKES SENSE
AS A NECESSARY CONDITION THE
FINDING VOLUNTARY EXECUTION ON
THE PART OF AN ON REPRESENTED
PARTY BECAUSE THE THE
REQUIREMENT AFFORDS A REASONABLE
PERIOD OF TIME TO OBTAIN AND
CONSULT.
WITH INDEPENDENT COUNSEL PRIOR
TO SIGNING A PREMARITAL
AGREEMENT.
ON THE OTHER HAND WHEN A PARTY
IS ALL RAPPERS ALREADY
REPRESENTED BY COUNSEL IN THE
TRANSACTION.
OBTAINING THE REQUISITE ADVICE
CAN OCCUR VERY QUICKLY AND NO
PURPOSE IS SERVED BY IMPOSING A
STATUTORY WAITING PERIOD.
RETAIN COUNSEL CAN CONTROL THE
TIMELINE IF NOT AVAILABLE
STRAIGHT AWAY. TO REVIEW A
DOCUMENT ANY COMPETENT ATTORNEY
COULD ADVISE THE CLIENT NOT
DECIDED UNTIL HERE SHE HAS
REVIEWED THE DOCUMENT AND
CONSULTED WITH THE CLIENT.
WHETHER THIS OCCURRED WITHIN THE
SEVENTY PERIOD OR BEYOND THAT.
THE CLIENT IS PROTECTED.
NUMBER NEGOTIATING A PREMARITAL
AGREEMENTS TYPICAL FOR COUNSEL
WITH THE CLIENT WITH GREATER
MEANS OR GREATER INCOME. TO BE
THE ONE TO PREPARE THE FIRST
DRAFT AND REVISIONS ARE
TYPICALLY REQUESTED BY THE LOWER
EARNING OR LESSER MEANS SPOUSE
TO BE.
AND THOSE REVISIONS ARE
TYPICALLY REVISIONS THAT BENEFIT
THE PERSON WHO IS BEING ASKED TO
SIGN THE PRIMERA ALL AGREEMENT.
OFTENTIMES THESE VOLUNTARY
AGREED UPON CHANGES ARE MADE
CLOSE TO THE WEDDING DATE.
HAVING COUNCIL IS A PROTECTIVE
FACTOR AND EVEN THE BILL'S
SPONSOR CONCEDES THAT
REPRESENTATION BY COUNSEL
PROVIDES SOLID PROTECTION.
AGAINST DECEPTION UNDER NORMAL
CIRCUMSTANCES.
ALLOWING RETAIN COUNSEL TO HAVE
THE FLEXIBILITY TO CONTROL THE
TIME LINE IS PREFERABLE.
VERSUS HAVING THE PARTIES ENTER
AN AGREEMENT THAT NEITHER
NEITHER OF THEM WANT.
OR EVEN WORSE HAVING THE PARTIES
DEAL WITH THE EMBARRASSMENT AND
FINANCIAL DEVASTATION OF HAVING
TO EITHER POSTPONE OR CANCEL
THEIR WEDDING.
AT THE LAST MINUTE BECAUSE OF
THE NEED TO START THE SEVENTIES
ALL OVER THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY IT IS FOR THOSE
REASONS THAT THESE BOTH OR THE
GIVE THESE ORGANIZATIONS OPPOSE
THE BILL.
THANKS SO MUCH THANK YOU ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MY TING IN NON.
YOU KNOW I FIND THIS VERY
INTERESTING I HAD THE GOOD
FORTUNE OR MISFORTUNE I'M NOT
QUITE SURE. TO DONE A NUMBER OF
THESE AGREEMENTS.
AND THIS IS PROBABLY FOR MOST
PEOPLE THE SINGULAR MOST
IMPORTANT CONTRACTING WHICH THEY
EVER ENTER.
OFFER MANY PEOPLE THEY HAVE NO
IDEA WHAT IT MEANS TO GET
MARRIED IN TERMS OF LEGAL
CONSEQUENCES.
CERTAINLY WHEN YOU HAVE OF
PARTIES EITHER ONE OR BOTH THE
CHOOSE TO ENTER INTO A
PREMARITAL AGREEMENT.
THERE USUALLY ASSETS OR THEIR
CHILDREN THERE'S SOME THERE'S
SOME REASON TO GO ABOVE AND
BEYOND WHAT THE LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS THE THE INHERENT
LEGAL REQUIREMENTS ARE OF
AMERICA RELATIONSHIP -- THE
NOTION THAT ANYONE WOULD
COMPLAIN ABOUT AN ADDITIONAL
SEVEN DAY WAITING PERIOD JUST
AYE AYE LISTEN CAREFULLY TO YOUR
TESTIMONY AND HAVING BEEN A
LAWYER.
DOING FAMILY LAW AND WHAT HAVE
YOU AND RESPECTING YOUR
ORGANIZATION SAKE I'M JUST
PUZZLED UP BECAUSE OF YOUR TO
YOU'RE DEALING WITH THE PROBABLY
PEOPLE AT THEIR MOST EMOTIONAL.
THE GETTING MARRIED THEY'RE IN
LOVE THEY THEY WANT TO A
PERMANENT LIFETIME COMMITMENT TO
EACH OTHER.
THE NOTION OF WAITING SEVEN DAYS
AFTER A FINAL CONTRACT IS
ENTERED INTO -- NOT ONLY DOESN'T
OFFEND ME BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT.
PEOPLE BE ABLE TO STEP BACK AND
WITH THE HELP OF COUNCIL WHICH I
ALWAYS FELT WAS APPROPRIATE TO
GET THE THE NUTS AND BOLTS OF
WHAT YOU'RE REALLY DOING HERE --
AND USUALLY THE THE THE LESSER --
POWERFUL OF THE PARTIES -- FEEL
SOME PRESSURE. TO SIGN THE
AGREEMENT TO GET MARRIAGE GOING --
BUT TO HAVE THAT SEVEN DAYS IT
IS I WON'T CALL A COOLING OFF
PERIOD BUT IT'S A REFLECTIVE
PERIOD AND I I THINK THIS MAKES
EMINENTLY GOOD SENSE.
JUST IN TERMS OF MY OWN
EXPERIENCES ARE.
NOW RECOVERING PRACTITIONER -- I
I JUST A MOMENT IT A BIT OF A
LOSS IN AS FAR AS THE THE
CADWELL CASE IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN.
THE COURT FOUND THE CURRENT LAW
SOMEWHAT AMBIGUOUS -- BUT
IRRESPECTIVE OF THAT THE RIGHT
TO DETERMINE A POLICY LIKE THE
DOES RESIDE WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND NOT WITH THE COURTS SO --
WELL I APPRECIATED I'M GLAD THAT
YOU'RE HERE TO EXPRESS YOUR
CONCERNS.
I HAPPEN TO THINK THAT A SEVEN
DAY WAITING PERIOD IRRESPECTIVE
OF WHETHER YOU REPRESENTED BY
COUNSEL NOT.
A KID IT CAN ONLY BE HELPFUL TO
THE PARTIES WHO ULTIMATELY DO
AGREE ON PREMARITAL.
OF TERMS THAT ARE GONNA FALL
THEM FOR HOPEFULLY THE REST OF
THEIR LIVES [inaudible]
SENATOR MONNING.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR I I
DIDN'T PRACTICE FAMILY LAW BUT I
DID LUCKY YOU EIGHT YOU KNOW
HIGH PROFILE PRENUP -- CASE OF A
RESIDENT OF MY DISTRICT IN A IN
A FIANCE OF LESSER MEANS LET'S
SAY SO I'M FAMILIAR WITH SOME OF
THE LEVERAGE POINTS IN.
AMIDST THE EMOTIONAL COMMITMENTS
THAT ARE BEING MADE -- HOW WE'VE
BEEN DISCUSSING A PRENUPTIAL
AGREEMENT?
CAN BE A TOUGH ISSUE TO EVEN
BROACH IN THE PENDING MARRIAGE
CIRCUMSTANCE I JUST LIKE TO GIVE
THE AUTHOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RESPOND TO THE CONCERNS RAISED
BY THE OPPOSITION I THINK THE
CHAIRED.
DID A GOOD JOB OF IT THAN I AM
JUST YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE
WAITING PERIOD WHERE BOTH.
PARTIES ARE REPRESENTED BY
COUNSEL I THANK YOU SENATOR OUT.
NORMALLY I AM NOT WANT TO BE A
PROPONENT OF FURTHER REGULATION
ON THE CITIZENRY OF CALIFORNIA
SO THIS IS SOMETHING THAT I TAKE.
A VERY SERIOUSLY AND VERY
CAUTIOUSLY AND I DID THINK ABOUT
TO THE CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION BUT I AS THE CHAIR
SAID THIS.
THESE AGREEMENTS ARE PROBABLY
THE MOST CONSEQUENTIAL THING
THAT MOST OF THESE PARTIES WILL
EVER SIGNED IN THEIR LIFETIME SO
GIVEN THAT FACT IT DOESN'T SEEM
LIKE SEVEN DAYS IS ON REASONABLE.
ALSO IS THE CHAIR POINTED OUT.
EVEN THOUGH THE I THINK
ORIGINALLY WHEN THE LAW WAS
DRAFTED THE THOUGHT WAS THAT IF
YOU HAVE ONE PARTY THAT'S
REPRESENTED ONE THAT'S ON
REPRESENTED THERE'S A BIG POWER
IMBALANCE.
THERE WHICH IS TRUE BUT IT IS
ALSO TRUE THAT IF YOU HAVE.
ONE THAT IS TRYING TO PROTECT
ASSETS IN ONE PARTY THE JUST
WANTS TO GET MARRIED EVEN IF THE
OTHER PARTY IS REPRESENTED
THERE'S STILL A POWER IMBALANCE
THERE BECAUSE ONE MIGHT HAVE THE
FAMILY LAW FIRM THAT'S BEEN IN
THEIR FAMILY FOR GENERATIONS.
AND THE OTHER HAVE SOMEONE THAT
THEY THEY LOOKED UP IN THE
YELLOW PAGES THAT MORNING RIGHT
SO -- THEY'RE STILL A
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF PRESSURE
THERE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT PRESSURE ISN'T A EXERTING
UNDUE INFLUENCE AND ALSO LET ME
MAKE ONE POINT. TO SOMETHING
ELSE THAT THE OPPOSITION SAID
THAT I DISAGREE WITH WHICH IS
THAT.
WOULD BE TERRIBLE IF THIS CAUSED.
A DELAY IN A WEDDING.
A WRITER SO YOU KNOW WE'RE
NEGOTIATING WE HAVE TO DO AN
AMENDMENT AND ON A WE'VE GOT TO
PUSH BACK THE WEDDING DATE BUT
WE ALL KNOW THAT LEGALLY.
THE THE MARRIAGE ISN'T ISN'T --
OUR CONSUMMATED UNTIL THE OUR
MARRIAGE LICENSES SIDE HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE CEREMONY
SO THE IN THE WORST CASE
SCENARIO WHERE AN AMENDMENT HAD
TO BE DRAFTED AND SIGNED AT THE
LAST MINUTE.
YOU COULD STILL HAVE THE
CEREMONY WILL JUST HAVE TO WAIT
THOSE SEVEN DAYS TO GET THE
MARRIAGE LICENSE SIDE AND AS YOU
POINT OUT YOUR ANALYSIS THAT
MIGHT BE ON A ROMANTIC BUT A
PRIMER AGREEMENTS ARE ROMANTIC
AND YOU KNOW THIS IS THE WORLD
WE LIVE IN SO.
THERE IS A A METHODOLOGY FOR
DEALING WITH EVEN THAT SITUATION
I APPRECIATE HERE MENTIONING
THAT BECAUSE THAT DID OCCUR SO.
YOU CAN GO FORWARD WITH THE
PLANNED.
END THE MARRIAGE LICENSE CAN BE
EXECUTED AFTER THE DATE THAT THE
PRENUPTIAL AGREEMENT.
IS EXECUTED.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AT GLAD TO
MOVE THE BILL AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME THANK YOU ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE -- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
TAKE THAT IS YOUR CLOTHES YES
MA'AM VERY GOOD ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE A MOTION. TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY JACKSON HI
JACKSON AYE BORDERS.
OR DECIDE TO RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I'D
JONES.
MARK JONES I MONNING.
MONEY AYE STERN.
STERN I AM BURKE.
BY KELSEY MY CASKEY I EIGHT ZERO
EIGHT TWO ZERO WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VENTURE THANK YOU OF
MR REALTY AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
RIGHT WE HAVE A A NEXT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GLORIA.
THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTEEN
COLLEAGUES THIS IS -- A. B..
FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN GOOD
AFTERNOON AND AGAIN AT THE
WITNESSES TO WITNESSES ON EACH
SIDE TWO MINUTES EACH SO -- A
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
AT FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN TODAY.
UNDER EXISTING LAW ONLY
PROSECUTORS MAY FILE LAWSUITS
CHARGING UNFAIR BUSINESS
PRACTICES THESE ACTIONS MAY BE
BROUGHT FORWARD BY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY OR
CITY ATTORNEY SERVING A POT A
CITY WITH A POPULATION GREATER
THAN SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE.
WHERE DITRICT ATTORNEY BRINGS
FORWARD AN ACTION UNDER THE
UNFAIR COMPETITION LAW THE
COUNTY RECEIVES ALL THE CIVIL
PENALTIES AWARDED BY THE COURT?
HOWEVER WHEN THE CITY ATTORNEY
BRING SUCH AN ACTION THOSE CIVIL
PENALTIES MUST BE TO SPLIT
EVENLY WITH THE TREASURE OF THE
COUNTY IN WHICH THE JUDGMENT WAS
ENTERED.
EVEN IF THE COUNTY PROVIDE NO
ASSISTANCE IN PURSUING THE
ACTION OF THE BY THE CITY
ATTORNEY.
THIS DISCREPANCY HAS LEFT THOSE
ELIGIBLE CITY ATTORNEY'S WITH
WHAT I SEE IS A DIFFICULT CHOICE
BALANCING THE PURSUIT OF LEGAL
RECOURSE AGAINST UNSCRUPULOUS
ACTORS.
VERSUS THE REALITY OF FINITE
PUBLIC RESOURCES.
LET ME BE CLEAR THE LEGAL AND
MORAL RESPONSIBILITY FOR THESE
ELIGIBLE CITY ATTORNEY'S HAS
BEEN AND WILL ALWAYS BE UNDER
THIS BILL TO PROVIDE LEGAL
RELIEF FOR HARM TO CONSUMERS.
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
REQUIRES THAT PENALTIES
COLLECTED BY THE ELIGIBLE CITY
ATTORNEY FROM AN ACTION UNDER
THE UNFAIR COMPETITION LAW BE
PAID ENTIRELY TO THE CITY.
THE BILL WAS AMENDED TO ALLOW
THE COUNTY TO STILL RECEIVE HALF
OF AN AWARD PENALTY IF THEY
PARTICIPATE IN PRE LITIGATION
INVESTIGATION.
OF THE ACTION BY ENSURING
EQUITABLE DISTRIBUTION OF THE
PENALTIES AWARDED UNDER UNFAIR
COMPETITION LAW THIS BILL WILL
EMPOWER THOSE ELIGIBLE CITY
ATTORNEYS TO PROSECUTE UNFAIR
BUSINESS PRACTICES IN THE
INTEREST OF CONSUMERS.
AND OF CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENT
WITH ME THIS AFTERNOON I HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES HERE ON BEHALF
OF SEGA C. ATTORNEY MAR ELLIOTT
AND LOS ANGELES CITY ATTORNEY
MIKE FEUER.
MARCH TWO MINUTES PLEASE.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS MARK AND CORN THE CHIEF
DEPUTY CITY ATTORNEY FOR THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO.
AB ONE FOUR SEVEN SEVEN BRINGS
THE UNFAIR COMPETITION LAW BACK
INTO BALANCE.
IT ALLOWS CITY ATTORNEYS FROM
THE THREE LARGEST CALIFORNIA
CITIES TO KEEP ALL THE CIVIL
PENALTIES WHEN THEY ACT
INDEPENDENTLY TO ENFORCE THE U.
C. L..
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY SOME DOES
NOT INCREASE OR DECREASE THE
AMOUNT OF PENALTY IN ANY WAY.
THE TRIAL COURT JUDGES STILL IN
POWERTO IMPOSE ONLY THE
APPROPRIATE AMOUNT OF PENALTY.
BASED ON THE CONDUCT OF THE
DEFENDANT A PARTICULAR MATTER
LET ME STRESS THE POTENTIAL
MONETARY RELIEF HE IS NOT AND
SHOULD NEVER BE THE REASON TO
BRING A CIVIL ENFORCEMENT ACTION.
OFFICE IS LIKE MINE ACROSS THE
STATE WORKS HARD TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS AND THE ENVIRONMENT
USING TOOLS LIKE THE UCL.
MONETARY PENALTIES OR ALWAYS
SECONDARY TO MAKING VICTIMS HOLE
IN OBTAINING INJUNCTIVE REMEDIES
THAT PREVENT FUTURE MISCONDUCT.
BUT IN CASES WHERE CIVIL
PENALTIES ARE APPROPRIATE AND
THE DEFENDANT HAS THE ABILITY TO
PAY IT'S ONLY FAIR THAT THE
AGENCY THAT DID THE WORK SHOULD
KEEP THOSE FUNDS. TO SUPPORT
FUTURE INVESTIGATION AND FUTURE
LITIGATION.
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
ENCOURAGES LOCAL AGENCIES TO
WORK TOGETHER BY PUTTING THEM
ALL ON AN EQUAL FOOTING
INCLUDING WHERE INVESTIGATIVE
RESOURCES ARE SHARED BETWEEN
JURISDICTIONS WE URGE AN AYE
VOTE ON FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MICHAEL BOSTROM AN ASSISTANT
CITY ATTORNEY WITH A LOS ANGELES
CITY ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
I'M THE HEAD OF THE OFFICE IS
AFFIRMATIVE LITIGATION DIVISION
AND AS SUCH A RESPONSIBLE FOR
MUCH OF THE CONSUMER PROTECTION
CIVIL LITIGATION BROUGHT BY OUR
OFFICE.
CITY ATTORNEY MIKE YOUR ASSET
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE TODAY AND
YOU CAN BASIS THANKS TO YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF OUR
COMMENTS.
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT HAS
RECOGNIZED THAT THE PRIMARY
REMEDY AND UNFAIR COMPETITION
LAW CASES IS INJUNCTIVE RELIEF
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF.
THUS OUR PRIMARY OBJECTIVE IN
PURSUING ANY UCL ACTION IS FIRST
AND FOREMOST TO STOP THE
OFFENDING CONDUCT.
CITY ATTORNEYS WILL CONTINUE TO
PARTNER WITH COUNTIES AND ANY
OTHER AGENCY THEY CAN ASSIST US
WITH THE SUBJECTIVE.
WE OWE IT TO OUR CONSTITUENTS TO
DO SO.
UNDERSTOOD THE ATTORNEY MIKE
FEAR OUR OFFICE IS BEEN A LEADER
IN BRINGING CONSUMER PROTECTION
MATTERS USING THE U. C. L. WE
BROUGHT THE UCL ACTION
CHALLENGING WELLS FARGO'S
PRACTICE.
OF OPENING FAKE ACCOUNTS WITH
ITS CUSTOMERS WITHOUT ITS
CUSTOMERS KNOWLEDGE MORE
RECENTLY WE BROUGHT YOU SEE L.
ACTIONS AGAINST VAPING COMPANIES.
WE ALLEGE HAVE MARKETED TOBACCO
PRODUCTS TO MINORS A U. C. L.
ACTION AGAINST THE WEATHER
CHANNEL APP WHOM WE ALLEGE HAS
MISLED CONSUMERS INTO GRANTING
ACCESS TO THEIR LOCATION DATA.
AND YOU STILL ACTIONS AGAINST
TURBO.
AND H. AND R. BLOCK WHEN WE
ALLEGE HAVE MISLED CONSUMERS
INTO PAYING HEFTY.
FEES FOR TAX PREPARATION
PRODUCTS THEY WERE ENTITLED TO
RECEIVE FOR FREE.
AS YOU CAN SEE FROM THESE
EXAMPLES THE INJUNCTIVE RELIEF
PROVIDED TO CONSUMERS BY
SUCCESSFUL CONSUMER PROTECTION
LAWSUITS BY CITY ATTORNEYS
IMPACTS CONSUMERS FAR BEYOND THE
GEOGRAPHIC BOUNDARIES OF THE
CITY.
THE CURRENT STATUTE RELATED TO
PENALTIES HOWEVER IS OUTDATED
AND IS IN NO WAY TIED TO
SUCCESSFUL CONSUMER PROTECTION
EFFORTS.
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN WOULD
STRENGTHEN CONSUMER PROTECTION
EFFORTS IN CALIFORNIA BY
ENSURING THAT ROBUST CONSUMER
PROTECTION PRACTICESARE FULLY
RESOURCE.
WE HAVE A VERY STRONG
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE COUNTY THE
COUNTY HAS BEEN A KEY PARTNER ON
MATTERS RANGING FROM ACTIONS
AGAINST BUSINESSES WHO STEAL
WAGES OF THEIR EMPLOYEES. TO
ACTIONS AGAINST NOTORIOUS WHO
DEFRAUD VULNERABLE CONSUMERS.
IF THE COUNTY HAS PARTICIPATED
IN THE MATTER IN THAT PRE
LITIGATION INVESTIGATION IN ANY
WAY WHATSOEVER WE FIRMLY BELIEVE
THAT THE COUNTY SHOULD RECEIVE
50% OF ANY PENALTIES AWARDED
THROUGH OUR LITIGATION EFFORTS.
WE ALSO BELIEVE HOWEVER THAT THE
CITY ATTORNEY'S OFFICE SHOULD
RETAIN ALL PENALTIES IN MATTERS
THAT WE PURSUE WITHOUT ANY
COUNTY PARTICIPATION.
THIS IS NOT JUST A MATTER OF
FAIRNESS BUT ALSO EFFICIENCY.
AS A MATTER OF STATE LAW
STATUTORY PENALTIES ARE ONLY TO
BE USE FOR FURTHER CONSUMER
PROTECTION PURPOSES.
pAGENCIES THAT HAVE BEEN MOST
EFFECTIVE IN VINDICATING
CONSUMER RIGHTS RESULT IN
STRONGER CONSUMER PROTECTION FOR
THE PUBLIC THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I GIVE
YOU A LITTLE EXTRA TIME BECAUSE
I KNOW THIS IS A BIT OF A
KERFUFFLE HERE AND I'M SURE
MEMBERS.
ON THE DíAS A VERY INTERESTED
IN YOUR PERSPECTIVE SO WITH THAT
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WHY DO I HAVE A FEELING THAT
THERE ARE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION MIGHT BE COMING FROM
LA COUNTY?
AND IF YOU ARE CAMANCHE
[inaudible]
OPPOSITION. TWO MINUTES EACH
PLEASE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JUDY WHITEHURST I'M A SENIOR
ASSISTANT COUNTY COUNCIL IN THE
OFFICE OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
COUNCIL.
EXPRESSING OPPOSITION TO A. B..
FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN BECAUSE
OF THE NEGATIVE IMPACTS TO ALL
CONSUMERS THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY
OF LOS ANGELES AND IT'S EIGHTY
EIGHT CITIES.
CONSUMER FRAUD PARTICULARLY IN A
LARGE COUNTY LIKE LOS ANGELES IS
PERVASIVE.
IT HURTS PEOPLE FROM ALL WALKS
OF LIFE PARTICULARLY THE
VULNERABLE LIKE ELDERLY
IMMIGRANTS YOUNG PEOPLE AND POOR.
AND SIGNIFICANTLY CONSUMER FRAUD.
DOES NOT END AT THE CITY BORDERS
IT FLOWS OVER AND AFFECTS ALL
RESIDENTS OF THE COUNTY.
THE STRONGEST WAY TO FIGHT
CONSUMER FRAUD AND PROTECT
CONSUMERS.
IS ONE GOVERNMENT WORKS TOGETHER
AS A TEAM.
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY WE HAVE A
HIGH HIGHLY EFFECTIVE TEAM OF
DEPARTMENTS THAT PROTECT
CONSUMERS AND PROSECUTE BAD
ACTORS.
THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE COUNTY
INCLUDING IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES IN MY OFFICE WE HAVE
ALSO ESTABLISHED AN AFFIRMATIVE
LITIGATION AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION DIVISION.
WE HAVE THIRTEEN LAWYERS WHO
FIGHT FOR CONSUMER PROTECTION
EVERY DAY. FOR MANY YEARS THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
HAS ALSO S. AND HAS AN
ESTABLISHED CONSUMER PROTECTION
SECTION.
WE BRING ACTIONS TOGETHER.
AND WE ALSO JOIN WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND CITY
ATTORNEY'S.
WE ALSO USE OUR INVESTIGATIVE
DEPARTMENTS SUCH AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AND
BUSINESS AFFAIRS PUBLIC HEALTH
AND THE AGRICULTURAL WEIGHTS AND
MEASURES TO ADDRESS.
COUNTY WIDE UNFAIR BUSINESS
PRACTICES FALSE ADVERTISING AND
PUBLIC NUISANCE SOME EXAMPLES
INCLUDE THE RECENTLY -- SETTLE
LAWSUIT THAT WE BROUGHT WITH THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY AGAINST WILY
SANDERS TRUCKING COMPANY THAT
WAS ILLEGALLY TRANSPORTING
HAZARDOUS LEAD BATTERY WASTE
FROM EXIDE.
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY INCLUDING
IN SOME OF YOUR DISTRICTS.
AND ON THE STREETS OF LOS
ANGELES ON ITS WAY TO
BAKERSFIELD.
OR THE ANA PLEX CHROME PLATING
FACILITY IN PARAMOUNT WHERE
WE'VE PARTNERED WITH THE SOUTH
COAST AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT TO REDUCE TOXIC
EMISSIONS.
SINCE WE FILED A LAWSUIT
EMISSIONS ARE TEN TIMES LOWER
AND OF COURSE EMISSIONS DON'T
AND AND PARAMOUNT.
THEY FLOW OVER TO THE
COMMUNITIES AND THE AREAS AROUND
THERE.
WE RECENTLY FILED THE LAWSUIT
WHERE PEOPLE IN SMALL CLAIMS
COURT WE'RE BEING SCAMMED OUT OF
THEIR JUDGMENTS.
THE VICTIMS ARE FROM ALL OVER
LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
INCLUDING THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES.
AND ALL THE WAY FROM LONG BEACH
TO SANTA CLARITA.
AND WE'VE SUIT ADDISON OVER AT
THE WALL THE FIRE AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA GAS OVERLY SO CANYON
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TEST BUT I'M SURE THE BE MORE
QUESTIONS. TWO MINUTES IF YOU
ENTER AN AFTERNOON AUDIBLE CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
JONI KITA ON BEHALF OF LA COUNTY
IN OPPOSITION.
I AM THE DIRECTOR OF THE LA
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AND BUSINESS AFFAIRS WE SERVE
CONSUMERS IN LA COUNTY IS EIGHTY
EIGHT CITIES.
IN OUR HUNDRED AND TWENTY
UNINCORPORATED AREAS IN OUR
NEIGHBORING COUNTIES AND ALL
OVER THE WORLD AND COUNTRY IN
FACT.
THIS TWENTY TWELVE MY DEPARTMENT
IS HELPED OVER SEVENTY FOUR
THOUSAND OF THESE CONSUMERS
RECOVER APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN ARCHES
INTERJECTION YOU'RE NOT FROM THE
SAME YOUR FROM THE COUNTY
COUNCIL IN YOUR FROM IN A
SEPARATE AGENCY.
I YES THAT'S CORRECT OKAY THANK
YOU I'M A RECOVERING COUNTY
COUNCIL MYSELF.
CONDOLENCES.
LIKE LIKE MISS WHITE HEARST I
BELIEVE AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN WILL REDUCE THE CONCERN
CONSUMER SERVICES THE COUNTY.
PROVIDES INCLUDING THOSE
PROVIDED BY IT MIGHT DEPARTMENT
AT THE CONSUME AT THAT APARTMENT
CONSUMER BUSINESS AFFAIRS.
WE WORK WITH THE COUNTY COUNCIL
AND THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY TO
LEVERAGE IVIL PENALTIES TO
INVESTIGATE ISSUES OF COUNTY
WIDE CONCERN AND I ALSO HAVE
SOME RECENT EXAMPLES VERY
BRIEFLY.
EARLIER THIS YEAR WE SUPPORTED
AN INVESTIGATION BY THE LA CITY
ATTORNEY AND STATE BAR THAT
RESULTED IN MISDEMEANOR CHARGES
AGAINST IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS.
WITH OFFICES IN LA CITY BUT
VICTIMS ALL OF AN ACCOUNT AND I
BELIEVE THE CITY REFERENCE THAT.
IN HIS TESTIMONY LAST MONTH WE
SUPPORTED AN INVESTIGATION BY
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY RESULTING
IN THE FILING OF OVER FIFTY
FELONIES IS THE CRIMINAL CASE.
AGAINST THE MAN PEDDLING SICK
AND DYING PUPPIES TO CONSUMERS
AGAIN FROM ALL OVER OUTSIDE THE
COUNTY AS WELL -- BUT CIVIL
PENALTIES DON'T JUST SUPPORT
INVESTIGATIONS THAT RESULT IN
PROSECUTION -- A BIG PORTION OF
OUR WORK IS IN THE AREA OF
LANDLORD TENANT FOR EXAMPLE LAST
MONTH WE HELP A HUNDRED AND TWO
YEAR OLD WOMAN.
YOU MAY HAVE HEARD OF THIS AVOID
DEPENDING ELECTION BECAUSE OUR
LANDLORD HAD NOT PROPERLY SERVE
NOTICE.
OUR CALL CENTER WITH THE CALL
CENTER ENCOUNTERS WE HELP
TENANTS AND ALL CONSUMERS WITH
ISSUES THAT ARE DEEPLY
MEANINGFUL AND DEEP CONCERN TO
THEM.
N. F. BOTTOM BOTTOM CIVIL
PENALTIES PROVIDE MY DEPARTMENT
WITH THE FLEXIBILITY TO HELP
CONSUMERS WITH LOST THIRTY
DOLLARS FIFTY DOLLARS HUNDRED
DOLLARS.
THESE ARE CASES WHICH WILL
LIKELY NEVER RISE TO THE LEVEL
OF PROSECUTION WERE OFTEN THE
LAST LINE OF DEFENSE.
OF FORTY FOR THE COUNTIES
WORKING POOR ON SMALL DOLLAR
CONSUMER ISSUES AND CERTAINLY.
OF THE LA THIRTY DALY CITY
ATTORNEY HAS BROUGHT SOME IN
FACT PACKED FULL CONSUMER CASES
I VALUE MY PARTNERSHIP WITH MIKE
FEAR.
BUT BECAUSE IN CLOSING BECAUSE
CONSUMER CIVIL PENALTIES ARE ARE
CRITICAL TO MY DEPARTMENTS
OPERATIONS AND BECAUSE WE'RE THE
ONLY LOCAL CONSUMER AFFAIRS
AGENCY IN THE STATE OFFERING THE
SERVICES SERVICES.
I MUST RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
OF A THANK YOU THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IF YOU'D
STEP FORWARD -- NAME AND
AFFILIATION PLEASE.
HAPPENING CHAIR MEMBERS TO NISHA
VOTER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA
CLARA COUNTY IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MAR WE'RE GOING TO BRING THIS TO
THE COMMITTEE I JUST WANT TO
START AND I KNOW CENTER AKOWSKI
HAS QUESTION WE'LL GO FROM.
THERE A LOT OF QUESTIONS.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT OUT OF
A AS AN AMENDMENT THAT ARE I
INSIST UPON BECAUSE THIS IS ONE
OF THOSE THINGS YOU'RE NOT SURE
IF IT'S BROKEN -- IS IF THE
COUNTY IS IN ANY WAY INVOLVED IN
THE EARLY INVESTIGATION IF
THERE'S ANY INVOLVEMENT OF THE
COUNTY.
THEN THE WHATEVER SETTLEMENT IS
REACH WOULD BE SHARED EQUALLY AT
WHICH IS WHAT IS WHAT HAPPENS
NOW.
THAT REALLY THE ONLY DISTINCTION
HERE AS I UNDERSTAND IT AND
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG IS THAT
IF THIS IS OUR LITIGATION.
THAT IS COMMANDS AND EXECUTED
EXCLUSIVELY.
BY THE CITY ATTORNEY THEN THE
BAND THE THE FINANCIAL BENEFIT
WILL END IN NEAR TO THE TO THE
CITY ATTORNEY EXCLUSIVELY.
BOB RIGHT NOW WHAT HAPPENS IS IF
THE COUNTY.
HAS NO INVOLVEMENT THEY STILL
GET 50% OF WHATEVER THE JUDGMENT
OR SETTLEMENT IS.
THIS WILL SIMPLY.
A PROVIDE THAT -- THAT.
IF THERE IS NO WORK SHARING THEN
THERE.
DOESN'T GO THERE WON'T BE IN
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE ANY KIND OF
SETTLEMENT SHARING SO YOU YOU'RE
EAGER TO RESPONSE TO TELL ME OF
MY WRONG ON THIS.
YOU'RE NOT WRONG I THINK THERE'S
A LITTLE BIT OF A
MISUNDERSTANDING BECAUSE WE LOOK
ATIT DOESN'T SEEM FAIR WHOEVER
PUTS THE WORK IN AS SHOULD
SHOULD RECOVER THE BENEFIT BUT
THE THE PROBLEM IS THE CONSUMERS.
WHO ARE THE CONSUMERS BETTER
IMPACTED?
IN THE WELLS FARGO CASE IT
WASN'T A MATTER OF WELLS FARGO
OPENING FAKE ACCOUNTS ONLY IN
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES.
THE ENTIRE COUNTY -- CONSUMERS
WERE ALL IMPACTED BY THOUGHT.
WE WERE WE RECEIVE 50% OF THAT
RECOVERY FROM THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES WHICH WE ARE EXTREMELY
GRATEFUL FOR AND WE STARTED OUR
AFFIRMATIVE LIVE LITIGATION
DIVISION SO THAT WE CAN HELP
MORE.
COUNTY WIDE CONSUMERSTHE CASES
THAT ARE BROUGHT ARE GENERALLY
NOT JUST WITHIN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES.
EVERYBODY'S IMPACTED AND SO
THAT'S WHY THE WAY THE LAW IS
RIGHT NOW ACTUALLY MAKES SENSE
BECAUSE HALF OF THE MONEY WILL
GO TO THE CITY WHO HAS ABOUT 40%
IN LOS ANGELES OF THE
CONSTITUENTS.
AND THE REMAINDER WILL COME TO
THE COUNTY SO THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE THE SRVICES TO THE
OTHER CITIES THATDON'T HAVE --
THE STRONGER CITY ATTORNEYS AND
AND JOE MAY BE ABLE TO TALK MORE
ABOUT -- HOW HIS RELATIONSHIP
AND WORKING WITH THE?
WELL LET ME LET ME ASK THE
AUTHOR TO RESPOND TO THAT THE
ARGUMENT THEN SHARED IT SHOWING
WHY YOU'RE THE CHAIR YOU GOT
EXACTLY WHAT YOU DESCRIBED THE
BILL PERFECTLY.
AND I WOULD GUESS THAT YOU KNOW
IN TERMS OF DISCUSSING FAIRNESS
WELL THEN EVERY INSTANCE IT WAS
GIVEN A BY THE OPPOSITE
OPPONENTS THIS BILL TODAY IN
NONE OF THOSE SITUATIONS THAT
THE SENATE RETURNEES ARE
INVOLVED.
RECEIVE ANY OF THOSE AWARDS SO
YES THEY'RE PROSECUTING CASES
THAT IMPACT PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES IN THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES DOESN'T
SHARING THE WARDS THEY GET.
SO THIS IS ALL UPSIDE FOR THE
CURRENT COUNTIES ALL DOWNSIDE
FOR THE CITY ATTORNEY'S AND THAT
SIMPLY ISN'T FAIR WHAT WE'RE
DOING IS EXACTLY TO YOUR
BRILLIANT RECOMMENDATION IF
THEY'RE INVOLVED IN ANYWAY.
THEY WILL GET SOME OF THE TIMES
I'M I'M DETECTING A NOTE OF WHAT
WOULD I CALL IT.
WELL I DON'T KNOW.
OBSEQUIOUS THANK YOU THANK YOU
THERE ARE OTHER PHRASES BUT I
WAS TOO MANY USE THEM IN PUBLIC
OBSEQUIOUS DOES BUT I
APPRECIATED I AND I DO
APPRECIATE BECAUSE EVEN.
BRILLIANCE OF COURSE OF COURSE
THANK YOU CENTER UNANIMOUS MADAM
CHAIR BECAUSE AS YOU THIS
AMENDMENT THAT WE HAVE IN THIS
THAT IF THEY DO SOME WORK IN THE
PRE SHOPPERS.
THEY COULD DO A MINIMAL AMOUNT
OF WORK THERE STILL ANY AT 50%
OF THE AWARD RIGHT PART OF ME
WOULD STATE NOT YOU KNOW WILL
COULD BE COMMISERATE AMOUNT OF
WORK THAT YOU PUT AN END FOR NOT
SAYING THAT WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYONE HERE CAN GO.
HOME FEELING GOOD ABOUT WHAT WAS
DONE HERE THE CURRENT SITUATION
IS FUNDAMENTALLY UNFAIR
PERSISTING IN OUR DOING SOMEHOW
THE CITY ATTORNEY'S SHOULD HAVE
TO SHARE.
ALL THE PROCEEDS WITH IT DOING
ALL OF HALF THE PROCEEDS WERE
DOING ALL THE WORK.
IS SIMPLY INDEFENSIBLE.
SO IF A AND THEN I'M GOING TO
OPEN IT UP IT.
SO WHAT I HEAR THE COUNTY
COUNCIL SAYING IS THAT.
THAT BECAUSE THE IMPACTS ARE
BROADER THAN JUST THE CITY IN
SOME OF THESE INSTANCES.
THAT THE COUNTY COUNCIL SHOULD
GET A BENEFIT.
FROM THAT NOT IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY WHAT GOES TO THE
PEOPLE OF THE COUNTY.
IT'S THAT THE MONEY THAT'S GOING
TO COME IN AND WHAT WE WOULD
OTHERWISE REFERRED WAS
ATTORNEY'S FEES -- WILL COME TO
THE COUNTY -- HOW?
IS THAT.
SO WHAT WE DO WE THEN USE THE
MONEY TO ENFORCE CONSUMER
PROTECTION LAWS THROUGHOUT FOR
pCOUNTY AND WE ALL WITH THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN THE COUNTY
COUNSEL'S OFFICE NOT JUST OUR
OFFICE.
WELL WHAT ABOUT THE MONEY THAT
COMES IN FROM.
OF THE WORK YOU MENTIONED A
COUPLE THE CASES CONGRATULATIONS --
THAT YOU'VE TRUST COMPLY OR THAT
YOU HAVE COMPLETED WHERE YOU GOT
A 100% OF THE FEES ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT WHY.
AT THE END THE CITY DIDN'T GET
ANY AYE I DON'T THINK THE CITY'S
COMPLAINING ABOUT THAT IT'S
BASICALLY.
IF IF WE DO ALL THE WORK.
ALL THE WORK I MEAN EVERY BIT OF
THE WORK THEN IT SHOULD BENEFIT.
THE AGENCY THAT DID THE WORK.
WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW IS THAT IF
THE CITY DOES ALL THE WORK 50%
OF IT BY VIRTUE OF THE CURRENT
LAW HAS TO GO TO THE COUNTY
THAT'S THE ISSUE.
YES IT IS THE ISSUE BUT BUT
AGAIN IT GOES BACK TO MY FIRST
POINT WHICH WAS WHO BENEFITS
FROM IT.
NOT NECESSARILY OUR OFFICE THE
CONSTITUENTS AND THE
CONSTITUENTS ARE COUNTY WIDE SO
IF THE CITY IF THE CITY RECEIVES
ALL OF THE RECOVERY.
WHO REPRESENTS THE REST LIKE IN
WELLS FARGO WHO REPRESENTS THE
REST OF THE 60% OF THE COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES THAT'S OUR OFFICE?
OR THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY AND
WHEN OUR FUNDS ARE A DIMINISHED
IT MEANS LESS FOR INVESTIGATIONS
AND LESS WORK FOR THE REMAINING
60% OF THE OF THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES.
BUT THE CITY RESIDENTS WILL
BENEFIT FROM IT.
AND YOU DON'T THINK THAT THE BY
VIRTUE OF THE SUCCESS OF THE
CITY ATTORNEY WITH WELLS FARGO
THAT.
ACTUALLY ALL THE RESIDENTS TO
CALIFORNIA BENEFITTED.
RELIGION I DO THINK THEY BENEFIT
AND THAT AND AND ONE OF THE
WONDERFUL THINGS ABOUT IT IS
THAT WE RECEIVED HALF OF THAT
PENALTY.
OKAY THANK YOU.
FOR A CENTER WERE CASKEY
FOLLOWED BY -- CENTER MINING IN
AND SENATOR -- GONZALEZ MANAGER
YOUYOU WERE HITTING ON THE
POINT THAT I WAS LOOKING AT IS
FUNDAMENTAL FAIRNESS I THINK THE
THE THE WORK THAT YOUR OFFICE
SAYS IN THE WORK TO THE CITY
ATTORNEY DOES THE WORK IN ANY.
CITY TURN YOUR DH TO BENEFITS
EVERYBODY IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
OF THAT INJUNCTIVE RELIEF WE
STOP THE BAD ACTIVITY AND WE'RE
LOSING.
WE LOSING TRACK OF WHO GETS THE
SPOILS SURE.
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY VENTURA
COUNTY ALAMEDA COUNTY EVERYBODY
WANTS THE MONEY THEY GET IT
COMES IN BUT IT DOESN'T SEEM
FUNDAMENTALLY FAIR WHEN THEY'RE
DOING A 100% THE WORK.
AND YOU GUYS WANT TO SPEND MONEY
OF COURSE EVERY EVERY COUNTY
WANTS TO SPEND MONEY AND IT'S
NOT VICE VERSA I WAS GOING TO
ASK IF IF THEY DID HUNDREDS AND
THE WORK THEY GIVE SOME MONEY TO
THE THE CITY AND OBVIOUSLY THAT
ANSWER.
IS NO SO YOU ANSWERED ALL MY
QUESTIONS.
GO AROUND THE HORN WILL GO TO
SENATOR DRAWS SO NEXT.
I KNOW THE COUNTY HAS IT RAISE
THIS ISSUE BUT I WOULD BE
CONCERNED.
IS.
HAVING THIS HIT OF I DON'T KNOW.
HOW MUCH MONEY EXACTLY BUT ARE
WE TALKING ABOUT TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS OF SEVENTY MIL I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE?
ANSWER IS BUT IT SEEMS TO ME.
THAT YOU KNOW THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT AS A COUNTY.
THEY HAVE YOU HAVE TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT -- HOW DO YOU?
OF ILL USE THAT AMOUNT OF MONEY
ESPECIALLY IF YOUR DEPARTMENT IS
TRYING.
TO YOU KNOW JUST GOT UP AND
GOING AND AND MOVING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION AND I CERTAINLY
WANT YOU TO CONTINUE TO DO YOUR
WORK.
YOU BOTH ARE DOING GOOD THE
CITIES AND THE COUNTIES ARE
DOING GOOD WORK -- YOU KNOW --
FIGHTING BACK AGAINST THESE --
SO I WANT TO APPLAUD YOU FOR
THAT CONTINUE TO DO THE WORK.
OF SO I GUESS MY QUESTION WOULD
BE.
I GUESS THAT'S MY CONCERN ON
BEHALF I MEAN I SUPPORT.
THE CITY'S POSITION -- BUT I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT THE COUNTY.
TAKING THIS HIT IF THERE'S A WAY
MADAM CHAIR THAT -- THESE
CONVERSATIONS COULD CONTINUE
MAYBE THERE'S SOME RELIEF THERE
IF THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT THE
COUNTIES ARE INTERESTED THEN --
I WOULD THINK SUPPORTING THE
CITIES.
THINK THE THING THAT THE THE
STRIKES ME IS.
THERE IS AN AND I'M CONCERNED
THAT THE THAT.
THE THE AGENCIES CONTINUE TO
WORK TOGETHER.
OF BECAUSE IF THEY DO THEN BOTH
WILL BENEFIT SO I'VE TALKED TO
THE AUTHOR THE BILL AND COMPLEX
PRESS MY CONCERNED.
DAD IF IF I GET TO KEEP IT ALL
THEN I'M NOT GONNA SURE BECAUSE
I HAVE THE CHANCE TO KEEP IT ALL.
AND I WAS ASSURED THAT THAT IS
NOT.
AT LEAST IT HAS NOT BEEN THE
CASE.
AND I WOULD HOPE IT WOULD
CONTINUE NOT BEING THE CASE BUT
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE WERE YOU
WE CAN SOMETIMES BE TALKING
ABOUT SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNTS OF
MONEY.
THAT ONE PARTY COULD WANT TO
KEEP IT RATHER THAN TO SHARE IT
SO I WONDER COULD THE CITY
ATTORNEY OF LA JUST GIVE US.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT ISSUE YES
I AND I AND ALL ALL REFERENCE
BACK TO MY OPENING REMARKS THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT HAS
RECOGNIZED THAT THE PRIMARY
REMEDY.
ALL OF THESE CASES INJUNCTIVE
RELIEF AND SAW US AS PROSECUTORS
WE ARE NOT LOOKING TO GO AFTER
THESE CASES FOR MONEY WE ARE
LOOKING TO GO AFTER THE CASE IS
TO STOP THE OFFENDING CONDUCT.
AND WE TRUE WE GO INTO THIS
BUSINESS BECAUSE WE BELIEVE IT
IS IMPORTANT TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS WE ARE THERE FOR
CONSUMERS THE COUNTY IS THERE
FOR CONSUMERS IF THERE IS A
MATTER THAT WE CAN PURSUE
JOINTLY WITH THE COUNTER.
TO THE COUNTY TO VINDICATE
CONSUMERS YOU BETTER BELIEVE
WE'RE GOING TO WORK TOGETHER TO
DO IT.
THANK YOU SENATOR MONNING.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
SO QUESTION FOR THE COUNTY.
IF THIS CITY PARTICIPATE IN AN
INVESTIGATION OR PROSECUTION
THAT'S INITIATED BY THE COUNTY.
ARE YOU PREPARED TO SHARE HALF
OF ATTORNEYS FEES WERE COVERED
WITH THE CITY.
THAT I DON'T BELIEVE SO BECAUSE
THE CITY ONLY REPRESENTS THE
CITY RESIDENTS AND WE REPRESENT
ALL OF THE RESIDENTS IN THE
ENTIRE COUNTY BUT IF THEY WORK
WITH YOU ON THE CASE.
REPRESENTING THE CITY'S INTEREST.
UNDER THE CURRENT.
FORMULA WOULDN'T FAIRNESS
DICTATE.
THAT THEY WOULD ALSO SHARE.
IN A PROPORTION OF WHAT THE
COUNTY IN THE IN THE ONE UNDER
THE CURRENT LAW WE SHARE WHEN WE
WORK TOGETHER.
YOU SHARE WITH THE CITY.
IT'S SPLIT BETWEEN THE CLIP.
AND LET ME ASSIST IN ANY
[inaudible]
PROPOSED LEGISLATION.
IS THERE ANYTHING THAT PREVENTS
THAT THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES.
FROM INITIATING A CONSUMER
PROTECTION LITIGATION.
IN RECOVERING.
ATTORNEYS FEES IN THAT
[inaudible]
NOW [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SO IF I UNDERSTAND YOU CORRECTLY
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS WHEN THE
COUNTY INITIATE SOMETHING AND
WORKS WITH THE CITY.
THAT YOU SHARE THE FUNDS WHEN
WHEN THE TWO OF US BRING THE
CASES TOGETHER WE SPLIT THE
FUNDS.
NXP LIKE SOUTHERN THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA GAS CASE AND THAT'S
BECAUSE THE CITY HAS ALSO
BROUGHT THE CASE AND THEY ARE
REQUIRED TO SHARE WITH YOU.
BUT YOU'RE NOT REQUIRED TO SHARE
WITH THEM IS NOT THE CURRENT
STATE OF THE LAW.
WHEN WE BRING THE CASE BY
OURSELVES WE ARE NOT REQUIRED TO
SHARE IT WITH THEM?
BUT THEY'RE REQUIRED TO SHARE
WITH YOU OKAY THAT'S YEAH.
OKAY -- SEE CENTER GONZALEZ.
YES NOW I THINK THE AUTHORS WELL
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND I
WOULD ALSO AGREED -- I THINK WE
DO NEED TO THINK ABOUT A
CONSUMER THIS BILL AND I DON'T
KNOW THAT.
BUT I REVIEW THE BILL -- IT
DIDN'T SEEM THE ANYTHING
PRECLUDED THE COUNTY FROM
CONTINUING THIS GREAT WORK WHICH
MOST OF IT THAT I HAVE HERE IS
EXIDE PARAMOUNT WHICH SHOULD BE
AND IN MY DISTRICT -- WHICH ARE
VERY -- IMPORTANT -- PROJECTS
BUT AGAIN I HOPE THAT THIS WORK
AND WHATEVER HAPPENS TODAY THAT
IT WOULDN'T PRECLUDE THE COUNTY
FROM CONTINUING THE WORK AND AND
WORKING WITH THAT THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES -- IN SOME REGARD
BUT YOUR POINT ABOUT SMALLER
CITIES VERSUS LARGER CITIES
HAVING A DISTRICT THAT HAS ABOUT
TWELVE CITIES -- THE SMALLER
CITIES ARE NOT GOING TO SEE THIS
THESE FUNDS DIRECTLY PARAMOUNT
AND VERNON WILL NOT SEE THOSE
DOLLARS DIRECTLY -- BENEFITING
THEIR CONSTITUENCIES SO THAT'S
WHERE I HAVE AN ISSUE.
WITH THIS AS WELL I THINK WE'LL
LET'S CONTINUE TO WORK WITH AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT -- I HAVE SO
MANY REGIONAL BOARDS AS GAG I
MEAN SO MANY THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH AND I KNOW
THE COUNTY WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH TO BRING THESE ISSUES.
TO RUSSIAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AGAIN.
THANK YOU SENATOR BORDERS.
I HAVE A HEADACHE ON THIS ISSUE --
IN MY PREVIOUS CAPACITY AS A
CITY COUNCILMAN IN MY PREVIOUS
CAPACITY THE COUNTY SUPERVISOR
LIKE LITERALLY I'M HEARING BOTH
SIDES YELLING BACK AND FORTH
INSIDE MY HEAD.
ON THIS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT WHAT IS THE BEST PATH
FORWARD -- WHEN YOU WERE MOVING
WE WHEN YOU WERE --
CONTEMPLATING MOVING THIS
LEGISLATION.
DO YOU EVER CROSS YOUR MIND THAT
MAY BE. ONE OTHER OPTION MIGHT
BE TO DRAW THIS INTO THE REALM
OF THE REVENUE SHARING AGREEMENT.
BETWEEN A MUNICIPALITY IN THE
COUNTY.
BECAUSE IN MY EXPERIENCE -- IN
THOSE EARLIER CAPACITIES.
EVERY YEAR EVERY TWO YEARS WE
HAD A REVENUE TAX REVENUE
SHARING AGREEMENT.
ADEN AND OBVIOUSLY MOST YOU KNOW
WITH THE WITH PROPERTY TAXES
SOMEONE SO FORTH BUT IT NGUYEN
INTO THE FORM OF CONTRACT VIA
NEGOTIATION.
AND I THINK THE EQUITIES FLOATED
TO THE TOP IN THE REASON WHY THE
EQUITIES FLOATED THE TOP IS THE
COUNTY IS A DIFFERENT ANIMAL.
THEN THE CITY.
THE COUNTY PROVIDE SERVICES AT A
LEVEL THE CITIES DO NOT -- FOR
EXAMPLE MMHM MY UNDERSTANDING
MOST CITIES OR A LOT OF CITIES
DON'T PROVIDE SOCIAL SERVICES
RIGHT.
THE COUNTY DOES.
BOB CITIES DO NOT HAVE DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS -- ACROSS A BROAD
RANGE OF ISSUES ARE -- THE
CITY'S DON'T SO.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR PARITY.
AND IT'S SEDUCTIVE TO LOOK UPON
THIS AS IF YOU DO THE WORK YOU
SHOULD REAP THE REWARDS.
BUT THAT IS NOT THE REALITY IN
THE INTERCONNECTEDNESS OF OUR
CITY MUNICIPALITY COUNTY.
OUR RELATIONSHIP IT'S NOT AS
SIMPLE AS THAT SO THAT'S WHY I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT I THINK THE
IDEA IS GOOD BUT DID YOU EVER.
IN SOME POSE MY QUESTION --
THROUGH THE CHAIR OF SHE SO
WISHES TO YOU DID YOU EVER
CONSIDER THERE MIGHT BE
ALTERNATIVE -- IN MAKE IT IN THE
FORM OF AN OF COUNTIES
NEGOTIATING WITH THEIR CITIES OR
VICE VERSA [inaudible]
LET.
LET ME JUST.
BEFORE FROM JUMP I WOULD SAY
THAT YOUR YOUR EXPERIENCES ON
THE LOCAL LEVEL WOULD NOT BE
APPLICABLE IN THIS SITUATION
BECAUSE THE SIZE FIFTY YOU'RE.
ABOUT.
IS THE SAME CONCEPT IT IS
SIMILAR CONCEPTS BUT HE AYE AYE
AND STILL I DON'T THINK IT'S
APPLES TO APPLES WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING TO BE TALKING ABOUT
THREE EXTREMELY LARGE CITIES.
I WOULD TELL YOU THE CURRENT
STATE OF AFFAIRS IS REVENUE
SHARING IF YOU THE COUNTY RIGHT
IT IS NOT A HAPPY SHARE YOU
SHARE THE CITY WOULD SHARE THE
REVENUE WITH THE COUNTY
CURRENTLY THIS PROBLEM THAT WE
HAVE IS THAT IS NOT RECIPROCATED --
WITH THIS BILL SIMPLY SAYS YOU
KNOW IF YOU'VE DONE SOME WORK
YOUR REVENUE SHARING BUT THE
CITY THE COUNTY WOULD DO IT IF
THERE IS A SHARED EFFORT --
THERE ARE EXISTING EFFORTS WERE
NEGOTIATIONS ARE DONE TO DO
REVENUE SHARING THAT'S THE STATE
OF PLAY TODAY THE PROBLEM SIMPLY
IS WHEN THE COUNTIES BEING THE
ACTIONS THE CITY SHARES AND NONE
OF THAT -- IF THE COUNT OF THE
CITY DOES ALL THE WORK THE
COUNTY ALWAYS SHARE AND HALF OF
THAT THAT MAKES SENSE AND RICK
GERMAN YOU YOU YOU RE YOU
PROPERLY RESTATED THE THE RUB.
BY BUT MY QUESTION IS
OUTSTANDING STILL IS WAS THAT
EVER CONTEMPLATED AS A WAY OF
GETTING YOU GUYS THROUGH THIS OR
POPULATION CENTERS OVER.
SEVEN FIFTY GETTING YOU THROUGH
THIS BECAUSE OF THIS IS NOT
INSIGNIFICANT -- DEVELOPMENT IN
THE SEPARATION.
OF COUNTY MUNICIPALITY RELATIONS.
DID YOU EVER THINK THAT YOU
NEGOTIATION IS IS A WAY FORWARD
BY AMENDING THE LEGISLATION THAT
WOULD ALLOW.
FOR SOME NEGOTIATED OUTCOME.
IT IS TO SYNC ANSWERS NO SENATOR
BUT YOU ALREADY HEARD THE ANSWER
IF GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY THE
COUNTY WOULD NOT SHARE THE
PROCEEDS WITH THE CITIES THIS IS
NOT WHAT THEY'RE INTERESTED IN
DOING.
THIS BILL CREATES.
A ENDS THE UNFAIRNESS AND
CREATES EQUITY WHEN THEY'RE
SHARED -- EFFORT MADE.
OKAY -- HOLD ON THERE'S ANOTHER.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR FOR YOUR FOR
YOUR COMMENTS -- ARE I THINK
THAT AND THAT IS MY QUESTION
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
SO I THINK THE CONCERN IS IF I
MAY.
A KNOWING IN DISCUSSING THIS
WITH.
SENATOR DORADO AND ENTER HER
QUESTIONS AND ALL THEIR CONCERN
IS.
DAD IF THE COUNTY IF YOU WILL
WE'RE TO GO COLD TURKEY.
HOW ARE THEY GOING TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE DOING THEIR WRK WHAT I
HEARD THE LA CITY ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE SAY AND I'VE DISCUSSES
WITH THE CITY ATTORNEY DIRECTLY
IT IS NOT HIS INTENT? TO
ESSENTIALLY CLOSE OUT AND KEEP
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN THE
COUNTY OF LA OUT OF THESE.
EFFORTS -- ON THE OTHER HAND IF
THAT WERE TO TAKE PLACE THE
COUNTY WOULD LOSE ITS ABILITY TO
FUNCTION UNLESS THE COUNTY WERE
MORE ARGUABLY MORE PROACTIVE IN
BROUGHT ITS OWN CASES.
MY HOPE IS THAT YOU WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER. TO
THE EXTENT THAT BENEFITS THE
CONSUMERS.
OUR IN THIS AND SO -- IF THERE
IS A TIE I THINK WHAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE IS.
IN WE TALKED ABOUT THIS AND I
THINK SENATOR RAZA WAS
ARTICULATED AS WELL AND AND
ACTUALLY I THINK EVERYBODY HERE
WHAT WE GOT TO KEEP WORKING
TOGETHER WE'RE ON THE SAME TEAM
HERE.
TRYING TO PROTECT THE CONSUMER
SO -- THE BILL IT CURRENTLY IS A
THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR -- PERHAPS DID.
IF YOU WOULD BE WILLING TO DO
THAT NOW OR IF WE CONTINUE THIS
PERHAPS A WEEK AND GET SOME KIND
OF AGREEMENT THE EITHER THE TO
DELAY.
IMPLEMENTATION PERHAPS A YEAR SO
THAT THE DA'S OFFICE CAN.
SORT OF TRY TO IDENTIFY SOME
MECHANISMS BY WHICH IT MIGHT
WORK WITH YOU -- IN THE CITY
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE TO DO SOME
WORK SHARING.
VERSES -- RESULTS SHARING.
OR ONE OF THE SUGGESTIONS WAS --
TO HAVE A A SORT OF A REVISIT ON
THIS IN A COUPLE YEARS TWO TO
THREE YEARS TO SEE HOW IT'S
GOING AS A TRUST A COUPLE
OPTIONS HI.
YOU KNOW I WANT TO SUPPORT THIS
I UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS I WANT
TO TAKE EVERYBODY AT THEIR WORD
BECAUSE I DO THINK THAT THAT
WOULD BE IN THE BEST INTERESTS
OF EVERYBODY.
BUT I JUST WANT TO THROW THAT
OUT THERE AND AS CENTER MONEY IF
YOU'D LIKE TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT
THINK ON THAT POINT MADAM CHAIR
AND BE CURIOUS WHAT THE AUTHOR
THINKS AS WELL BUT I THINK THE
AMENDMENT.
THAT HAS BEEN TAKEN BY THE
AUTHOR.
PROVIDES THAT MECHANISM ALREADY
IF THE COUNTY WANTS TO GUARANTEE
ITS CONTINUED SHARE THEY NEED
ONLY PARTICIPATE.
AT THE INVESTIGATIVE LEVEL OF
THE CASE.
THEY'RE GUARANTEED HALF IS I
READ THE CURRENT BILL SO THAT IS
CORRECT ABOUT ECONOMIC IMPACT.
THEY NEED ONLY PARTICIPATE WITH
THE CITY ATTORNEY.
IN THE INVESTIGATION OF A
PENDING CASE.
I GUESS THE ONLY QUESTION IS
WOULD THE CITY ATTORNEY WANT TO
KEEP DOING THAT WHEN AT THE END
OF THE DAY THEY COULD GET THE
FULL NINE YARDS OR THE FULL
AMOUNT OF THE SETTLEMENT.
VERSUS HAVING TO SHARE IT AND IN
TALKING WITH THE CITY ATTORNEY
HE SAID HE IS MORE THAN HAPPY TO
KEEP WORKING WITH THE WITH THE
COUNTY -- AND I THINK THAT'S IF
THAT'S THE CASE THEN I THINK
WE'RE IN GOOD SHAPE HERE.
BUT THEN PERHAPS.
THERE MIGHT BE A DISCARDED. TO
REVISIT THIS AT SOME POINT I
DON'T KNOW WHETHER AGAIN A SOME
KIND OF I HESITATE TO SAY SUNSET
BUT SOME KIND OF PERHAPS OF
REPORTING.
SO THAT WE CAN SEE HOW THIS IS
ALL WORKING WOULD THAT BE
SOMETHING THAT THE AUTHOR WOULD
BE WILLING TO DO. FOR YOU AND
THE COMMITTEE HAVE MY IRON CLAD
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE TO
DISCUSS WITH ALL THE PARTIES
INVOLVED IN THIS MATTER TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE GET THE MOST
AGREEABLE OUTCOME FOR CONSUMERS --
I'D LIKE TO SEE THIS BILL
ADVANCE TODAY I APPRECIATE
CEREMONIES REFERENCE TO THE
AMENDMENT THAT I HAVE ALREADY
ACCEPTED IT AND I ASK MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE TAKE THAT AS A
TOKEN OF FAITH.
AGAIN THEY DO THE MINIMALIST
AMOUNT OF WORK AND THEY'RE GONNA
GET HALF OF THE AWARD A RIGHT
NOW THAT I THINK IS A SHOW OF MY
FAITH WANTED TO DO SOMETHING
GOOD IN THIS SPACE.
A WE CAN CONTINUE EXPLORE THE
CONCEPTS HAVE ADDITIONAL
DIALOGUE ON THIS BILL NEEDS TO
BEFORE MADAM CHAIR IT'S THE BEST
THING FOR CONSUMERS CALIFORNIA.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SENATOR OF
BOARD JUST ONE LAST QUESTION
HERE AND I'D WE NORMALLY DON'T
SPEAK TWICE BUT I I DO HAVE TO
MAKE A COMMENT -- BASE TO ONE
MADE EARLIER.
THERE IS A TENSION IN
INSTITUTIONAL TENSION THAT
EXISTS BETWEEN MUNICIPALITIES
AND COUNTIES.
THE IDEA OF PARTICIPATING AT THE
INVESTED INVESTIGATORY STAGES.
I THINK IT SOUNDS NICE I DON'T
THINK OUR THAT ONCE SOMETHING
LIKE THIS DEVELOPS.
THAT THE THE TERRITORIAL ISM.
WILL GO AWAY IN FACT IT WILL
INCREASE.
AND THAT THAT IS THAT IS MIKE MY
CONCERN MY CONCERN.
AND IT BUT I THINK THE CHEER I
DON'T KNOW WHERE IT'S AT RIGHT
NOW BUT I THINK.
IF THERE WERE A WAY OF PUTTING A
A SUNSET.
THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR THIS TO
DEVELOP WITHOUT BEING BOUND BY
THE CONSEQUENCES AND HAVING TO
RE INITIATE I THINK THAT COULD
BE A GOOD WAY FOR AN ITEM WHICH
I I COMMEND THE WORK THAT YOU'RE
DOING [inaudible]
YOUR YOU YOU'RE SWINGING FOR THE
FENCES AND I LIKE IT BECAUSE YOU
KNOW WE'RE DEALING WITH THE
STATE LEVEL BUT WHEN THIS IS AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL.
THIS IS REALLY WHERE THE CLAUSE
IN THE TEETH COME OUT.
IT'S VERY INTERESTING DYNAMIC --
BUT I DON'T KNOW IF YOU -- MY
ONLY RECOMMENDATION IS THAT IF
YOU WERE TO PUT A SUNSET IN
THERE I THINK A LOT OF FOLKS
WOULD PROBABLY LOOK UPON THAT AS
FRUITFUL AND ALLOW FOR MORE
ENGAGEMENT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER UP WHAT I'M
GONNA DO SAYS I'M GOING TO URGE
THAT WE MOVE THE BILL.
ON YOUR COMMITMENT AND MY
EXPERIENCE IS THAT YOU ARE MEN
OF GOOD FAITH AND YOU WILL HONOR
YOUR WORD IN THE CONVERSATION
WILL CONTINUE YOU'VE HEARD THE
CONCERNS HERE.
EVERYBODY WANTS YOU TO SUCCEED
ALL OF US TO SUCCEED WE NEED TO
HAVE A ROBUST ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM.
OUT THERE SO.
I'M GOING TO SUGGEST THAT --
WITH YOUR PROMISE AND IN GOOD
FAITH TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION THAT WE A PASS THIS
BILL AND THAT YOU WILL INDEED
CONTINUE TRYING TO RESOLVE THIS
LAST REMAINING ISSUE AND AND
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS UP TO
NOW TO DO THAT SO.
IS OUR MOTION MOTION BY A
SENATOR TO RISE SO -- AND WE
WILL LOCK -- MOVE FOR THE VOTE
ON THIS THE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN JACKSON
HI JACKSON AYE BORDERS.
BORDERS NO TO RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
JONES.
JONES NO MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN.
STERN I BURKE.
NUMBER GUY WHY KELSEY. SIXTY TO
SIXTY TWO WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE THE THE EFFORT HERE
IN THE WORK YOU'RE DOING -- AND
NOW TO THE VERY PATIENT
[inaudible]
AUTHOR.
OF THE FILE ITEM. SIXTEEN HER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RADIUS MY
APOLOGIES I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN
HERE AND HOPEFULLYYOU FOUND
THIS TO BE A FASCINATING WAY TO
SPEND YOUR DAY.
WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE YOU --
PRESENTING THIS BILL.
THIS IS AB.
FIFTEEN TEN WELCOME AND WOULD
LIKE TO GO AHEAD YOU HAVE TO
WITNESSES I SEE A TWO MINUTES
EACH -- BUT AT THIS POINT TIME
OPENING STATEMENT THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS.
FIRST I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
FOR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE ON
THIS BILL.
AB FIFTEEN TEN IS A RESPONSE TO
EGREGIOUS ACTS OF SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT THAT OCCURRED FOR
ALMOST THIRTY YEARS.
ON YOUR SEATS CAMPUS BY FORMER
SOUL.
FULL TIME GYNECOLOGIST DR GEORGE
TYNDALL.
IN MAY OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
THE LA TIMES BROKE THE STORY AS
A COVER UP BY U. S. C..
REGARDING SEXUAL MISCONDUCT OF
STUDENT PATIENTS BY TYNDALL AT
YOU ARE SO YOU STUDENT HEALTH
CENTER.
HE STARTED AT USC IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE AND OVER THE YEARS
IT IS ESTIMATED THAT OVER
FOURTEEN THOUSAND FEMALE
STUDENTS WERE IMPACTED.
IN HIS ASSAULTS ON THOUSANDS OF
WOMEN HE MADE RACIST REMARKS
TOWARD WOMEN OF COLOR AND
INTERNATIONAL STUDENTS.
AFTER THE UNIVERSITIES
INVESTIGATION U. S. C. QUIETLY
PAID TEN DAHLE TO GO AWAY AND
FAILED TO DISCLOSE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE FINDINGS OF THEIR
INVESTIGATION. TO THE STUDENTS
TO THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA OR TO LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THISBILL ALLOWS VICTIMS OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT THEIR DAY IN
COURT BY EXEMPTING FROM THE
CURRENT STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS.
CLAIMS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT AT
STUDENT HEALTH CENTERS THAT
OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE BEEN BARRED
PRIOR TO JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY WE HAVE COUNTLESS
VICTIMS WITHOUT RECOURSE.
THESE INCLUDE THE CURRENT AND
FORMER U. S. C. STUDENTS WHO ARE
VICTIMIZED BY DR KENDALL.
FAILURE TO DISCLOSE AND BRING TO
LIGHT COMPLAINTS OF DOCTOR
TYNDALE'S SEXUAL ASSAULT ON
STUDENTS ALLOWED HIM TO CONTINUE
TO ASSAULT.
THOUSANDS OF WOMEN FOR YEARS.
IT IS VITAL THE SURVIVORS ARE
PROVIDED WITH AN OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE THEIR DAY IN COURT AND THIS
BILL WILL PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL
YEAR. FOR SURVIVORS TO SEEK
JUSTICE.
HERE TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF
THIS BILL ARE YOU S. C.
SURVIVORS NICOLE HAYNES AND MY
MIZUNO.
WE ALSO HAVE ATTORNEY HOLLY
BOYER TO ANSWER ANY LEGAL
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS NICOLE HANSON I'M
HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FIFTEEN TEN DURING MY TIME AT
USC I SERVED AS CAPTAIN OF THE
TRACK TEAM.
SPECIALIZING IN THE HEPTATHLON
WHICH IS SEVEN EVENTS COMPETED
OVER TWO DAY PERIOD.
I WAS THE PAC TEN CHAMPION
SILVER MEDALIST OF THE NC DOUBLE
A CHAMPIONSHIPS COMPETED AT THE
OLYMPIC TRIALS.
AND IN THE DECADE AFTER
GRADUATION BECAME A PRO TRACK
ATHLETE.
AFTER RETIRING I BECAME A SPORTS
JOURNALIST AND FOR A TIME
COVERED USC SPORTS.
I AM A TROJAN TO THE CORE AND
THAT'S WITH MADE.
COMING FORWARD TO SPEAK ABOUT
THE ABUSE THEY SUFFERED AT THE
HANDS OF DOCTOR TYNDALL SO.
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT.
I'M AN OVERALL VERY HEALTHY
PERSON I VERY RARELY GET SICK --
ACTUALLY NEVER MISSED A DAY OF
SCHOOL FROM KINDERGARTEN THROUGH
HIGH SCHOOL DUE TO ILLNESS SO
THAT'S WHY THE MEMORY OF THE
ENCOUNTER I HAD WITH DOCTOR
TYNDALL.
IS SO VIVID.
IT WAS IN NINETEEN NINETY FIVE
DURING MY JUNIOR YEAR IN COLLEGE.
I WENT TO THE S. C. HEALTH
CENTER BECAUSE I WAS
EXPERIENCING DIARRHEA.
AND THE MOST EXCRUCIATING
STOMACH PAIN HAD EVER FELT.
IT WAS THERE THAT I CAME UNDER
THE CARE OF DOCTOR TYNDALL.
I WAS IN SO MUCH PAIN.
I JUST WANTED TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF MY ILLNESS.
SO I COULD BE TREATED IN THE
PAIN WOULD JUST GO AWAY.
WHEN I WAS TOLD TO GET UNDRESSED?
AND TO PUT MY LEGS UP IN THE
STIRRUPS.
I COMPLIED.
THE EXPERIENCE IT WASN'T EASY BY
ANY MEANS -- IN ADDITION TO THE
ALMOST BLINDING STOMACH PAIN
THAT I WAS EXPERIENCING -- I WAS
PUT THROUGH THE ORDEAL OF A FULL
A VAGINAL EXAM.
THAT WAS MY FIRST GYNECOLOGICAL
VISIT AND I WAS A VIRGIN AT THE
TIME.
AFTER HE WAS DONE WITH MY EXAM.
HE CAME UP.
AND SAID.
YOU HAD FOOD POISONING.
GO BACK TO YOUR DORM AND IT'LL
PASS IN A COUPLE HOURS.
I WAS VERY CONFUSED WHY I HAD TO
GO THROUGH A FULL VAGINAL EXAM
JUST FOR SIMPLE FOOD POISONING.
DIAGNOSIS.
BUT YOU KNOW I TRUSTED THE
DOCTOR.
AND I DIDN'T QUESTION IS ACTIONS.
BUT NOTHING ABOUT THAT DAY THAT
WILL MY SPIRIT.
I'VE BEEN TO MILLIONS OF DOCTORS
APPOINTMENTS AND I'VE YOU KNOW.
I'VE I REMEMBER THIS ONE LIKE IT
WAS YESTERDAY.
BUT IT WASN'T UNTIL I STARTED
READING ABOUT THE STORIES.
OF DOCTOR TEN THE LAST YEAR.
IN THE NEWSPAPER THAT.
MY CONFUSION ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED
TO ME IN NINETEEN NINETY FIVE
BECAME CRYSTAL CLEAR.
DR TYNDALL VIOLATED ME.
I WAS PUT THROUGH THE ORDEAL FOR
VAGINAL EXAM FOR SOMETHING
TOTALLY.
AND RELATED TO MY DISEASE HE
PRAYED ON MY YOUTH.
AND MY NAY OF IT TODAY.
LIKE OVER SEVEN HUNDRED OF MY
TROJAN SISTERS.
I WAS SEXUALLY ASSAULTED BY
SOMEONE WHO WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
MY TRUSTED DOCTOR.
A DOCTOR THAT USC KEPT EMPLOYED
AND ALLOWED TO TREAT YOUNG WOMEN
[inaudible]
LIKE ME.
LONG AFTER REPORTS OF ABUSE HAVE
BEEN REPORTED.
MY MOTHER WAS ABUSED AS A CHILD
AND SHE ALWAYS IMPRESSED UPON ME
IF SOMEBODY EVER VIOLATED ME TO
SPEAK UP.
I NOW HAVE A FOUR YEAR OLD
DAUGHTER AND I'M CONSTANTLY
TALKING WITH HER ABOUT HOW SHE
SHOULD AND SHOULDN'T BE TOUCH.
SO I JUST I HAD TO SPEAK UP.
AND COME FORWARD AND NOT JUST
FOR ME BUT FOR MY MOM AND FOR
THE HUNDREDS OF USC WOMEN WHO.
HAVE SAT IN THEIR SHAME FEAR AND
MISTRUST BECAUSE OF THE VIEWS
THEY SUFFERED BY SOMEONE WHO IS
SUPPOSED TO CARE FOR THEM.
THE SYSTEM IS NOT WORKING.
WHEN THIS TYPE OF BEHAVIOR IS
ALLOWED TO CONTINUE FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS?
THE SYSTEM IS BROKEN WHEN THOSE
GOOD NURSES WHO REPORTED THIS
HORRENDOUS CONTENT CONDUCT WERE
MET WITH INACTION OR EVEN WORSE
A COVER UP.
THE SYSTEMIC FAILURE IS
CONTINUING AND NOW AS WE TRY TO
BRING OUR CASE TO A COURT OF LAW.
THE ENTITY THAT ALLOWED THE
ABUSE UFC.
IS CLAIMING THAT ARE QUE
DEADLINES AND STATUTES OF
LIMITATIONS LIMIT OUR RIGHTS AND
OUR VOICES.
I REMEMBER WHEN THE WHOLE LARRY
NOW SORRY USA GYMNASTICS.
STORY BROKE OUT WITH.
SECOND I CAN BELIEVE USA
GYMNASTICS ALLOW THIS MAN TO
VIOLATE THESE YOUNG WOMEN FOR SO
MANY YEARS AND ME BEING.
AN ATHLETE I WAS TOTALLY INTO IT
I WAS WATCHING EVERY DAY I SAW
THOSE YOUNG GIRLS TESTIFY AND I
WAS SO PROUD THAT THEY GOT UP
THERE.
LO AND BEHOLD I AM IN THE SAME
SITUATION AND I NEVER GOT MY DAY
IN COURT I NEVER GOT TO FACE
THIS MAN AND ASK ISSUE WHY YOU
ALLOWED THIS TO HAPPEN.
AB FIFTEEN TEN GIVE SURVIVORS
LIKE ME.
WHO HAVE COME FORWARD A CHANCE
TO HOLD THOSE WHO HARM DEATH
ACCOUNTABLE?
IT GIVES US A CHOICE.
WE CAN CHOOSE OUR OWN PATH TO
JUSTICE.
USC'S UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT
GOVERNMENT VOTED UNANIMOUSLY TO
PASS A RESOLUTION TO SUPPORT AB.
FIFTEEN TEN I URGE YOU TO JOIN
ME.
MY ASIAN SISTERS MY AFRICAN
AMERICAN SISTERS MY LATINO
SISTERS MY ANGLE SISTERS.
PLEASE PLEASE SUPPORT THIS
IMPORTANT BILL. OH AND ONE LAST
REQUEST -- I HAVE COPIES OF THE
USC RESOLUTIONS HERE CAN THE
SERGEANT PLEASE DISTRIBUTE WILL
ASK THE SERGEANT TO DO THAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
INCREASED SO MUCH.
IN YOUR HERE TO ANSWER ANY
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS OR DID YOU
WANT TO TESTIFY AS WELL.
ALL RIGHT PLEASE.
BRIEFLY IF YOU WOULD.
I COULD AFTERNOON CHAIR IN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MY NAME IS
YOU KNOW AND I'M HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB.
FIFTEEN TEN I WAS A FRESHMAN
WHEN I WENT TO THE U. S. C.
HEALTH CENTER FOR A CONSULTATION
ABOUT THE BIRTH CONTROL METHOD I
WAS TAKING.
I REQUESTED A FEMALE
GYNECOLOGIST BUT WAS TOLD THAT
DR TUNNEL WAS THE ONLY CAMPUS
GYNECOLOGIST.
WHEN I RIDE FOR MY APPOINTMENT
DOCTOR TO KNOW IMMEDIATELY ASKED
ME IF I WAS JAPANESE?
I CAN TELL BY YOUR LAST NAME HE
SAID.
DOCTOR TO KNOW THEN ASKED IF I
HAD DONE A PELVIC EXAMINATION
BEFORE I HAD NOT HE REACTED AS
IF THIS WAS LUDICROUS AND
INSISTED I NEEDED TO HAVE ONE
DONE THAT DAY.
I BELIEVED IN HIS CREDIBILITY AS
A DOCTOR'S SO I ALLOWED HIM TO
TAKE ME TO THE EXAMINATION ROOM.
I DIDN'T REALIZE THAT THERE WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE A CHAPERONE IN
THE ROOM AND I CERTAINLY DIDN'T
REALIZE WHAT WAS ABOUT TO HAPPEN.
AS HE PULLED MY LEGS APART AND
SECURED MAY FEET IN THE STIRRUPS
HE STARTED TALKING ABOUT EAST
ASIA AGAIN.
AND AS HE STARTED HIS
EXAMINATION HI.
HE COMMENTED ON THE AESTHETICS
OF MY BODY.
HE TOUCHED MY BREAST AND THEN AS
HE INSERTED HIS FINGERS INSIDE
OF ME OVER AND OVER HE ASKED ME
WHAT WAS WOMEN'S SEX LIFE WAS
LIKE.
HOW IT FELL DURING SEX IF I
ENJOYING SEX AND IF I HAD A
BOYFRIEND?
I WAS NINETEEN YEARS OLD.
I DIDN'T KNOW THAT AT THE TIME
U. S. YOU HAD ALREADY RECEIVED
RECEIVED DECADES OF COMPLAINTS
AGAINST THIS THE DOCTOR.
I DIDN'T KNOW THAT USC HAD HIRED
A TEAM OF MEDICAL EXPERTS TO
EVALUATE HIM.
I DIDN'T KNOW THAT THEIR REPORT
CONCLUDED THAT DOCTOR TYNDALL
PREYED ON ASIAN STUDENTS WHO.
BECAUSE OF CULTURAL REASONS ARE
LESS LIKELY TO RECOGNIZE HER
HUSBAND OR LODGE A COMPLAINT.
I DIDN'T KNOW ANY OF THIS BUT U.
S. C. DID.
AND STILL THEY DID NOT NOTIFY
LAW ENFORCEMENT OR THE STATE
MEDICAL BOARD OF ITS INTERNAL
REPORT. TWO MONTHS AGO I MET
WITH FELLOW SURVIVORS OF DOCTOR
TO KNOW SEXUAL ABUSE THERE WERE
WOMEN IN THEIR SIXTIES TO WOMEN
IN THEIR EARLY TWENTIES LIKE ME.
ARE ONLY COMMON DENOMINATOR
DENOMINATORS SHOULD HAVE BEEN
THAT WE IDENTIFIED AS WOMAN AND
AS TROJANS.
BUT ALL OF THAT WAS OVERSHADOWED
BY THE FACT THAT WE ALSO SHARE
THE SAME ABUSER.
DR DENTALS ABUSE CONTINUED YEAR
AFTER YEAR AND DECADE AFTER
DECADE.
I SPOKE WITH WOMAN LIKE MISS
HAYES WHO HAD REPORTED THEIR
ABUSE TO USC BEFORE I WAS EVEN
BORN.
I AM STILL IN SHOCK NO THE
NUMBERS IS ONE THING. TO MEET
THE WOMAN TO KNOW THE WOMAN AND
TO CONSIDER THEM MY SISTERS
SURVIVORS IS ANOTHER.
BY THE TIME OTHERS OTHERS CHOSE
TO LISTEN IT WAS TOO LATE BUT
WITH AB FIFTEEN TEN WE HAVE A
CHANCE TO ALLOW MY FELLOW
SURVIVORS.
TO AT LEAST ACCESS LEGAL JUSTICE.
LAST MONTH I BECAME A GRADUATE
OF THE UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
AND JOIN THE RANKS OF OTHER
ALUMNI.
IN DOING SO I REFLECTED AS TO
WHAT IT MEANS TO BE A PART OF
THE TROJAN FAMILY.
I'VE COME TO THE CONCLUSION THAT
TO BE A TROJAN MEANS TO TRULY
EMBODY OUR SCHOOL MOTTO. TO NOT
JUST FIGHT ON BUT TO FIGHT ON
FOR SOMETHING THAT MATTERS.
IN THIS CASE TO STAND WITH
SURVIVORS IN TO DEMAND JUSTICE.
I HOPE YOU WILL SUPPORT OUR
FIGHT THANK YOU [inaudible]
VERY MUCH.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
PLEASE COME FOR WITH YOUR NAME
AND AFFILIATION [inaudible]
THANK.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SERRA FLOCKS
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
JANUARY TERRACE ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS AND THE THOUSANDS OF
HEALTH CARE WORKERS WE REPRESENT
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THE KIND OF JENKINS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CIVIL LIBERTIES
ADVOCACY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MEGAN SUPERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU -- I'M CHRISTOPHER
MARIN AND UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT
GOVERNMENT SENATOR FROM USC ON
BEHALF OF THE UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENT BODY AND SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS HALEY GARLAND I'M A
STUDENT SENATOR AT USC SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENT BODY AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
STEPHANIE GOLDMAN OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
RIGHT BEFORE WE GET TO THE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION THE
MOTHER IN ME SAYS.
DO NOT BLAME YOURSELVES THIS WAS
NOT YOUR FAULT.
WITH THAT LET'S HAVE THE
OPPOSITION COME FORWARD.
YOU CAN TAKE SEATS AT THE TABLE.
TWO TWO WITNESSES PLEASE
. ONE
SECOND THERE'S SERGEANTS
DELIVERING THESE DOCUMENTS TO
WILL.
WE ON GO AHEAD AND HELLO YES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHELLE WELCOME
ON BEHALF OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND IN
OPPOSITION TO AB.
FIFTEEN TEN SHORTLY AFTER THE
FIRST FEDERAL CLASS ACTION
LAWSUIT WAS FILED.
THE UNIVERSITY ENTER INTO
MEDIATION TO BEGIN TO PUT
TOGETHER A COMPREHENSIVE
SETTLEMENT PACKAGE THAT WOULD
COMPENSATE.
EVERY SINGLE WOMAN WHO SAW
DOCTOR TYNDALL.
IT ALSO INCLUDED SWEEPING
INSTITUTIONAL REFORMS THAT MAKE
USC A SAFER ENVIRONMENT FOR ALL
U. S. C. STUDENTS.
US HE HAS COMMITTED TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS THE
FEDERAL SETTLEMENT THAT WILL
PROVIDE.
EVERY WOMAN WHO SAW DOCTOR
TYNDALE A PRIVATE RESPECTFUL AN
EXPEDITED REMEDY.
MONTHS AFTER NEGOTIATIONS HAVE
BEEN UNDERWAY.
AND ONLY AFTER THE SETTLEMENT
WAS FILED IN FEDERAL LAWSUIT WAS
A. B. FIFTEEN TEN INTRODUCED.
THE AUTHORS CLAIM THAT THE BILL
IS NECESSARY IN ORDER FOR WOMEN
WHO ARE CURRENTLY BARRED BY THE
STATUE OF LIMITATIONS. TO
RECEIVE COMPENSATION FOR THEIR
INJURIES.
THIS BILL.
IS NOT NECESSARY TO ACCOMPLISH
THAT GOAL.
THE AUTHOR HAS ALSO STATED.
THAT THIS BILL IS NECESSARY
BECAUSE USC HAS ENGAGED IN
FRAUDULENT CONCEALMENT.
WE DISPUTE THAT ASSERTION.
AND EVEN IF THAT WERE TO BE THE
CASE [inaudible]
CURRENT LAW.
HOLD THE REMEDY IN THOSE CASES.
SO THEN WHY ARE WE HERE.
WHY DOES THIS PARTICULAR
SETTLEMENT?
REQUIRE LEGISLATIVE INTERVENTION.
IT IS OUR POSITION THE JUDICIAL
SYSTEM IS THE APPROPRIATE VENUE.
TO DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THE
SETTLEMENT IS FAIR AND
REASONABLE.
AND JUST LAST WEEK ON THURSDAY
WE HAD A FEDERAL JUDGE WHO AFTER.
REVIEWING REAMS OF EVIDENCE.
OF DATA OF STATEMENT.
GRANTED THIS SETTLEMENT
PRELIMINARY APPROVAL.
MADE PUBLIC COMMENTS.
THAT THIS SETTLEMENT IS IN FACT
FAIR AND REASONABLE.
THIS IS WHY USC OPPOSES AB
FIFTEEN TEN AND THE DANGEROUS
PRECEDENT THAT IT SUCKS.
YOUR ANALYSIS ACCURATELY STATES.
BUT YES THE LEGISLATURE HAS THE
DISCRETION TO RETROACTIVELY OPEN
UP STATURE LIMITATIONS HOWEVER
IT CAUTIONS AS DO THE COURTS.
THAT THAT DISCRETION SHOULD BE
USED SPARINGLY.
THIS SITUATION DOES NOT RISE TO
THAT LEVEL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CAN I JUST REALLY WRAP UP THE
WHO WOULD.
WHERE THEY GOT MORE TIME THEY
HAD A STORY TO TELL YOU'RE
DEFENDING THE SITUATION I WANT
TO GIVE YOU TIME SO OUR APP WRAP
IT UP PLEASE?
SO -- LAWCENTER THOUGHT I WOULD
ASK FOR YOU TO CONSIDER WHETHER
OR NOT IF IT IS.
IF IT IS.
SOMETHING EXTRAORDINARY THEN WHY
IS LIMITED TO PRIVATE
UNIVERSITIES IN ADDITION I WOULD
ASK THE CONSIDER WHETHER THE
LEGISLATURE IS THE SHOULD HAVE
THE ROLE OF SUPPLANTING A
THOUGHTFUL TRADITIONAL ANALYSIS
THAT HAS DETERMINED THAT THE
SETTLEMENT IS FAIR AND
REASONABLE AND WITH THAT I WOULD
ASK THAT YOU VOTE NO.
ON AB.
FIFTEEN TEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
IS ME I AM DOCTOR ELIZABETH
SHARON DAVIS I AM THE PRESIDENT
OF THE SACRAMENTO CHAPTER OF THE
NATIONAL COALITION OF ONE
HUNDRED BLACK WOMEN.
THE NATIONAL COALITION OF ONE
HUNDRED BLACK WOMEN SACRAMENTO'S
CHAPTERS MISSION IS TO ADVOCATE
ON BEHALF.
OF AFRICAN AMERICAN GIRLS AND
WOMEN TO PROMOTE LEADERSHIP
DEVELOPMENT AND ECONOMIC
EMPOWERMENT.
THAT MISSION IS WHAT BRINGS ME
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE TODAY ON
BEHALF.
OF OUR COALITION WHICH ALSO
INCLUDES THE FREDERICK DOUGLASS
FOUNDATION.
EXCUSE ME OF CALIFORNIA.
THE DOUGLAS INSTITUTE.
AND THE CALIFORNIA CLERGY AND
THEIR CONGREGATION.
THE ACTIONS OF DOCTOR GEORGE
TENDO AT U. S. C..
IS THIS IS DISTASTEFUL.
THE WOMEN WHO HAVE BEEN
VICTIMIZED BY THIS MAN DESERVES
JUSTICE.
THE CURRENT CONVERSATION
HAPPENING HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THE COUNTRY SURROUNDING
SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
AND ASSAULT IS LONG OVERDUE.
I AM PLEASED TO LEGISLATOR IS
LOOKING INTO THIS MATTER
SERIOUSLY HOWEVER.
THESE CONVERSATIONS LARGELY
EXCLUDES AREAS VICTIMS MORE
SPECIFICALLY VICTIMS OF COLOR.
WHILE I'M GRATEFUL THAT AB
FIFTEEN TEN HAS BROUGHT FORTH A
DIALOGUE ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
I APPRECIATE THE SPIRIT OF THIS
LEGISLATION.
AB FIFTEEN TEN AS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN COMES UP SHORT FOR OUR
COMMUNITY AND FRANKLY FOR THE
ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AS WRITTEN AB FIFTEEN TEN DOES
NOTHING FOR STUDENTS ATTENDING
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
CAMPUSES FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES.
TOGETHER U. S. C..
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
CAMPUSES.
EDUCATE MORE THAN SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS.
I I AGREE WITH BRANDON HE'LL WHO
WROTE IN THE USA TODAY THIS WEEK
AS IT RELATES TO HER EXPERIENCE
AS A U. S. C. VICTIM.
THAT SHE HOPES TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE TO LEGISLATION
FOR ALL WOMEN'S VICTIMS AND
SURVIVORS.
TODAY WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ACHIEVE THAT GOAL.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THE BILL IS
SHORT HAS FALLEN SHORT.
TODAY I AM PROUD TO BE HERE TO
ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF SO MANY
THAT REMAIN IN THE SHADOWS.
I WANT TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS IN THE SENATE WHO HAS
MET WITH US TO DISCUSS THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
AND I HOPE THAT THIS COMMITTEE.
WILL DO THE RIGHT THING AND A
MAN.
AB FIFTEEN TEN TO SUPPORT ALL
SURVIVORS.
AND FINALLY I WOULD LIKE TO
CONCLUDE WITH A SINCERE QUESTION
TO THE COMMITTEE.
WHY DOES THIS BILL NOT INCLUDE
VICTIMS FROM PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS?
AND WHY NOT AMEND THIS BILL TO
SUPPORT ALL SURVIVORS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY ALL RIGHT
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IF
YOU'D STEP FORWARD DAMON
AFFILIATION.
PLEASE.
I AM VALERIE SPAKE UCLA GRADUATE
I WANT YOU TO CONSIDER OPPOSING
THIS BILL UNLESS AMENDED THANK
YOU.
NEXT NEXT WITNESS.
I'M ON A LOCAL LOS RIOS
COMMUNITY COLLEGES UNLESS
AMENDED -- OPPOSING THANK YOU.
EMILY RIVERS RESIDENT OF MERCED
COUNTY AND PREVIOUS ATTENDEE OF
MERCED COLLEGE OPPOSE THANK YOU.
CAROLINE MULLINS RESIDENT OF
SACRAMENTO COUNTY GRADES WITH A
VIEW OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA DAVIS AND OPPOSED N
LAST AMENDED TO INCLUDE ALL
SURVIVORS THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS AARON WILLIS -- ITEM
OPPOSITION -- TWO AB FIFTEEN TEN
RESIDENT INCLUDES [inaudible]
ALSO VACANCY.
MY NAME IS EVELYN FRAZIER I'M A
GRADUATE OF CHAPMAN UNIVERSITY
I'M OPPOSED TO THIS BILL UNLESS
IT COULD INCLUDES ALL SURVIVORS
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ERICA WILLIS AND
I'M OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL AS
IT'S AMENDED TO OUGHT TO ALSO
RISE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KAY LOCAL NO YES I'M
A RECENT GRADUATE OF SACRAMENTO
STATE UNIVERSITY.
AND I OPPOSES BILL UNLESS IT.
UNLESS IT INCLUDES ALL SURVIVE
THANK YOU.
SIR FOSTER RESIDENTS OF
SACRAMENTO NAY GRADUATE OF UC
BERKELEY CLASS OF FIFTY FIVE AYE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
ALL THE REASONS GIVEN IT HAS TO
INCLUDE ALL SURVIVE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLACE.
MY NAME IS MARYANN HOLSTON I'M A
UC DAVIS ALUMNI AND I'M HERE IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU -- TOPS I AM.
VERY CHILDHOOD CAN WE CAN'T HEAR
YOU CAN YOU MOVE A LITTLE CLOSER
POSE UNLESS IT'S MENDED FOR ALL
VICTIMS THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON LOUISA WOODROW
GRADUATE OF SANTA BARBARA AND
I'M OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ERIC REGARD I AM A
RESIDENT HERE IN ELK GROVE --
ALSO GRADUATE OF UCLA AND I JUST
THAT WE AMEND THE BILL.
IN ORDER FOR TO BE PASSED THANK
YOU.
HI KEVIN MY GARY CHAIRMAN OF THE
FREDERICK DOUGLASS FOUNDATION OF
CALIFORNIA WE OPPOSE UNLESS IT'S
AMENDED TO INCLUDE ALL SURVIVOR
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JUANITA CAREER AND I
RESIDE IN SOLANO COUNTY I AM A
PASTOR AND ALSO OPPOSE THIS BILL
UNLESS AMENDED FOR ALL SURVIVOR
THANK YOU.
FOR MERRIAM WATERMAN AND I'VE
BEEN A VICTIM OF SAN JOSE STATE
AND I AGREE WITH THEM NO UNLESS
AT SOME.
AMENDED I OPPOSE THANK YOU.
HELLO I AM I AM MILLION A TAILOR
I AM A GRADUATE OF UC DAVIS AND
A MOTHER TWO DAUGHTERS.
THIS THIS UNLESS IT'S AMENDED
AND I AM SO SORRY FOR YOUR
EXPERIENCES THANK YOU.
ANITA JOHNSON RESIDENT OF
SACRAMENTO COUNTY I OPPOSE THE
BILL.
THANK YOU.
VETERANS PHYLLIS JOHNSON I'M OF
RESIDENTS OF A EL DORADO COUNTY
AND I PULLED HIS BILL UNLESS IT
INCLUDES ALL SURVIVORS THANK YOU.
I MEDINA BOYLAN I'M A RESIDENT
OF SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I
OPPOSE AB FIFTEEN TEN UNLESS IT
APPLIES TO ALL SURVIVORS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
DANNY SMITH RETIRED LAW
ENFORCEMENT OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
TELL US TO BE APPROPRIATE TIME.
FOR THE IN BETWEEN.
ARE YOU ALL RIGHT.
EIGHT HI ALEX GRAVES WITH THE
ASSOCIATION INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES UNIVERSITIES
WE DON'T HAVE AN OPPOSE POSITION
ON THE BILL I WE DO HAVE TWO
CONCERNS AS WANTED BRIEFLY SHARE --
ONE OF WHICH HAS BEEN MATCH I
THINK BY NUMBER OF FOLKS FOR ME
AND THE OTHER IS JUST -- BURNHAM
OF OUR SCHOOLS THE CHALLENGE TO
POTENTIALLY GO BACK UP TO THIRTY
YEARS -- IN GATHERING EVIDENCE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY OTHER WITNESSES HAVE OPPOSE
YOUR ANY WITNESSES NEUTRAL ON
THIS.
AFTER BRUCE RIVERS LOS BANOS
CALIFORNIA MERCED COUNTY FORMER
STUDENT AT MONTEREY PENINSULA
JUNIOR COLLEGE LANEY JUNIOR
COLLEGE AND CAL STATE UNIVERSITY
NORTHRIDGE WHICH HAD THE NUMBER
ONE DIVISION ONE MEN'S TRACK
TEAM BACK IN THE DAY.
AND I KNOW THIS A MORE TEN
DALE'S OUT THERE BECAUSE I HEARD
STORIES AS I WAS GOING TO
COLLEGE IN THE SEVENTIES FORTY
ONE YEARS AGO AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL UNLESS IT INCLUDES ALL.
STATE UNIVERSITIES ALL UC'S
SINKING AND ALL JUNIOR COLLEGE
THANK YOU SIR.
OKAY LET'S BRING IT BACK. TO THE
TABLE THIS IS OBVIOUSLY A VERY
EMOTIONAL ISSUE YOU KNOW.
ALL OF US.
AS WOMEN HAVE BEEN THROUGH WHAT
IS ALMOST INHERENTLY A SOMEWHAT
HUMILIATING EXPERIENCE OF GOING
THROUGH A GYNECOLOGICAL EXAM IT
IS.
AMONG THE MOST VULNERABLE
MOMENTS IN ONE'S LIFE AND TO
HAVE.
INJURED THIS EXPERIENCE IS
[inaudible]
OF JUST THE TAKES MY BREATH WAY
AND SO I APPRECIATE THE
TESTIMONY.
OF ALL OF YOU THEIR MEANING FULL
AND I KNOW THAT THERE ARE OTHERS
THAT.
THIS KIND OF TREATMENT OF WOMEN
IS GONE ON SINCE THE BEGINNING
OF TIME AND HOPEFULLY NOW WE ARE
WE'RE GONNA STOP IT.
UP.
IT'S JUST NOT A IT'S IT'S BEYOND
DISTASTEFUL I THOUGHT THAT WAS
ONE OF THE UNDERSTATEMENT OF THE
DAY IT IS ABSOLUTELY
UNACCEPTABLE BEHAVIOR.
SO YOUR TESTIMONY COMING FORWARD
REALLY MEANS A LOT.
AND I THINK THAT WE CAN ALL
AGREE THAT THAT THE ABUSE HERE
WAS JUST ABOMINABLE AND AND WE
HAVE TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
MAKE SURE THIS TRUST DOESN'T
HAPPEN.
EVER AGAIN GOING FORWARD AND
CERTAINLY LOOKING BACK TO THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE.
CLEARLY DOCUMENTED EVIDENCE OF
THIS MAN'S BEHAVIOR OVER THE
COURSE OF THIRTY YEARS -- I
THINK WHAT IS OF PARTICULAR
CONCERN.
AND I WOULD ASK THE AUTHOR -- TO
TO FOLLOW UP ON THIS IS THE FACT
THAT NOT ONLY DID THIS HAPPEN.
BUT THAT THE UNIVERSITY WAS WELL
AWARE OF THIS AND ALLOWED IT TO
CONTINUE FOR YEARS [inaudible]
THAT.
OF IT WE KNOW THEIR PERPETRATORS
OUT THERE WE KNOW THERE.
ARE -- DEVIANCE WE KNOW THERE
ARE PEOPLE WHO WILL TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF WOMEN OR YOUNG
PEOPLE VULNERABLE PEOPLE BUT FOR
AN INSTITUTION WHICH HAS THE
RESPONSIBILITY. TO PROTECT US
WHETHER IT'S THROUGH MAKING SURE
WE GET A QUALITY EDUCATION
WHETHER IT'S THE PROVISIONS OF
TITLE.
NINE WHETHER IT'S JUST BASIC
HUMAN DECENCY.
WE HAVE A AN ENORMOUS LAPSE THAT
OCCURRED HERE AND SO EXCUSE ME.
OUR WE SOMETIMES HEAR THAT FROM
PEOPLE WHO ARE INDIVIDUALS BUT
NOT PEOPLE WHO ARE HERE AS
WITNESSES SO PLEASE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SO WE KNOW THAT -- THERE'S BEEN
A FAILURE THIS INSTITUTION THERE
ARE PROBABLY BEEN FAILURES OF
OTHERS AND PERHAPS WE WILL LEARN
OF THOSE GOING FORWARD BUT THE
QUESTION NOW BEFORE US IS
WHETHER THIS BILL.
IS THE RIGHT WAY TO RESPOND TO
THE ISSUES BEFORE US STATUTES OF
LIMITATIONS ARE I PRACTICED LAW
FOR TWENTY TWO YEARS --
RECOVERING -- BEEN IN RECOVERY
FOR ABOUT THE SAME LENGTH OF
TIME WE HAVE MEMBERS OF THIS
BODY HERE WHO HAVE PRACTICED LAW.
IN THOSE WHO -- I HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN PUBLIC POLICY FOR
PERIODS OF TIME EVEN IF THEY
HAVEN'T SO.
IT IS -- UNDERSTOOD THAT
STATUTES OF LIMITATIONS AND OUR
RELIANCE ON THEM ARE
FOUNDATIONAL TO OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
WE DON'T WANT CASES TO GET TOO
STALE WITNESSES MEMORIES CHANGE.
OF PEOPLE DIE SO A HAVING
STATUTES OF LIMITATIONS ARE A
FOUNDATION OF OUR JUDICIAL
PROCESS AS ANCIENT AS FOR
EXISTED AS LONG BACK AS FAR BACK
AS ANCIENT ROME.
AND WHILE THE LAW IS CLEAR THAT
IT IS WITHIN THE POWER OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO REVIVE EXPIRED
CIVIL CLAIMS WE'VE DONE THAT
BEFORE WE'VE DONE THAT WITH THE
MISTREATMENT OF HORRIFIC
TREATMENT WITHIN THE CHURCH.
AND A SEXUAL PREDATORS OF THE
CHURCH KNEW ABOUT FOR DECADES IF
NOTHUNDREDS OF YEARS WE'VE DONE
IT THERE SO -- WE HAVE IN FACT
REVIVED EXPIRED CIVIL CLAIMS IN
THE PAST THE QUESTION TODAY IS
WHETHER IT'S JUSTIFIED IN THIS
CIRCUMSTANCE I THINK THAT'S THE
QUESTION BEFORE US.
AND I THINK THAT THE SITUATIONS
IN THE CLAIMS THAT ARE COVERED
BY THIS BILL.
DO WARRANT THIS EXTRAORDINARY
RELIEF READING THE STORIES OVER
AND OVER AGAIN -- YOU ARE NOT
ALONE AND AS I SAID EARLIER THIS
IS NOT YOUR FAULT.
AND A YOUNG WOMEN.
THE WOMEN WHO'VE EXPERIENCES
SHOULD NOT BEAR.
THE GUILT OF THIS MISTREATMENT
AND YET WE AS WOMEN DO.
I DON'T KNOW WHY BUT WE DO --
WEATHER WHERE THE VICTIM OF
SEXUAL ABUSE RAPE -- OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SOMEHOW OR OTHER WE
FEEL THAT IT'S OUR
RESPONSIBILITY.
AND IT IS NOT BUT IT IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THESE
UNIVERSITIES AND ANY INSTITUTION
THAT IS AWARE THAT THIS IS
HAPPENING TO TAKE IMMEDIATE
STEPS. TO ENDED [inaudible]
AND SO.
A I DON'T MAKE THAT DECISION
LIGHTLY BECAUSE AGAIN TO SOMEONE
WHO BELIEVED SO FIRMLY IN THE
JUDICIAL PROCESS -- THIS IS A
SITUATION THAT.
THAT I THINK BEGS THE THE
RESPONSE AND IN RESPONSE TO THE
CONCERN ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THERE'S A TWO HUNDRED FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLAR SETTLEMENT ON THE
TABLE.
IF THE SETTLEMENT IS FAIR AND
REASONABLE FOR VICTIMS THEY
WON'T OPT OUT THEY'LL
PARTICIPATE BUT THIS BILL AS I
UNDERSTAND IT GIVES THOSE WHO
HAVE TIME BARRED CLAIMS.
A CHOICE. TO TAKE THE SETTLEMENT
OFFER OR TO SEEK JUSTICE IN THE
COURTS PURSUANT TO THE REVIVAL
PROVISION.
THEY HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY I
FRANKLY THINK TWO HUNDRED AND
USC IS A DROP IN THE BUCKET.
UP BUT IT IS A SETTLEMENT THAT
WAS OFFERED IN THE CORD.
DID -- TO APPROVE THE SETTLEMENT
THEN SO BE IT FOR THOSE WHO
CHOOSE AND MAYBE FOR GOOD REASON
BUT I THINK FOR THOSE.
ARE FOR WHOM THE STATUTE HAS RUN
IF THEY WANT TO ASSERT THEIR
CLAIMS GIVEN WHAT WE KNOW AND
GIVEN WHAT THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA NEW.
ARE THEY SHOULD CERTAINLY HAVE
THE RIGHT TO DO THIS AND AS FAR
AS EXPANDING THIS PERHAPS GOING
FORWARD.
IF THERE ARE OTHER SITUATIONS
WHERE THE FAX SERVICES GREGIS AS
THEY ARE IN THIS CASE THAT WOULD
HAPPEN AND IT IS MY HOPE THAT
EVERY SCHOOL IN EVERY
INSTITUTION THAT IS GIVEN THE
TRUST OF ITS STUDENTS OR ITS
POPULATION -- IF THEY HAVE -- OF
NOT THE CARED FOR THEIR STUDENTS
OR THEIR POPULATION AS THEY
SHOULD.
THEIR DUTIES TO THEIR TO THEIR
CONGREGANTS WHAT HAVE YOU WILL
IMMEDIATELY RECOGNIZE AND
PROCEED APPROPRIATELY GOING FOR
TO THIS DOES NOT HAPPEN ONE MORE
DAY IN THE FUTURE -- I HOPE
THERE WILL HAPPEN AS WELL AND SO --
THOSE ARE MY THOUGHTS ON THIS
SUBJECT I RECOGNIZE -- THEIR
POINTS OF VIEW PASSIONATELY ON
BOTH SIDES BUT THIS KIND OF
THING HAS JOSH GOT TO STOP.
AND IF WE GIVE THESE VICTIMS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SEEK THEIR
JUSTICE I CERTAINLY FEEL THAT
IT'S APPROPRIATE UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES AND WITH THAT I
WOULD OPEN IT.
THE COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES.
CENTER MONEY FALL BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
OF WANT TO THANK THE WITNESSES
WHO SPOKE TODAY I WOULD LIKE TO
ASK THE AUTHOR TO RESPOND TO THE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE SCOPE.
OF THE BILL -- AS I THINK THE
CHAIR BEGAN TO ASK BUT IF YOU
COULD RESPOND TO THE QUESTION
ABOUT INCLUDING.
OF ALL.
INSTITUTIONS OF PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER LEARNING.
SENATOR I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO TO RECOGNIZE THE
THE IMPETUS.
FOR THIS BILL.
IT IS WHAT WAS HAPPENING AT U.
S. C. IT IS WHAT HAPPENED OVER
THE PERIOD OF THIRTY YEARS IT IS
A VICTIMS OF USC.
THE FACT THAT THIS WAS A STORY
THAT BROKE.
IT WASN'T SOMETHING THAT THE THE
UNIVERSITY REACHED OUT TO THE
VICTIMS AND SAID WE FOUND OUT
THIS DOCTOR HAS DONE THIS AND WE
NEED TO BRING IN ALL OF THE THE
VICTIMS.
THERE'S A STORY THAT BROKE IN
THE LA TIMES.
BECAUSE OF INVESTIGATION SHOWING
THAT.
THIS IS KNOWN BY USC AND WE HAVE.
FOURTEEN THOUSAND WOMEN.
WHO WERE SEEN BY THIS DOCTOR WHO
WAS THE ONLY GYNECOLOGIST IN
THIS -- STUDENT HEALTH CENTER.
THE THIS BILL IS VERY SPECIFIC.
TO THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES AND I
THINK AS THE CHAIR HAS INDICATED
IF WE FIND THAT.
THIS HAS HAPPENED TO THAT DEGREE.
WITH THE COVER UP.
THAT WE FIND AT THIS UNIVERSITY.
BUT I THINK IT WOULD BE OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO RESPOND
ACCORDINGLY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU.
THE CENTER GONZALEZ FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR BORCHERS DID YOU HAVE A
OKAY VERY GOOD TENOR GONZALEZ.
AND I'M CHAIR AND THANK YOU --
FOR SHARING YOUR STORIES WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT -- I KNOW
IT MUST BE VERY HARD AND TO COME
IN FRONT OF THIS COMMITTEE IS
VERY DIFFICULT SO THANK YOU FOR
FOR THAT -- I FIRST WANT TO ASK
ABOUT THE FRAUDULENT CONCEALMENT --
REFERENCE IT MADE AND WHAT'S --
IF ANYTHING HAS BEEN DONE ABOUT
THAT I KNOW THERE'S BEEN A
REPORTS OF THE DECK THE DECADES
OF REPORTS.
THAT HAVE BEEN -- THAT REPORTED
BUT NOTHING DON PAYMENTS TO THE
COACH BUT ALL WHAT CAN YOU
EXPLAIN -- ON THE FRAUDULENT
CONCELMENT DIDN'T WEAR THAT.
MAY TAKE US YES THANK YOU EXCUSE
ME OPENS UP SORRY I THOUGHT TO
THE RUSSIANS.
ARE TO THE AUTHOR IN INTO THE
WOODS THANK YOU FOR THE CHAIR I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK HOLLY BOYER
THE ATTORNEY TO RESPOND TO THAT.
HI.
SO A COUPLE POSITIONS WITH THE
FRAUDULENT CONCEALMENT WOULD YOU
IDENTIFY YOURSELF FOR THE RECORD
PLEASE YES I'M SORRY HOLLY BOYER.
ON BEHALF OF THE SPONSOR -- ONE
IS THAT USC HAS ACTUALLY TAKEN
THE EXACT OPPOSITE POSITION IN
LITIGATION THEY ARE -- SEEKING
TO DISMISS AND HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL DISMISSING CLAIMS
WHERE THE PLAINTIFFS OF ARGUED
THAT ARE DELAY DISCOVERY OR
FRAUDULENT CONCEALMENT HAVE --
STOPPED THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS.
BOTH OF THESE DOCTRINES OUR OUR
FAX SPECIFIC HURDLES PLACED ON A
VICTIM TO ESTABLISH THAT THEY
WERE NOT ON NOTICE OF THEIR
CLAIM EARLIER USC HAS POINTED TO
FAX OF THESE VICTIMS WITH A STAY --
I SENSED THAT SOMETHING WAS
WRONG DURING THIS EXAMINATION TO
SAY AHA YOU KNEW OR SHOULD HAVE
SUSPECTED THIS WAS ABUSE
THEREFORE YOU CANNOT TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF FRAUDULENT
CONCEALMENT DOCTOR AN ORDERLY
DISCOVERY TO TOLL YEARS TO
STATURE LIMITATIONS.
UNDER THEIR ANALYSIS THERE
FRAUDULENT CONDUCT DOESN'T EVEN
COME INTO PLAY AND IT'S BECAUSE
THEY'RE POINTING TO THE THE TYPE
OF AND THE NATURE OF THIS ABUSE.
AB FIFTEEN TEN GIVES THESE
VICTIMS THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
THEIR OWN ACTION IN STATE COURT
THAT'S ALL THIS BILL IS SEEKING
TO DO IS OPEN THAT DOOR
[inaudible]
THANK YOU -- THAT CLARIFIES
EVERYTHING FOR ME APPRECIATE
THAT AND WHAT I'LL JUST SAY OUT
WITH THAT AND I THINK JUST CHECK.
ONE OTHER QUESTION BECAUSE I
KNOW IN TERMS OF THE SETTLEMENT
WHICH IS TWO HUNDRED FIFTEEN
DOLLARS IT SEEMS.
MILLION DOLLARS YES TWO HUNDRED
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS -- WHICH
DOES SEEM LIKE A DROP IN THE
BUCKET I KNOW THAT THERE ARE
DIFFERENT TEARS AS WELL -- IN
TERMS OF USC DETERMINING LIKE
WHO EXACTLY -- WOULD GET WHAT
AMOUNTS 225-002-5000 AND TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND THERE'S A
THREE MEMBER PANEL THAT WOULD
DECIDE THAT.
SO I JUST.
JUST IN HEARING THAT TODAY I
KNOW THAT -- WOMEN WHO ALREADY
FEEL A MAJOR DISTRUST IN -- THIS
UNIVERSITY WITH AND HAVE TO GO
TO THIS PANEL I FEEL LIKE IS AN
EXTRA BURDEN -- AND FOR THAT
REASON -- I FEEL THE SAME WAY
YOU KNOW I REALLY DO AND SO I
WOULD WANT TO THANK YOU AGAIN.
AND I HOPE AND WITH THE SUPPORT
OF MANY PEOPLE THAT YOU'VE HAD
HERE TODAY -- I HOPE THAT WE CAN
SET A REALLY GOOD PRESIDENT HERE
IN THE STATE WHERE WE DO HAVE
ADDITIONAL VICTIMS THAT CAN COME
FORWARD AND VARIOUS OTHER --
EDUCATIONAL CAPACITIES THANK YOU.
OF THE THREE ONE RESPOND TO THAT.
BRIEFLY.
I'M I THINK THAT THERE'S BEEN A
LITTLE BIT OF CONFUSION ABOUT
WHAT ACTIONS THE UNIVERSITY HAS
TAKEN ONCE ALLEGATIONS HAVE
RISEN WE DISTRIBUTED TO ALL OF
YOUR OFFICES IN A LETTER THAT
DETAILS.
VERY SPECIFICALLY THE TIMELINE
OF ALLEGATIONS MADE AGAINST
OFTEDAL AND THE ACTIONS THAT U.
S. HE TOOK AFTER EACH ALLEGATION.
AND THE SUBSEQUENT ACTIONS AND
AND ALSO JUST REMIND IF THIS IS
A CASE ABOUT FRAUDULENT
CONCEALMENT AND IF USC IS BEING
ACCUSED.
OF ENGAGING IN THAT ACTIVITY
THIS BILL IS NOT NECESSARY TO
ALLOW THOSE WOMEN A REMEDY THERE
IS A REMEDY IN CURRENT LAW RIGHT
NOW FOR THOSE PARTICULAR
INSTANCES.
I THINK THAT WAS EXPLAINED BY
THE ATTORNEY A PREVIOUSLY.
ESSIE HAS FOUGHT THIS INCLUDE
QUARTZ -- VIGOROUSLY -- DENYING
OF BEHAVIOR IT HAS NOT.
I THINK EVEN TODAY AND HAS NOT
DEMONSTRATED THE KIND OF REMORSE
AND RECOGNITION -- THAT -- ITS
VICTIMS OF BELIEVE IS
APPROPRIATE SO -- AND I THINK
THAT'S ANOTHER REASON THAT THE
PEOPLE.
ARE BELIEVED TO THE THIS IS AN
INADEQUATE SETTLEMENT SO.
THAT'S ART OF WHAT THIS BILL
DOES SHE VERY UNIQUE SET OF
FACTS.
SET OF FACTS AND I THINK FOR
SOME OF US THAT'S REALLY THE
REASON WE'RE WILLING.
TO DEAL WITH THE STATURE
LIMITATIONS ISSUE.
IN THIS FASHION SENATOR BORCHERS.
THANK YOU AND THE CHAIR WOMAN IS
CORRECT -- THIS -- CERTAINLY
[inaudible]
IS A COMPLICATED SCARY -- ISSUE
THAT ROLLS THE PASSIONS -- AS
POLICY MAKERS I THINK IT'S
INCUMBENT UPON US TO MAKE
CERTAIN THAT.
WE DEVISE LEGISLATION IN
APPROVED LEGISLATION.
THAT IS APPLICABLE TO THE STATE.
AND MY CONCERN IS WHEN WE HAVE
CARVE OUT.
OR ARE REALLY UNIQUE BOUTIQUE
TYPES OF LEGISLATION THAT IT
WORKS AGAINST WHAT I THINK OUR
CORE MISSION IS IS TO LOOK AFTER.
THE BETTERMENT OF THE STATE AND
ALL ITS RESIDENTS.
AND I'VE HEARD SOME EXPLANATION
AS TO WHY S. C. AND I'M
CERTAINLY NEVER GONNA DEFEND
ESSIE.
IN ANY CAPACITY IF THESE IF IF
IF EVERYTHING THAT I'VE HEARD IS
TRUE.
IT'S A HORRIFIC.
EVENT.
BUT I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY WE
ARE NOT APPLYING IT [inaudible]
AS POLICY. TO ALL SCHOOLS.
AND I'D I'D I KNOW THAT -- MY
COLLEAGUE POSE THAT QUESTION BUT
I'M NOT CERTAIN I UNDERSTOOD THE
RESPONSE THAT I THAT I HEARD
FROM THE AUTHOR OF OF THIS.
MAYBE I'LL GIVE YOU ANOTHER SHOT
IF YOU'RE INTERESTED -- WHAT IS
THE HARM IN APPLYING THIS TO ALL
UNIVERSITIES?
IN IS THERE SOMETHING OTHER
POLITICAL FORCES OUT THERE.
THAT ARE MAKING THIS.
MORE DIFFICULT TO DO SO.
I THOUGHT I HAD RESPONDED BUT
HOWEVER SENATOR I WILL ASK THE
ATTORNEY -- TO GIVE IT A SHOT.
TO SO ONE OF THE AS THE
CHAIRPERSON NOTED IT'S BECAUSE
OF THE AGREE JUST NATURE OF THE
THIRTY YEARS THAT THREE DECADES
OF ABUSE THAT OCCURRED HERE.
THAT NOT ONLY ALLOWED IN PLACE
UNTIL IN A POSITION TO SEXUALLY
ABUSE THESE WOMEN TIME AND TIME
AGAIN BUT ALSO THE COVER UP AS
WELL.
AS SIMILAR TO THE CHURCH CASES
AROUND TWO THOUSAND TWO WHEN
THERE WAS A LIMITED ONE YEAR
REVIVAL PROVISION FOR SEXUAL
ABUSE VICTIMS OF THOSE IN THOSE
CHURCH CASES.
THIS BILL TARGETS THE AGREE THE
PASSAGES NECESSARY NOW BOTH
BECAUSE ONE CLAIMS THAT ARE HAVE
BEEN FILED ARE BEING DISMISSED
BASED ON THE STATURE IMITATIONS
GROUNDS.
AND THE FEDERAL SETTLEMENT THAT
WAS REFERRED TO EARLIER BY USC
HAS AN OPT OUT PROVISION OF
NOVEMBER SEVENTH SO IF THIS IF
THIS BILL IS NOT PROVIDED TO
GIVE THESE WOMEN THE CHANCE.
THEY ARE DENIED THE CHOICE AND
READING IN THE OLDER RESPECT IN
YOUR ARTICULATING TO PROCEDURAL
CIRCUMSTANCE OF S. C..
I'M LOOKING UPON THE POLICY
IMPLICATIONS THAT SHOULD BE
BORNE BY UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS
ACROSS THE STATE.
AND THAT'S WERE -- I DON'T I'M
NOT FINDING SATISFACTION IN IN
THIS ANSWER NGUYEN.
WE HEARD TESTIMONY EVEN FROM THE
CHAIR HERSELF AND I'LL QUOTE ANY
UNIVERSITY -- TO TAKE IMMEDIATE
STEPS AND I TOTALLY AGREE WITH
HER [inaudible]
ALL UNIVERSITIES.
AND IF THIS IS TRIGGERING A ARE
DISCREET AREA OF TIME.
THEN WHY NOT APPLY IT.
ACROSS THE BOARD YOU'LL STILL
ACHIEVE THE SAME RESULTS BUT WE
WILL SEND PUBLIC POLICY IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION.
I I THINK THIS BILL IS VERY
SPECIFIC IT IS TO TIME AND THAT
IS WHAT THE BILL IS AND IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO BRING ANOTHER BILL.
DIFFERENT BILL THAT YOU CERTAIN
NOW WITH ALL DUE RESPECT I'M
RESPOND EXCUSE ME EXCUSE ME
COUNTY EXCUSE ME.
I HAVE HI I AM ANSWERING YOUR
QUESTION.
THIS IS NOT A DIALOGUE I'M
ANSWERING YOUR QUESTION.
THIS IS A SPECIFIC BILL.
DEALING WITH A SPECIFIC SET OF
ISSUES AND I INVITE ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO BRING THEIR OWN BILL
DEALING WITH SOME OTHER ASPECTS
OF THIS.
THEY HAVE EVERY RIGHT TO DO THAT --
YOU DO SENATOR BORCHERS YOU CAN
BRING YOUR OWN LEGISLATIVE
PACKAGE AS WHAT WE DO IS
LEGISLATORS.
THIS BILL IS VERY NARROWLY
FOCUSED.
THE SET OF FACTS THE EXPANSION
OF THE STATURE LIMITATIONS IS
VERY LIMITED TO A PARTICULAR SET
OF FACTS IF THERE ARE OTHER
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT COME FORWARD.
THAT HAVE A SET OF FACTS THAT
THE AUTHOR BELIEVES WOULD
JUSTIFY THIS ADDITIONAL
EXPANSION OF THE STATUTE.
THEN THAT CERTAINLY IS SOMETHING
THAT THIS.
THERE WOULD COME TO THIS
COMMITTEE FOR CONSIDERATION SO.
IF YOU WANT MY QUESTION DO YOU
HAVE A QUESTION I DO RIGHT --
ONE THE YOU'VE NOT ANSWERED --
THE IDEA IS.
AND WE EXT WE EXPECT THIS IN IN
OUR IN OUR COMMITTEE IN OUR
FORUM THAT IF SOMETHING IS
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT IS PROPOSED
AND BRING UP A SUBSEQUENT PIECE
OF LEGISLATION FORWARD.
BUT MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THIS RECOMMENDATION WAS MADE
EARLY.
AN ODD THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS.
SO WHY DON'T I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY THIS WAS INCORPORATED INTO
IT WHAT AM I MISSING WHAT ARE
THE FORCES AT PLAY THAT IS OUR
IS KEEPING THIS.
FROM OCCURRING.
MAY I JUST SAY.
WHAT IN INJUSTICES WOULD BE?
IF WE WERE TO INCLUDE OTHER
UNIVERSITIES WHERE.
HE THE ONLY ONE THAT COMES TO
MIND NOW IS YOU SEE A LATE THIS
IS JUST BEGINNING FOR UCLA.
USC'S COVER UP USC'S
VICTIMIZATION HAS BECOME.
THE VICTIMS OF ALREADY BEEN
NOTIFIED THEY'RE PART OF A CLASS
ACTION SUIT.
THAT HAS BEEN OVER OVER A YEAR
THEY ARE NOW AWARE IF WE NOW SEE
HERE'S THIS WONDERFUL
OPPORTUNITY UPS ARE YOU DIDN'T
HEAR ABOUT IT.
NOTHING WE CAN DO.
THERE WAS A SERIOUS
CONSIDERATION HOWEVER I BELIEVE
THAT THE CIRCUMSTANCES AND I'M A
TROJAN.
I I RECEIVED MY EDUCATION AT USC
THIS WAS NOT AN EASY DECISION
EVEN FOR MYSELF I STAND WITH MY
SISTERS ALSO WHO HAVE BEEN
VICTIMIZED IN THIS MANNER.
U..
ACTIONS IN THIS CASE.
HAVE PROVIDED THE NOTICE TO THE
VICTIMS.
THERE WILL BE A ONE YEAR.
RE OPENING OF THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS FOR THOSE VICTIMS
AND DURING THAT YEAR IF THEY
BRING THEIR CLAIM.
PERFECT IF THEY DON'T THE
STATURE IT WILL HAVE PASSED IF
WE WERE TO EXPAND THIS TO EVER
UNIVERSITY THAT WOULD BE SUCH A
DISSERVICE TO THEM.
THANK YOU I THINK YOU'VE
ANSWERED THE QUESTION NOW
SENATOR MORNING AND THEN I THINK
AT THIS POINT WILL ASK YOU TO
CLOSE AND WE WILL TAKE ABOUT.
JUST BRIEFLY -- I THINK THAT IS
THE DISTINCTION HERE FOR THOSE
WHO SEEK THE SAME TREATMENT. TWO
OTHER UNIVERSITIES [inaudible]
WE WANT.
VICTIMS TO HAVE THE FULL PANOPLY
OF RIGHTS THIS IS TAILORED TO A
SITUATION WHERE THERE'S ALREADY
A SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT AND WE'RE
TRYING TO CREATE A WINDOW FOR
VICTIMS IN THIS PARTICULAR
INCIDENT.
THAT WINDOW FOR OTHER VICTIMS IN
OTHER UNIVERSITIES IN ESSENCE
WOULD BE SLAMMING THE DOOR.
ON THEM TO HAVE THE FULL COURSE
TO RUN THE POSSIBILITY.
OF SEEKING JUSTICE AND THEIR
RIGHTS THERE MAY BE OTHER
INSTANCES WHERE THE INJUSTICE OF
WHAT HAPPENED AT USC IS REVEALED
AT THAT POINT.
THEN IT'S APPROPRIATE TO EXPLORE
DOES THAT WARRANT OPENING A
WINDOW THIS WINDOWS FOR VICTIMS
AT USC.
THIS WINDOW APPLIED TO THE STATE
WOULD BE CLOSING THE DOOR ON
POTENTIAL REMEDIES TO OTHER
VICTIMS.
I'D LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL THANK
YOU SENATOR MONEY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU FOR THIS ROBUST CON
CONVERSATION I THANK THE VICTIMS
FOR COMING FORWARD IT IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO HEAR
THEIR VOICE AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN A. B.
FIFTEEN TEN JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE BORDERS [inaudible]
THE RUSSELL.
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I JONES.
MONNING MONEY AYE STERN STERN I
AM BURKE.
BY CAL SKI.
ORDERS HERE RIGHT THE VOTE COUNT
IS FORTY ZERO WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH FOR BEING HERE AND FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY FROM ALL PERSPECTIVES
I THINK WAS VERY HELPFUL TO ALL
OF US.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
THANK YOU.
BARRED OUR FINAL BUILD.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A MINUTE TO
JUST CLEAR THE ROOM.
IT WILL TAKE NOT QUITE ARRIVE
WILL TAKE A MINUTE TO CLEAR THE
ROOM.
GIVE YOU ALL A MOMENT
.
THE TOUGH COMMITTEE.
HELLO WATCHING YOU GUYS
[inaudible]
THAT AREA
.
GOOD AFTERNOON WE ARE ON OUR
LAST ITEM FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN
WHICH IS AB.
SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE OF
HOPEFULLY WE'LL GET OUR MEMBERS
BACK -- SO THAT WHEN WE ARE DONE
WITH THIS -- BE ABLE
[inaudible]
TO OF VOTE -- ON THIS ITEM AND
CLOSE THE ROLES ON OTHERS SO --
THIS IS AB -- SEVENTEEN THIRTY
ONE OF REALLY YOU SEE BILL TWO
WILL PROBABLY HAVE SOME ROBUST
DISCUSSION ABOUT IT LOOKING
FORWARD TO IT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BURNER **** BATH THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND SENATORS TODAY IT'S MY HONOR
TO PRESENT MY BILL AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY ONE WHICH APPROPRIATELY
REGULATES.
SHORT TERM VACATION RENTAL
PLATFORMS AND SAN DIEGO COUNTIES
COASTAL ZONE AS A THREE YEAR
PILOT.
I WHEN I THINK THE CHAIR IN THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR CONSTRUCTIVE
AMENDMENTS WHICH I'M HAPPY TO
ACCEPT TODAY.
WE ALL KNOW TOO WELL THAT
CALIFORNIA IS IN THE MIDST OF A
STATE WHAT HOUSING CRISIS.
AND YOU ALL KNOW THAT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS CAME REGULATE OR
BAN SHORT TERM VACATION RENTALS
AS THEY SEE FIT.
THIS IS THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS.
EXCEPT IN THE OASTAL ZONE.
AND THE COAST IS ON THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION
HAS ABILITY TO REGULATE LAND USE
BUT ONLY AS A PLACE TO COASTAL
ACCESS.
THEY DO NOT HAVE THE AUTHORITY
TO BALANCE COASTAL ACCESS WITH
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY OR IN THE
CASE SOCIAL FULL TIME SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTALS REMOVING
HOUSING FROM THE HOUSING STOCK.
THEREFORE CAL IN CALIFORNIA'S
COASTAL ZONE THE CALIFORNIA
COAST MAKE COMMISSION THAT
REQUIRES CITY TO HAVE SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTAL.
RESEARCHER VACATION RENTALS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR
AFFORDABILITY AND EVEN IN
COUNTIES THAT DO AN EXCEPTIONAL
JOB -- IN PROVIDING LOW COST
COAST ACCOMMODATIONS LIKE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY.
SAN DIEGO COUNTY ACCOUNTS FOR
NEARLY ONE THIRD OF THE STATE'S
ENTIRE STOCK OF LOW COST COASTAL
ACCOMMODATION.
THAT MEANS ONE IN ONE THOUSAND
PER ONE THOUSAND RESIDENTS IN
SAN DIEGO COUNTY THIS IS FAR
ABOVE THE REST OF THE STATE IN
ANY OTHER COUNTY.
AND SO WE DO A GOOD JOB OF
PROVIDING LOW COST BECAUSE OF
COMBINATIONS WE DO NOT HAVE A
COASTAL LOW COST ACCOMMODATION
PROBLEM THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
BUT WE DO HAVE A CROWD HOUSING
CRISIS EXACERBATED BY THE
PROLIFERATION OF SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTALS WHICH ARE
REMOVING HOUSING FROM OUR
HOUSING STOCK.
ESPECIALLY DUE TO THE POPULARITY
EASE THROUGH WHICH THEY CAN BE
RENTED OVER SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTAL PLATFORMS -- AND THIS IS
ESPECIALLY ISSUE WHEN IT AN
ADVERT LEE INCENTIVIZE FULL TIME
SHORT TERM VACATION RENTALS OVER
LONG TERM RENTALS WE SEE THAT.
LONG TERM RENTAL RATES INCREASE
AND IT'S JUST A SIMPLE SUPPLY
AND DEMAND IF WE ALL GO BACK TO
ECONOMICS ONE A ONE WE KNOW WHAT
THIS IS.
CURRENTLY THERE ABOUT FOURTEEN
THOUSAND SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTALS IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY MOST
OF WHICH ARE FULL TIME.
WE ESTIMATE THAT APPROXIMATELY
FIVE THOUSAND FULL TIME SHORT
TERM VACATION RENTALS AND SAN
DIEGO COUNTIES COASTAL ZONE.
AND WHEN IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
STATE HOW IT WHAT HOUSING CRISIS
WE ALLOW THE DE FACTO DEMOLITION
OF FIVE THOUSAND UNITS IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY SCHOOL SYSTEM.
I NOT HAVE THEM BE REPLACED.
THIS MEANS THERE FIVE THOUSAND
UNITS NOT AVAILABLE TO BUY OR
RENT LONG TERM FOR FAMILIES
SENIORS VETERANS ARE WORKERS.
DECREASE THE SUPPLY WHICH WE ON
THOSE INCREASES RENT AND HOUSING
PRICES.
AND REMEMBER THESE UNITS ARE
COUNTED IN CITIES RENO NUMBERS
FOR HOUSING NOT VISITORS SERVING
USES WHICH SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTALS ARE FUNDAMENTALLY ARE.
WELL NOT ALL THESE RENTALS WILL
BE AFFORDABLE I THINK THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REALIZE THEY PUSH
HIGHER INCOME FOLKS DOWN THE
HOUSING MARKET WHICH THEIR
FULLER FOR CAUSES DISPLACEMENT
OF OUR FAMILIES THING YEARS
VETERANS AND WORKERS. THIRTY TWO
ADDRESSES MARKET DESTRUCTION I
AUTHORED AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE
IT'S NEARLY TAILORED TO PROBABLY
REGULATE SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTAL PLATFORMS IN THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY COUNCILS ON AND I
WANT TO GET AT THAT BECAUSE OF
THE SHORT TERM VACATION RENTAL
PLATFORMS.
THAT ARE CAUSING THIS MASSIVE
MARKET DISTORTION IN IMPERIAL
BEACH WHICH IS ONE OF OUR
COASTAL COMMUNITIES AND ALSO WON
THE POOREST CITIES IN THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY.
THEY USE A LOT OF POLITICAL
CAPITAL WE ALL KNOW IT'S HARD TO
BUILD IN THE COASTAL ZONE -- AND
THEY BUILT A TWO HUNDRED THEY
APPROVED A TWO HUNDRED UNIT --
MULTI FAMILY DEVELOPMENT TWENTY
FIVE OF THOSE TWO HUNDRED UNITS
WITHIN THREE MONTHS OUR FULL
TIME SHORT TERM VACATION RENTALS.
I PREDICT IT'LL BE FIFTY BY THE
END OF THE YEAR.
THOSE WERE HOMES AND APARTMENTS
MEANT FOR FOLKS THEY WERE NOT
MEANT TO BE VISITORS SERVING
USES AND THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE A
PROLIFERATION AND THE SUCCESS
REALLY OF THE SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTAL PLATFORMS.
ARE DOING TO OUR HOUSING MARKET
AT SOME POINT I THINK WE HAVE TO
BE REALLY HONEST DO WE HAVE A
HOUSING CRISIS OR DO WE HAVE A
SHORT TERM VACATION IN A CRISIS
AND I THINK WE ALL AGREE.
WE HAVE A HOUSING CRISIS.
AT ITS CORE.
AB SEVENTY THIRTY ONE A LOT
ALLOWS LEGITIMATE HOME SHARING
WHILE PRESERVING THE ROLE
PREVENTING THE REMOVAL OF
HOUSING FOR THE HOUSING STOCK.
DUE TO FULL TIME SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTALS AND MANY HOTELS
PROLIFERATING WITH ANY OF COUNTY
COUNCILS ON AS A PRIMARY
RESIDENCE ON SITE.
THEY ARE EXCLUDED FROM THE BILL.
IF THE CITY ZONES AREA
RESIDENTIAL TOURISM THEY'RE
EXCLUDED FROM THE BILL.
IF THE PRIMARY RESIDENCE IS NOT
ON SITE IN THE SHORT TERM
VACATION WITH A PLATFORM MAY
BOOK THAT UNIT FOR UP TO THIRTY
DAYS.
AND THAT IF THE IF THE USER
DECIDES A PLATFORM HOP THAT'S
NINETY DAYS TOTAL PER YEAR.
THAT INCLUDES ALMOST EVERY
SINGLE WEEKEND IN A YEAR OR THE
ENTIRE SUMMER.
THAT'S APPROPRIATE HOME SHARING
THAT DOES NOT REMOVE HOUSING
FROM THE HOUSING STOCK.
AND AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE
ALLOWS RETURN OF MUCH READ
NEEDED TRANSIT OCCUPANCY TAX TO
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THIS IS THE
TAX THAT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
USED TO ACCOMMODATE THE SERVICES
NEEDED FOR THEIR THEIR INTEREST
POPULATION.
AND THIS IS CRITICAL TO ALLOW --
THE IMPACT OF THE SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTALS ON THE
COMMUNITIES TO BE RECOVERED BY
CITIES AND ALSO A LOT OF LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO COMPARE WHO'S
RENTING OUT WHO'S GOTTEN A
PERMIT.
AND COMPARE THAT BACK TO THEIR
LOCAL PERMITTING PROCESS
SOMETHING THAT CAN'T BE DONE
RIGHT NOW.
I'D LIKE TO ALSO POINT OUT THAT
THE MEMBERS TAKEN THIS COMMITTEE
MEANS THIS IS A THREE YEAR PILOT
INSTEAD OF THE PROPOSED FIVE
YEAR PILOT -- AND WE WILL HAVE A
MUCH NEED.
A VERY IMPORTANT STUDY AT THE
END -- SHOWING WHAT THE EFFECT
OF THE SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTAL PLATFORMS ARE ON THE
HOUSING MARKET AND SAN DIEGO
COUNTIES COASTAL ZONE.
SPECIFICALLY I'M INTERESTED IN
TWO THINGS WHICH IS WHAT THE
EFFECT ON LONG TERM RENTAL RATES
WHAT'S THE BY FACT ON HOUSING
AVAILABILITY.
THESE ARE THINGS WE CAN'T KNOW
BECAUSE THERE'S NO CONNECTION
BETWEEN THE SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTAL PLATFORMS.
AND THE INDIVIDUAL PERMITTING
THAT HAPPENS IN THE CITY.
THIS BILL IS ALSO SIMPLE TO
IMPLEMENT IT REQUIRES FIVE FORMS
ADD PRACTICALLY FOR CHECK BOXES
THAT WOULD CATEGORIES A UNIT IN
THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY'S COASTAL
ZONE.
AS ELIGIBLE UNDER THIS BILL IS A
ARE YOU THE PRIMARY RESIDENCE
ARE YOU ON SITE OR OFFSITE ARE
YOU A RENTER AND IF YOU ARE TO
HAVE PERMISSION FROM THE
LANDLORD TO RENT AS A SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTAL.
RIGHT IT'S A PRETTY SIMPLE BALL
IF THOSE CONDITIONS ARE MET THEN
IT SAYS THIRTY DAYS MAXIMUM
BOOKING OVER THE PLATFORM.
CITIES WILL RECEIVE THIS
INFORMATION CITIES WILL RECEIVE
THIS INFORMATION FROM THE TO
YOUR TEAM BE ABLE TO ENFORCE FOR
THEIR LOCAL POLICIES.
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE PROTECTS
PROPERTY RIGHTS BY APPROPRIATELY
REGULATING SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTAL PLATFORMS.
RATHER THAN REGULATING PROPERTY
OWNER SOIT'S A LITTLE
COMPLICATED TO GET NOTHING SOME
FOR SOME FOLKS IN THE HEAD
AROUND THAT -- THEY CAN STILL
RENT YOU KNOW ANY OF THE
PROPERTY OWNERS CAN STILL WRITE
SHORT TERM VACATION RENTAL
PLATFORMS AS THEY DID BEFORE THE
ADVENT OF THESE PLATFORMS -- AND
THAT MEANS THE COMMISSION TO
FAMILY AND FRIENDS THEY CAN PUT
A SIGN FROM THEIR HOUSE THEY CAN
HAVE THEIR OWN WEBSITE OF COURSE
NOTHING STOPS.
ANY OF THE OF THE PROPERTY
OWNERS FROM RENTING LONG TERM.
OR FOR NINE MONTHS WE HAVE LOTS
OF STUDENTS WHO ARE HOUSING AND
SECURE THERE'S LOTS OF FOLKS
THAT WOULD RENTED OUT DURING THE
THE THE SCHOOL YEAR AND THEN
DURING THE SUMMER THEY COULD
HAVE THAT IS THEIR OWN
INDIVIDUAL USE -- AND SO ON THE
ISSUE OF PROPERTY RIGHTS I'D
LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT THIS BILL
DOES NOT REGULATE THE USE OF
RESIDENTIAL HOME FOR A SHORT
TERM VACATION RENTAL.
THAT'S THE JOB OF THE CITY BUT
ONLY RECORD REGULATES THE
PLATFORM AND HOW LONG THE
PLATFORM CAN BOOK IT.
SO AS A POINT OF FACT USE OF A
RESIDENTIAL HOME FOR A SHORT
TERM VACATION RENTAL.
IS NOT A VESTED PROPERTY RIGHT
IT'S A VISITORS SERVING USE
GRANTED ONLY IF ALLOW BY THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT VIA PERMITTING
REGISTRATION LICENSING IT'S NOT
AUTOMATICALLY VESTED IN THE
HOMEOWNER.
AB SEVENTY LEARNING THIRTY ONE
PRESERVE LOCAL CONTROL BY ADDING
WHAT I SAID BEFORE THE
RESIDENTIAL TOURISM PROVISION
THAT'S BASED CAN OPT OUT
PROVISION OF CITIES IF THEY
WANTED TO THEY COULD.
GO IN AND SAY.
DO A RESIDENTIAL TOURISM OVERLAY
AND THEN THEIR ENTIRE CITY COULD
HAVE THAT IN THE COASTAL ZONE IF
THEY WANTED.
AND AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE ALSO
PRESERVES COASTAL ACCESS.
BEYOND THE LOW COST COAST
ACCOMMODATION WHICH WERE ALREADY
REALLY GOOD AT DOING.
BY ALLOWING THE LEGITIMATE HOME
SHARING WITH PRIMARY RESIDENCE
ON SITE AND THEN OFF SITE FOR UP
TO NINETY DAYS A YEAR -- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
LOW TODAY ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL
TO ADDRESS ONE PART OF THE
EQUATION AND IT IS ONLY ONE PART.
WE DO HAVE OTHER ISSUES IN THE
SAN DIEGO COUNTY BECAUSE OF SOME
OF THIS DOES ONE PART TO REALLY
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF HOUSING
AFFORDABILITYAND THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY COASTAL ZONE AND WITH ME
I'VE TO WITNESSES AND SO CHRIS
DIPLOMA AND SERRA FOX.
THANK YOU TWO MINUTES TEACHER IF
YOU WOULD MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE CHRISTY BOMB ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS.
WILL DO IN ONE MINUTE OR LESS
TWO POINTS A PUBLIC SAFETY THE
SHORT TERM RENTALS CHANGE THE
PROFILE OF A COMMUNITY AND THE
SERVICE LEVEL DEMANDS ON THE
COMMUNITY.
A SO IT'S JUST A MATTER PUBLIC
SAFETY TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES
AND TIED TO THAT AND SECONDARILY
TO THAT.
OF HAVING THIS INFORMATION SO
THE PLATFORMS CAN.
COLLECT AND REMIT THE PROPER
TRANSIT OCCUPANCY TAXES TO THE
LOCALITIES THAT IS THE REVENUE
THAT IS FUNDING THE SERVICES TO
THESE.
HOMES AND THEREFORE WE NEED TO
BETTER HAVE ABILITY TO AUDIT AND
COLLECT OF THIS.
THIS REVENUE WE ARE YOUR SUPPORT.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE GOOD GOOD
ADAM WHERE MEMBERS SERRA FLOCKS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION.
WE REPRESENT MEMBERS WHO WORK
AND LIVE IN THESE COASTAL ZONES
AND TING THIS IS A VERY MODEST
BILL -- AND IT THE REDS THE
NEEDLE AND FINDS MIDDLE GROUND
IT DOES PROTECT.
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO SUPPLEMENT
THEIR INCOME WHO NEED TO
SUPPLEMENT THEIR INCOME BY
RENTING OUT TO SPARE ROOMS ARE
COTTAGES THEY CAN DO THAT THAT
IT LEAVES THEM BE WHAT IT DOES.
IS IT PREVENTS PRACTICES THE I
WOULD SEE ABUSE OF THESE
PLATFORMS THAT IS FUELING A
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY CRISIS IT
IS INVESTORS L. L. C.'S
COMPANIES THAT ARE BUYING UP
PROPERTIES IN THE COASTAL ZONE
BECAUSE PEOPLE WANT TO VACATION
THERE.
AND THEN RENTING THEM OUT ON
THESE PLATFORMS AND ESSENTIALLY
BECAUSE THEY'RE IN ZONE WHEN
AREAS THAT ARE ZONED
RESIDENTIALLY THEY ARE RUNNING A
LEGAL HOTELS.
BUT WITHOUT WORKERS WITHOUT
INSURANCE WITHOUT ANY OF THE
LAWS THAT PREVENT THINGS LIKE
HUMAN TRAFFICKING WHICH HOTELS
HAVE BEEN VERY GOOD ABOUT --
BEING THE POSTING AND NOTICING
WHO'S COMING IN AND OUT OF THESE
HOTELS.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT A JUST AN
INFORMAL SURVEY OF AIRBNB IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY -- 50% OF THE HOSTS
HAVE MULTIPLE PROPERTIES LISTED.
WHICH MEANS THESE ARE PROBABLY
COMPANIES THAT ARE BUYING UP
PROPERTIES AND THEN RENTING THEM
OUT IN FACT IF YOU LOOK AT THE
TOP POSTS IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY
SOME OF THEM ARE BLUE WATER
VACATIONS.
PENNY REALTY THESE ARE NOT
FAMILIES WHO JUST HAVE A SECOND
HOMES THAT THEY'RE RENTING OUT.
AND THIS IS AN IMPACT ON
BUSINESS IT HAS AN IMPACT ON
HOUSING IT HAS AN IMPACT ON
THINGS LIKE RESTAURANTS BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE GOING OUT BECAUSE
THEY'RE COKING IN THEIR AIRBNB
UNIT SO THERE ARE A LOT OF
RIPPLE A FAX -- AND THERE'S EVEN
THERE'S A RECENT STUDY THAT CAME
OUT JUST RESPONDING TO THE
ANALYSIS -- FROM UCLA AND A
RESEARCHER AT USC.
THAT.
ACTUALLY SHOWS THAT WHEN YOU
HAVE AN INCREASE IN AIRBNB
RENTALS RENT DOES GO UP AND THAT
THE FACTIS EXACERBATED WHEN YOU
HAVE.
THESE NON OWNER OCCUPIED RENTALS
LIKE WHAT IS HAPPENING IN SAN
DIEGO.
SO WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NAME
AND AFFILIATION PLEASE CARE
MEMBERS MAP BROUGHT FOR THE
TEAMSTERS AND UNITE HERE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS JOHN CALDWELL CALIFORNIA
HOTEL LODGING ASSOCIATION FOR IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WITNESSES ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION COME ON DOWN. TWO
MINUTES EACH PLEASE THANKS.
AND WE'LL DO OUR BEST TO HIT IT
RIGHT ON TO AN ALL GO FIRST TO
LET DATA SPEAK UP -- MY NAME'S
JOHN ROSS I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
AIRBNB I HAVE WITH ME DAY
FLETCHER WHOSE AND AIRBNB HOST
HE WILL READ A LETTER -- AT WHEN
I CONCLUDE -- SUBMITTED ON
BEHALF OF SHARE SAN DIEGO AND
OVER SIX THOUSAND HOST STATEWIDE
EXPRESSING THEIR CONCERNS WITH
THE BILL -- FUNDAMENTALLY WE
THINK THIS IS A HARD ISSUE AND A
HEART ISSUE THAT SHOULD BE
RESOLVED IN SAN DIEGO BY SAN
DIEGANS -- THIS BILL HAS DIVIDED
SAN DIEGO LEGISLATORS IS DIVIDED
RESIDENTS OF THE COMMUNITY AND
WE THINK THAT'S THE APPROPRIATE
PLACE FOR AN ISSUE SUCH AS THIS
TO BE RESOLVED.
ON THE BILL ITSELF I'D LIKE TO
MAKE A HANDFUL OF POINTS BEFORE
I TURN IT OVER TO DAVE -- FIRST
ADD THIS BILL BANS BANS -- THE
RENTAL OF VACATION HOMES HI IN
SAN DIEGO IF YOU'RE NOT A
PRIMARY RESIDENCE IN A PRIMARY
RESIDENT IS DEFINED AS ONE WHO.
LIVES IN THE HOME.
MORE DAYS IN A YEAR THAN THEY
LIVE ANYWHERE ELSE.
THE BILL DOES NOT LET YOU USE A
HOSTING PLATFORM TO READ YOUR
HOME.
SO IF YOU HAVE A IF YOU LIVE IN
LOS ANGELES AND YOU HAVE A HOME
IN SAN DIEGO AND USE BRB OUR
AIRBNB TO RENT THAT.
GRAPHICALLY THIS BILL SAYS NOW.
IT DOES SAY THAT A PRIMARY
RESIDENT CAN DO IT IN LIMITED
CIRCUMSTANCES OF DAY ARE LIVING
THERE PART TIME IF THEY LIVE
THERE FULL TIME THEY HAVE MUCH
MORE GENEROUS PROFESSIONS BUT
FOR THOSE ONE WE CAN RUN A
VACATION I'M IT SAYS NOW.
HI IT PREEMPTS THE ABILITY OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO ESTABLISH
THRESHOLD THAT THEY THINK ARE
MORE APPROPRIATE THAN THE
THRESHOLD SET FORTH IN THIS BILL.
PAGE THREE LINE THIRTY SAID I'M
ON PAGE THREE LINE THIRTY SIX
THROUGH PAGE FOUR LINE NINE AND
THEN PAGE FOUR LINES TEN THREE
FIFTEEN WAY OUT THE CAPS.
THAT APPLY TO RENTALS IN SAN
DIEGO INTO THIS BILL AND THEY
SAY THAT A LOCAL GOVERNMENT
CANNOT APPLY -- A CAP THAT'S
GREATER THAN WHAT IS PROVIDED
FOR IN THIS BILL SO IN THAT WAY
IT DOES SAY.
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAN
EXERCISE AS OUR OWN DISCRETION
WHY DOES THAT MATTER AIRBNB IS
CURRENTLY COLLECTING THE TRANSIT
OCCUPANCY TAX.
IN EIGHTEEN COUNTIES FORTY THREE
CITIES THREE CITIES WITHIN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY AS THOSE IF THE
BILL IS SUCCESSFUL IN THE INTENT
IS TO RESTRICT.
THE USE OF SHORT TERM RENTAL
PLATFORMS IN THOSE AREAS WE ARE
THE ONES REFLECT IN THE TIER
TEAM PROVIDE IN ITS LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS.
YOU'RE GONNA PUSH THESE
TRANSACTIONS OFF THE PLATFORMS
WERE WE CURRENTLY CORRECT
COLLECT THE TOT PURSUANT TO
AGREEMENTS WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND REDUCE THE REVENUE THAT'S
ENJOYED CURRENTLY BY OCEANSIDE
CARLSBAD IN THE CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO.
ON COASTAL ACCESS TO TO YOU KNOW
HIT ON THE BIG POINT THAT I
THINK -- I'D SEND YOU I'M SORRY
SENATOR THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE THE CORRECTION AS
USUAL.
YOU'VE GOTTEN ABOUT TWO MINUTES
AND FORTY SECONDS I'M MORE
VERBOSE THAN I WANTED TO BETTER
I TRY TO WRAP IT UP WILL GIVE
YOU A SO ON ON COASTAL ACCESS
AND I THINK THAT'S FOR THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STARTED.
THE CAUSAL MISSION HAS A CHARGE
TO ENSURE THAT THOSE WHO CAN'T
AFFORD TO LIVE AT THE COAST HAVE
THE ABILITY TO VISIT THE COAST
AND STAND ACCOMMODATIONS.
AS COMMUNITIES ALONG THE COAST
HAVE ATTEMPTED TO RESTRICT THE
ABILITY OF SHORT TERM RENTALS
THE COASTAL COMMISSION HAS
WEIGHED IN AND SAID NO IN MANY
CASES THAT'S NOT REASONABLE IT'S
OVERLY RESTRICTIVE.
WE NEED TO TAILOR -- WE NEED TO
TAILOR THE PARTICULAR PERMISSION
THAT COMMUNITY IN A WAY THAT
ALLOWS -- FOR SHORT TERM ACCESS
TO CONTINUE TO THANK YOU THANKS
SO MUCH.
AND IF YOU'D LIKE TO GO AHEAD
AND READ YOUR LETTER PLEASE THE
THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU FOR PRESIDENT IF YOU
COULD SPEAK INTO THE HIT GO
GREAT ART SURE SAN DIEGO IS A
COALITION OF SHORT TERM RENTAL
OWNERS MANAGERS AND PROPERTY
RIGHTS.
ADVOCATES IN SAN DIEGO AS SUCH
WE OPPOSE AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY
ONE DUE TO ITS DEVASTATING THE
EFFECTS IT WILL HAVE.
ON OUR REGION AND LOCAL ECONOMY
FOR MORE THAN A HUNDRED YEARS
SAN DIEGO HAS DEPENDED ON SHORT
TERM RENTALS.
ARE REGION'S RICH HISTORY OF
SUPPORTING THESE LOW COST
VISITOR ACCOMMODATIONS MADE OUR
COMMUNITY A VIBRANT PLACE THE
ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S TOP TOURIST
DESTINATIONS.
UNFORTUNATELY AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY ONE ATTEMPTS TO TURN BACK
THE CLOCK AND MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT FOR FAMILIES TO VISIT
OUR BEACH COMMUNITIES BY.
ESSENTIALLY BANNING ON HOSTED
SHORT TERM RENTALS.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN OR CITY
COUNCIL VOTED TO PUT INTO EFFECT
A SIMILAR LAW WHICH WOULD HAVE
ALSO RESTRICTED SHORT TERM
RENTALS.
IN A LESS THAN THIRTY DAYS SIXTY
TWO THOUSAND REGISTERED VOTERS
SIGNED PETITIONS TO STOP THIS
LAW FROM GOING INTO EFFECT.
A. B. SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE WOULD.
UNDERMINE AT THE WILL OF THE
LOCAL VOTERS WHO HAVE ALREADY
OPPOSE SUCH HEAVY HANDED
RESTRICTIONS.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN STUDY
BY RESEARCHERS ECONOMIST ALAN
NEVIN FOUNDED THAT IN SAN DIEGO
ALONE SHORT TERM RENTAL STREET
NEARLY. FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC ACTIVITY AND
SUPPORT MORE THAN THIRTY ONE
THOUSAND JOBS.
THESE ARE JOBS THAT WOULD NOT
OTHERWISE EXIST WITHOUT THOSE
LOW COST A VISITOR
ACCOMMODATIONS.
ADDITIONALLY THE CITY COLLECTED
MORE THAN TWENTY SIX MILLION IN
TRANSIENT OCCUPANCY TAXES FROM
THESE RENTALS IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN ALONE.
HELPING PAY FOR HOMELESS
PROGRAMS POLICE FIRE AND
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE LCAL ROADS
WITH NO WITH SO MUCH AT STAKE
FOR OUR REGION I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT YOU JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
VOTE NO ON AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY
ONE AND KEEP SAN DIEGO A
WELCOMING PLACE FOR ALL VISITORS
AND HELP PROTECT THIS VITAL PART
OF OUR REGION'S.
TOURIST INDUSTRY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BY TWO MINUTES ON THE BUT
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IF
YOU'D STEP FOR WITH NAME AND
AFFILIATION PLEASE.
A GOOD MORNING OF A JOURNAL I
HOPE NOT.
IT'S A BEEN A GOOD IT GOOD
AFTERNOON ALMOST GOOD EVENING
APOLOGIES -- CREAM GREASY AND A
HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU SIR.
AND AT THE GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF
EXPEDIA IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
TWENTY LOOK BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF
THE CENTRAL COAST MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATION -- WE OPPOSE FOR
SMALL VACATION RENTAL MANAGERS
WHO HAVE BEEN IN EXISTENCE FOR
DECADES THANK YOU.
BUT SHEPHERD ON BEHALF OF THE
CAL ASIAN CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT LET'S BRING
IT BACK TO THE DíAS THIS IS A
VERY INTERESTING BILL -- CENTER
WHITE HOUSE KEY WILL START WITH
YOU I'M SORRY MADAM CHAIR I WAS
AT THE HOUSING AND I'M NOT SURE
THE STAFF REPORT TALKS ABOUT
SOME.
A CONFUSING LANGUAGE ABOUT
WHETHER IT IT'S THIRTY DAYS AT
THE HOUSE THE PROPERTY CAN BE
RENTED OR THIRTY DAYS AND IT'S
ON THE THE THE HOST SITE HAVE
THOSE WITH THOSE CLOTHES.
IF YOU LOOK AT PAGE TWELVE ITEM
EIGHT THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
THAT THE CLARIFY SAID
AND ONE OF THE OTHER MA'AM AND
ALSO -- MOVES THE SUNSET DATE
TWO THREE YEARS RATHER THAN FIVE
YEARS.
AND THOSE HAVE BEEN ACCEPTED YES.
AND I HAVE A QUESTION OF WHAT IS
A RESIDENTIAL TOURISTS SOUND.
IT'S A IT'S IS ON THAT WE
TYPICALLY HAVE IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY OCEANSIDE HASN'T.
AND SO IT'S AN AREA THAT'S
DESIGNED TO HAVE SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTALS AND SO FOR
EXAMPLE HALF OF THE OCEAN SIDE --
COASTAL ZONE IS IN THE
RESIDENTIAL TOURISM DOWN AND SO
THAT'S WHY WE CAME THE MAYOR OF
OCEANS THAT ASK FOR THAT
AMENDMENT AND WE TOOK OUT OF MY
MEANT -- TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S THAT THAT THAT THAT THAT
AND THAT'S THE MECHANISM FOR THE
OPT OUT PROVISION SO STATE
CREATE A RESIDENT AND TOURISM SO
IN A RESIDENTIAL TOURISM OVERLAY
OVER THERE BECAUSE OF THEIR
OPTED OUT OF THE BILL
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THE GOOD THE OTHER QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
SENATOR DORADO [inaudible]
YES -- I'VE BEEN EXPOSED TO THIS
ISSUE FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS --
PRIMARILY BECAUSE OF THE HOUSING
ISSUES IN LOS ANGELES -- AND
THIS IS A BEEN A VERY VERY --
GOTTEN CONTENTIOUS AT TIMES BUT
I THINK AS WE WE STEP BACK AND
LOOK AT ALL OF THE ELEMENTS THAT
ARE IMPACTING OUR HOUSING STOCK.
JUST HOUSING AVAILABILITY THIS
HAS TO BE.
FACTUALLY SEEN AS A PART.
OF OF THE CAUSE OF HOUSING
SHORTAGE.
NOT THE WHOLE NOT EVERYTHING BUT
A PART OF AND WE CAN'T GO FROM
ONE ROOM TALK ABOUT HOUSING --
STOCKY SHORTAGE AND TO THE
EMERGENCY AND HUSING
AVAILABILITY AND THEN TURN
AROUND AND ALLOW THIS TO
CONTINUE TO TO HAPPEN SO I I
BEEN.
INVOLVED IN THE TOURISM INDUSTRY.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO THE
ECONOMY OF THIS STATE TOURISM
PROVIDES AND CREATES HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF JOBS.
ALL OF THE HOTELS THE MOTELS
EVERYONE WHO HAS INVESTED IN
CREATING THAT PART OF OUR
TOURISM INDUSTRY KNOWS HOW
IMPORTANT THAT IS AND SO ON YOU
KNOW TO SAY THAT THIS IS SOMEHOW
GOING TO PROVIDE.
LOW COST HOUSING -- FOR TOURIST
IS NOT TRUE.
NOT TRUE THERE IN FACT THEIR
RENTED THAT MUCH HIGHER MUCH
HIGHER RATES A BECAUSE THEY'RE
TRYING -- TO YOU KNOW -- TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF PEOPLE COMING IN SO
THIS IS NOT GOING TO ADDRESS.
THE AVAILABILITY OF LOW COST
HOUSING IN THE COASTAL AREA SO I
THINK THIS IS A REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT -- PIECE OF
LEGISLATION TO SUPPORT AND I
APPRECIATE THAT.
YOU HAVE NARROWED IT DOWN AS
MUCH AS YOU HAVE.
I AT THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
DIFFICULT FOR ME TO DO BUT YOU
NARROWED IT DOWN IN SUCH A WAY
THAT IS EXTREMELY REASONABLE AND
FAIR SELF.
I THANK THE AUTHOR AGAIN.
US SENATOR MONNING.
YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR.
FOR TAKING THE AMENDMENTS FOR
THE COMMITTEE'S WORK ON THIS I
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS RAISED
BY THE OPPOSITION IT'S A HUGE
ISSUE IN MY DISTRICT BUT IT'S A
TOURISM DISTRICT.
BUT WE HAVE DIFFERENT CITIES
WITH DIFFERENT ORDINANCES WE
HAVE COASTAL ZONE.
WE HAVE SOME CITIES ALLOWING
KNOW AIRBNB NO SHORT TERM
RENTALS WE HAVE OTHERS TRYING TO
REGULATE IT.
THE FACT THAT THIS WOULD BE A
PILOT PROGRAM I THINK IT COULD
EDUCATE OTHERS OF US IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE STATE HOW WE MOVE
FORWARD.
THERE'S THERE'S NO EASY SOLUTION
TO THIS WE DO KNOW IN MY
DISTRICT.
HOUSING THAT USED TO BE
AVAILABLE TO WORK FORCE. FOR
LEASE AGREEMENTS.
IS NOW OFF THE MARKET AND IT'S
BEING RENTED OUT AT HIGHER RATES
FOR WEEKEND USE ARM.
AND IT'S AFFECTING NEIGHBORHOODS
BUT WE HAVE WORKFORCE NOW
COMMUTING FROM FARTHER AND
FARTHER AWAY FROM THEIR JOBS
BECAUSE WHERE THEY USED TO BE
ABLE TO RENT.
A THREE BEDROOM HOUSE IN BIG SUR
ON A ONE YEAR LEASE.
THAT'S NOW BEING RENTED ON
WEEKENDS FOR AS MUCH AS THEY
WERE PAYING PER MONTH.
BUT THEY'RE DRIVING FROM
WATSONVILLE SALINAS.
LOS BANOS PEOPLE ARE COMMON OVER
THE MOUNTAINS TO THEIR JOBS SO.
LETTING IT GO UNREGULATED I
DON'T THINK IS THE ANSWER -- ALL
BE SUPPORTING THIS TODAY BUT
I'LL BE WATCHING TO LEARN
LESSONS -- THAT CAN HOPEFULLY
INFORMANTS.
IN OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE
THANK YOU [inaudible]
CENTER BORCHERS.
IF IF YOU WANT TO SPEAK JUST LET
ME KNOW BY RAISING HIM OR
SOMETHING I'M MY MENTAL
TELEPATHY SO OF SKILLS -- A
FADING WITH AGE.
BUT MINE AS WELL AND I THANK YOU
HAPPY TO HAVE YOU -- AT THE
PROCEED SORRY I WAS -- WAS THANK
YOU I APPRECIATE THAT AND THERE
BORDERS I'LL HAVE A CONVERSATION
LATER ABOUT HOW TO HANDLE EACH
OTHER'S -- QUESTIONS I SUPPOSE
SO -- JUST A QUICK QUESTION --
ONE OF THE CONCERNS THAT WAS
BROUGHT UP -- WAS INVESTMENT
VALUE OF THE PROPERTIES -- IF
THIS BILL PASSES AND AND THEN
SOME SOME AND THEN ADDITIONAL
CONCERN ON THE THE TERM OF THIS
OF THE I GUESS THE STUDY YOUR
PILOT PROGRAM YOU KNOW THREE
YEARS FIVE YEARS THREE YEARS IN
A LONG ENOUGH. TO GET YOU KNOW
LEARN THE RESULTS THAT WE WANT --
BUT SOMEHOW FIVE YEARS WAS IT
ENDED UP BEING TOO LONG -- THE
TWO QUESTIONS -- ONE AT HOW DO
YOU DRESS FOR THE INVESTORS
ABOUT THESE HOMES FOR THIS AS AN
INVESTMENT VALUE.
AND TO A CAN YOU SPEAK TO THE
LENGTH OF THE PILOT.
YES I I THINK THREE HERE ARE THE
SECOND QUESTION FIRST I THINK
THREE YEARS IS ON THE THE SHORT
END FIVE YEARS WAS ON THE HIGH
END -- BUT YOU KNOW I THINK
THERE WERE THERE WAS A SENTIMENT
OF THREE YEARS IS SUFFICIENT I
THINK WE CAN LOOK AT WHAT
HAPPENS.
WITHIN THREE YEARS I THINK THE
FIRST YEAR OF IMPLEMENTATION
WHAT YOU'RE GONNA SEE IF YOU SEE
THE TRANSITION SO IF YOU'RE TWO
ONE THREE THAT WILL GIVE YOU
ACTUAL DATA.
AND THAT SHOULD BE SUFFICIENT TO
DO REGRESSION ANALYSIS TO GO YOU
KNOW -- ACCOUNT FOR OTHER
FACTORS GOING ON THE MARKET
BECAUSE WHAT WE'RE REALLY GOING
TO BE LOOKING FOR IS WHAT'S THE
EFFECT ON HOUSING AVAILABILITY
WHAT EFFECTS ON LONG TERM RENTS.
AND WE KNOW THIS IS ONE ASPECT
TO IT.
THE SECOND IN TERMS OF
INVESTMENT VALUE I BELIEVE --
THE AIRBNB REPRESENTATIVE IN THE
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY ACTUALLY
TESTIFIED THAT LONG TERM RENTAL --
AMOUNTS ARE ACTUALLY HIGHER THAN
SHORT TERM RENTAL RATES BECAUSE
YOU DON'T RENT OUT SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTALS THE ENTIRE YEAR.
IF I'M IF I'M CORRECT JOHN CAN
CORRECT ME IF I AM INCORRECT BUT
AND THAT'S THE THING IS YOU CAN
GET THAT AND I WOULD WANT TO
ADDRESS WITHOUT THE ECONOMIC
IMPACT WHEN FAMILIES LIVE THEIR
FAMILIES LIVE IN A COMMUNITY.
SO SO I MEAN IF THE METER ON WE
HAVE SHORT TERM VACATION RENTALS
YOU HAVE A TOURISM.
ECONOMY.
BUT WHEN YOU HAVE FAMILIES
LIVING THERE YOU HAVE THE ENTIRE
ECONOMY.
THOSE FOLKS ARE GOING TO
BIRTHDAY PARTIES THEY'RE GOING
TO MUSIC LESSONS THEY'RE GOING
TO YOUR SCHOOLS ARE INVESTING
YOUR PDAS THEIR VESTING NEAR
TOWN COUNCILS ARE INVESTING TIME.
SO THERE'S A MONETARY AND NON
MONETARY COMPONENT OF HAVING
LONG TERM RENTALS -- THAT REALLY
IN RICH CITIES AND IN MANY WAYS
OTHER THAN JUST THE TOURISM
INDUSTRY THAT'S ONE ASPECT AS
YOU KNOW IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY --
THANK YOU AND AND I APPRECIATE --
YOU TAKING THE TIME TO COME --
ME WITH ME PERSONALLY ALLEN AS
WE DISCUSSED.
I AGREE WITH.
A LOT OF YOUR CONCERNS A LOT OF
YOUR CRITICISMS OF OTHER --
GOVERNMENT -- AGENCIES -- I JUST
CAN'T GET THERE TODAY ON THIS
BUT I I I THINK THERE'S SOME
OTHER THINGS THAT WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER ON THAT ARE IMPORTANT.
TO OUR SHARED COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU CAN CENTER CHRONIC YOU
OUT THE TORRENT WILL NEXT UNLESS
THERE WAS A ADDITIONALQUESTION
DO.
I THINK WHAT WAS GOING ON
MANAGER -- APOLOGIZE FOR JUMPING
THE AUTHOR DID MENTION THAT JOHN
MAY HAVE A RESPONSE TO ONE OF
THE COMMENTS AND SHE MADE I
ACTUALLY AM INTERESTED TO HEAR
THE RESPONSE.
THROUGH THE CHAIR PLEASE MAKE
YOU SURE OUR CHURCH JACKSON AYE
THE COMMENT THAT WE MADE IN THE
ACHE IN THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
WAS -- QUOTING FROM US -- BAY
AREA COUNCIL STUDY OF THE MARKET
IN SAN FRANCISCO IT'S PRETTY
MATURE MARKET FOR THESE SORTS OF
THINGS.
AND WHAT THAT STUDY POINTED OUT
IS IF YOU'RE AN INVESTOR AND
YOU'RE BUYING A PROPERTY.
WHAT YOU DO TO MAXIMIZE YOUR
RETURN IS TO RENT IT OUT YEAR
ROUND BECAUSE THE BREAK EVEN
POINT? TO DO IT ON A DAILY BASIS
AS MUCH HIGHER THAN YOU WOULD
EXPECT IT DEPENDS ON THE
NEIGHBORHOODS IN JURISDICTIONS
BUT IN PARTS OF SAN FRANCISCO.
IT'S THREE HUNDRED DAYS TO BREAK
EVEN IN THE MARINA IT'S A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DAYS BASED ON
WHAT.
THEY LOOKED AT SO WE HAVE FOUND
ANECDOTALLY THAT THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE ACTUALLY TAKING
PROPERTIES AND TURNING THEM INTO
EUROPEAN BEES IS GROSSLY
OVERSTATED.
AND WE'VE WORKED WITH LOCAL
COMMUNITIES FINAL TO WORK AGAIN
SAID IT'S AGAINST OUR POLICY TO
SEEK YOU KNOW THE FACTS --
HOTELS CREATED A RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTY WHERE THAT OCCURS WE'VE
WORKED WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
REMOVE THOSE FROM THE SITE SO
THAT'S A A GOAL THAT WE SHARE WE
DON'T THINK THIS BILL GETS
ANYWHERE CLOSE TO ADDRESSING
THAT.
AS I MISSED WHEN YOU OPENED --
EARLIER -- WHO YOU'RE
REPRESENTING?
OKAY THANK YOU.
I RISK MY RESPOND TO THAT PLEASE.
SO SO I THINK THERE'S THERE'S AN
ASPECT OF THAT BUT WE KNOW WE
HAVE ABOUT FIVE THOUSAND SHORT
TERM VACATION RENTALS THAT ARE
FULL TIME.
AND I'M I HAVE ALWAYS SAID IN
EVERY SINGLE COMMITTEE I'VE
TAKEN AMENDMENTS IN EVERY SINGLE
COMMITTEE I AM HAPPY TO WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION.
THEY GET TO THAT PLACE BECAUSE I
AUTHORED THIS BILL ME MYSELF IN
MY LIVING ROOM BROUGHT IT OUT
RIGHT.
WHICH MAY AND GIVE A LITTLE BIT
OF CONTEXT TO IT BUT I'M HAPPY
TO WORK ALL I CARE ABOUT IS THE
REMOVAL OF HOUSING FOR THE
HOUSING MARKET SAN DIEGO COUNTY
CLASSES ON THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS KENTUCKY.
THANK YOU CENTER BORDERS DID YOU
HAVE A QUESTION DID NOT HAVE
QUESTION ALL RIGHT.
VERY INTERESTING ISSUE I'VE USED
AIRBNB AND SAN DIEGO COUNTY --
BROUGHT MY FAMILY THERE I LOVED
IT I THOUGHT IT WAS WONDERFUL
BUT I ALSO SEE.
THAT FOR THOSE THAT A LOT OF
FOLKS -- PARTICULARLY IN COASTAL
AREAS -- ARE USING ARE BUYING UP
PROPERTY FOR AS INVESTMENT AND
RENTING IT OUT AND AND SO IT'S
REMOVING RENTAL STOCK IF YOU
WILL FROM THE MARKET PLACE SO.
I'M KINDA TORN ON THIS I THINK --
IT'S TO BEGIN TO A VERY
INTERESTING CONCEPT THE FACT
THAT YOU'RE WILLING TO TAKE THE
SON SAID IT'S A LITTLE SHORTER
BUTIT DOES STILL GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE WHETHER OR
NOT THIS IS.
A REALLY PROBLEMS SO -- I THANK
YOU FOR THIS -- I I REALLY DO
THINK REASONABLE MINDS CAN
DIFFER ON THIS -- ONE IT'S IN A
IT'S A TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX WHERE
WE HAVE SUCH A HOUSING SHORTAGE.
YOU'VE GOT A ROBUST -- VACATION
AND COASTAL ECONOMY WHICH I CAN
RELATE TO IS SENATOR MINING CAN
I REPRESENT THE COAST OF THE
CENTRAL COAST FROM.
SANTA BARBARA DOWN THROUGH
VENTURA AND A YOU KNOW A GREAT
PLACE TO COME WE INVITE YOU TO
COME IN.
YOU KNOW ENJOY WHAT WE HAVE TO
OFFER BUT I DO THINK THAT WITH
HOW THINGS HOUSING STOCK IT'S
SUCH A PREMIUM NOW THAT THIS IS
CERTAINLY AN INTERESTING IDEA
AND APPRECIATE YOUR BRINGING THE
BILL.
AND IF WITH OUT ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU DID YOU WANT TO MOVE
THE BILL.
MOTION BY SENATOR RUSS SO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO BRIEFLY CLOSE YES
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE BOAT
VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT BELL TO
STOP THE BLEEDING AND HOUSING
FROM HOUSING MARKET AND JUST
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY.
AND THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY HOPEFUL
ACOSTA SOMETHING KQ AND SO THE
MOTION SO THAT WE'RE CLEAR -- IS
TO DO PASS AS AMENDED THE
AMENDMENTS WILL BE -- DO EXCUSE
ME TO PASS WITH THE AGREEMENT
THAT YOU WILL TAKE THE
AMENDMENTS IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE
SO THIS IS A SIMPLE DO PASS. TO
SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES AND
WATER WERE THOSE MOMENTS WILL BE
TAKEN.
AND WITH SAP THANK YOU AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR THE DISCUSSION --
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE JACKSON HI
JACKSON AYE BORDERS.
BORDERS NO DRAW SO.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
JONES.
JONES NO MONNING MONNING AYE
STERN.
STERN I BURKE LIKE HEALTHY.
NUMBER I WHY BECAUSE HE AYE
RIGHT BEFORE -- ANYBODY LEAVES I
APPARENTLY CLOSE TO ROLL EARLIER
SO WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL
RECONSIDER THE VOTE ON BILL --
NUMBER AB SIX TWENTY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MADAM COMMITTEE ASSISTANT IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WE'VE
GOT TO DO THAT ITEM OVER AGAIN
I'D INADVERTENTLY CLOSE TOMORROW.
YES WE DO WITHOUT.
CORRECT I'M SORRY SO OF WITH SO
THE VOTE IT WITHOUT OBJECTION IS
ON RECONSIDERATION TO OPEN THE
ROLE.
EXCELLENT ALL RIGHT SO -- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE MOTION TO RECONSIDER AB.
SIX TWENTY JACKSON HI JACKSON
AYE BORDERS WERE JUST AYE TO
RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
JONES JONES I'M MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN STERN I BURKE
NUMBER I WHITE HOUSE E..
I KELSEY I ALRIGHT THE MOTION TO
RECONSIDER IS GRANTED AND NOW WE
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ON THAT ITEM SO THAT WE CAN AND
THOSE WHO VOTED CAN LEAVE SO
FILE ITEM FIVE AB SIX TWENTY WE
ARE -- ON A MOTION BY SENATOR
MONNING.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS.
AND A AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL JACKSON HI JACKSON AYE
ABORTIONS.
BORDERS I DO RUSSELL RUSSELL I
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I JONES JONES
I MONEY.
MONEY AYE STERN STERN I AM BURKE
UMBERG I WAKE HEALTHY.
WEIGHT HUSKY I NINE TWO ZERO
THAT BILL IS OFFICIALLY
APPROPRIATELY NOW OUT.
ALL RIGHT MOVING -- TO I HAVE AN
UPSET YET I'M SORRY ON BURNER --
BURNER FOR FAST -- THE VOTE
COUNT.
WAS SEVENTY TWO THAT BILL IS OUT.
MOVING NOW BACK TO FILE ITEM
WOMAN.
I WILL GET OVER THE ROLE ONE
TIME FOR THOSE WHO HAVEN'T VOTED
[inaudible]
CALENDAR.
OF WILL START WITH THE CONSENT
THE CONSENT CALENDAR THE VOTE
COUNT IS SIX TWO ZERO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR RUSSELL.
BUT ALSO I JONES.
JONES I Y. CASKEY.
RIGHT HEALTHY I NINE TWO ZERO
THE CONSENT CALENDARS OUT.
FILE ITEM ONE A. B. SEVENTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS THE VOTE
COUNT IS SIX TO ONE PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I LIKE HELL SKI.
I CASKEY AYE BROKEN IS EIGHT TWO
ONE THAT BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM
TO AB THREE THIRTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL THE VOTE COUNT IS
SIX TO ZERO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS OR JUST
[inaudible]
JONES.
MY CAL SKI.
MICHAEL SKI I SEVEN TWO ZERO
THAT BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM.
OF THE SIX AB SIXTY SEVENTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN THE VOTE
COUNT IS. EIGHT TWO ZERO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
I'M BURKE.
NUMBER HI NINE TWO ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM TEN AB
ELEVEN TEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN THE VOTE COUNTY. SIXTY
TWO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS I'M BURKE [inaudible]
NUMBER I SEVENTY TWO THAT BILL
IS OUT FILE ITEM TWELVE AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OBERNOLTE THE VOTE COUNT
IS A TWO ZERO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS OF BURKE.
NUMBER FIVE NINE TWO ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM FIFTEEN A.
B. FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA THE VOTE
COUNT IS SIXTY TWO PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
WHITE HOUSE SKI.
MY COUNTY I SEVENTY TWO THAT
BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM SIXTEEN AB
FIFTEEN TEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RADIUS THE VOTE COUNT IS FORTY
ZERO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS GORGEOUS -- RUSSELL
RUSSELL I JONES.
I'M BURKE UMBERG HIGHWAY CASKEY
MICHALSKI I SIX SEVEN TWO ZERO
THAT BILL IS OUT AND I BELIEVE.
WE ARE GOOD -- ALL BILLS ARE
ACCOUNTED FOR AND WE ARE
ADJOURNED THANK YOU TO THE STAFF
GREAT JOB.
THANK YOU TO OUR MEMBERS